So, jetzt sind wir da, jetzt haben wir es geschafft, Leute. Wir sind on air. Ja, Freude. Das war einfach ein dummer Versuch, damit wir hier mal ein bisschen einen kleinen mentalen Break rein kriegen.
Ich bin auf mental gebrochen.
Das war jetzt nicht der Ideale, da muss ich noch mal dran arbeiten. Aber ich denke, es ist ganz wichtig, dass wir hier einen mentalen Break hinkriegen.
Kann das sein, dass mich...
Wir können dann mal hier die Vorhänge zu machen. Wie sich das gehört, hier bei Mobile Max, Ausgabe Nummer 41.
Oh, die nächste Ausgabe ist ja die große Ausgabe dann quasi.
Die nächste Ausgabe ist die große Ausgabe, da müssen wir dann mal wirklich alle pünktlich kommen. Und dann...
Was willst du damit andeuten?
Gar nichts, Dennis.
Gut.
Sowas würde mir einfach überhaupt nicht auch nur in den Sinn kommen.
Nicht, dass unsere zugreiffeilten Gedanken kommen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das wollen wir ja natürlich gar nicht. Ja, jetzt...
Wer weiß, ob die alle pünktlich kommen.
Haben wir auf jeden Fall eine aufregende Woche hinter uns gehabt, sodass wir uns nicht mit langweiligen News rumgeschlagen müssen. Es ist endlich raus.
Microsoft Pink.
Microsoft Pink?
Ja, das wollte ich... An dem Tag, an dem die erste Keynote kam, hat irgendjemand berichtet, dass Microsoft weitere Details über Project Pink rausgegeben hat. Ich hab's nicht mal durchgelesen.
Ernsthaft?
Die Vision Software auf dem Windows-Mobile.
Das ist nicht dieses Projekt, das IBM mit Apple schon mal hatte vor 20 Jahren.
Ja, gescheiterte Projekte scheinen Pink zu heißen.
Gescheiterte Projekte haben wir glücklich von Microsoft aufgenommen. Ob des guten Omens.
Reverse-engineert.
Wobei, Microsoft gehts wohl ganz gut.
Sie haben ein komplett Betriebssystem.
Die haben ordentlich Gewinn eingefahren. Die haben 6,7 Milliarden Dollar Gewinn gemacht in diesem Quartal. Das ist absurd.
Windows 7 läuft total gut.
Na gut, jetzt haben sie alle lange noch gewartet. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich hab die Quartalzahlen von Microsoft nicht in dem Maße studiert, wie jetzt die Quartalzahlen von Apple und auch die hab ich nicht wirklich studiert, weil ich war etwas durcheinander und verwirrt.
Das ist auch nicht mehr spannend, oder? Ich meine, das ist immer Plus. Früher war es ab und zu nur noch, oh, das ist Plus, das ist minus, wie viel Minus ist es? Und jetzt ist es so, naja, ein paar Milliarden, okay.
Ja gut, so kann man das natürlich auch sehen. Andererseits war das schon erstaunlich, wie sie so grundsätzlich ihre Linie gehalten haben. Also vor allem, also letztes Jahr war es ja so...
Läuft die Sendung jetzt schon so richtig?
Ja, ja, ja, das ist alles ernst jetzt. Das ist alles kein Spaß mehr.
Also müssen wir uns jetzt wieder verstellen.
Ja, ich meine, wir können uns natürlich nochmal rückversichern, dass wir jetzt auch gehört werden. Aber eigentlich sollte dem so sein, ne?
Wir werden gehört.
Wir werden gehört, genau. Zahlen interessieren keine Sau. Das stimmt nicht. Mich interessiert das nämlich. Und es gab so einige Zahlen, die ich daran doch sehr erstaunlich fand. Also mit diesem ganzen Umsatz und so, da würde ich jetzt gerne drüber abreven. Allerdings bin ich total verwirrt dadurch, dass diese... Ihr erinnert euch, es gab doch da diese Geschichte mit diesem Subscription-based-Abrechnung.
Subscription, dass die iPhone-Einnahmen über zwei Jahre gestreckt haben, weil sie ja zwei Jahre sich von AT&T haben Kohle geben lassen. Und das haben sie auch erst eingeführt für das Einfach. Das hatten die ja vorher nicht. Weil die auch vorher so eine Produkte gar nicht hatten. Oder hatten sie? Nee, hatten sie nicht. Aber jetzt haben sie es wieder abgeschafft.
Genau. Also die Amerikaner haben das irgendwie abgeschafft. Und ich weiß aber jetzt nicht genau, was das jetzt bedeutet. Haben die jetzt zurückwirkend irgendwie alles andere angepasst? Also werden jetzt auch die ganzen letzten Quartale dann statistisch nochmal anders...
Da hättest du das Kleingedruckte unter der Apple-Presse-Meldung gelesen.
Ja und vor allem, was ist mit dem, was bisher sozusagen über die Quartale verteilt werden sollte? Ist das jetzt alles drin oder wird das halt weiter verteilt? Und nur das, was jetzt dieses Mal dazu kam? Also das lässt diese ganzen Zahlen so ein bisschen merkwürdig erscheinen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es so schlecht nicht gelaufen. Und sie haben...
Wie ist es nicht so schlecht gelaufen?
Na, ist nicht so schlecht gelaufen.
Best Quartal ever, würde Steve sagen.
Na ja, gut, ich mein, das ist ja auch...
Amazing!
Das ist ja auch nötig, dass sie auch noch die nächsten fünf Jahre ihr Best Quartal ever machen, damit sie endlich mal da hinkommen, wo sie hingehören. Na, zumindest nicht in diesen 5% Marktanteil, Klim Bim.
Ich find das gar nicht schlimm.
Na ja, gut, vielleicht findest du es nicht schlimm, aber...
Der Elite kann halt nicht so groß sein.
Vergiss es, Elite. Wir sind jetzt hier voll im Konsumermarkt angekommen.
Hab ich schon gemerkt, jeder Idiot rennt halt immer mit dem iPhone rum. Ist voll peinlich. Ich brauch was anderes.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich überlege mir...
Ich finde das nächste neue Top-iPhone-Modell braucht irgendwie eine andere Farbe, so braun oder blau. Damit ich das neue iPhone habe, damit ich das neue iPhone habe, ich anders aussehe als der Rest. Weil es sehen ja alle so aus. Ich meine bis auf das erste iPhone. Die sind schon wieder cool, weil die hat halt keiner mehr.
Findest du?
Ja klar, man braucht doch Individualität. Wir können doch nicht alle Uniform aussehen.
Naja, ich meine du kannst ja wieder anfangen mit Floppy Disk rumzurennen.
Mach ich gerade.
Wirklich?
Weil ich gerade PC Floppy Disk mit dem Admin auslese.
Ernsthaft?
Das ist total Lead. Auf Sub-Ebene mit MFM irgendwie Amiga-Disc-Ketten auslesen.
Wir halten fest, denn das ist total Lead. Wir müssen uns jetzt noch was einfallen lassen.
Aber ich muss kurz intervenieren. Ich weiß warum die Sendung gerade so ein bisschen komisch gestartet ist, weil wir haben uns gar nicht vorgestellt.
Das stimmt.
Das fehlt nämlich irgendwie.
Mach du das doch mal heute.
Also hier ist jetzt wieder Mobile-Max-Sendung 41. Das hatten wir jetzt schon. Und zu meiner rechten hier sitzt Tim Prittlaff. Hallo. Hallo, genau. Zu meiner linken wie immer Max...
Hallo. Winde heiß ich.
Genau. Grundig wollte ich gerade sagen, ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Grundig?
Max Grundig ist auch gut. Klingt so nach Firmengründer.
Und hier in der Mitte, so in mir sozusagen, sitzt Dennis.
Er lässt sich wie immer nicht aus der Ruhe bringen. Das ist auch sehr angemessen, weil heute muss man ja hier noch so ein bisschen streiten und bewerten. Was ist denn nun alles auf sich hat? Wollen wir noch länger über den heißen Brei drum herum reden oder wollen wir gleich zum Thema kommen? Also es ist da. Es ist da. Sie haben es endlich auf den Tisch gelegt. Und ich frage mich ernsthaft, was das psychologisch jetzt einfach bedeutet für die Welt, was sollen sie jetzt voraussagen?
Die Welt.
Ja, das Tablett ist da.
Jetzt kommt was. Jetzt kommt ein iPhone S4.
Wollen wir uns gleich auf so eine Rollen festlegen? Also ich würde gerne den Bat-Cop spielen.
Jaja, das ist das. Das war auch die Idee.
Ich wollte auch mal was anderes machen.
Okay, und ich bin skeptisch.
Du bist skeptisch.
Aber nicht sehr.
Okay, also Max macht den Plus, ich mach den Minus und du machst die Null.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, wir fangen erstmal an, dass wir vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen die Fakten niedergeben, weil es kann ja sein, dass... Also wir sollten auf jeden Fall erstmal sagen, worüber wir reden.
Wir können schon die Fakten wiederholen, weil wir haben natürlich viel mehr Infos als da verbreitet worden, ist ja klar.
Stimmt, unser ganzes Insiderwissen.
Ja, und auch halt unsere Erfahrungen.
Du bist wahrscheinlich auch deshalb so spät gekommen, weil du wieder ein bisschen die Nacht mit Steve gesoffen hast.
Nee, der konnte diesmal nicht nur viel Kram.
Okay, also was haben wir gekriegt? Er hatte relativ, muss man sagen, seine Suspense. Weißt du, was Suspense ist? Suspense ist ein Begriff, den...
Das hat Hitchcock schon erklärt.
Genau.
Suspense ist, wenn du weißt, dass die Bombe unterm Tisch liegt. Und nicht, wenn sie plötzlich hochgeht.
Genau, das ist irgendwie so... Hitchcock hat zum Beispiel bei Psycho hat er so eine kleine Glühlampe in das Milchglas reingetan, was irgendwie der... Welches Milchglas? Was er da irgendwie durchs Haus getragen hat. Es gab da so eine Szene mit Milchglas. Dann hat er so eine Glühbirne reingetan. Dann hab ich gelüte einfach diese Milch so ein bisschen. Das sind alles so kleine Elemente. Und irgendwie fand ich das dann da... Von daher fand ich die Kino schon mal so ein bisschen enttäuschend. Ja, und wir haben dann ja was in die Mitte gebaut. Und wir nennen es iPad. Da dachte ich mir so, ja super. Hättest du da schon ein bisschen mehr drum herum schwurbeln können. Ich meine, iPhone, was hat er da für ein Fass aufgemacht? Wir haben drei Produkte!
Warte, das ist schon ein bisschen fies, weil als du die Kino gesehen hast, da wusstest du ja schon, dass das iPad rauskommt. Die Leute, die da gesessen haben, die wussten das noch nicht so richtig wirklich.
Was, woher wusste ich das? Das ist, wieso?
Na, durch die Live-Ticker vorher.
Ich hab nichts gelesen. Ich bin um 19 Uhr...
Du hast nicht...
Um die Kino zu lesen, hast du auf die Webseite geklickt und da war es doch schon.
Ich bin um 19 Uhr ins Bett gegangen. Ich war scheiße müde. Ich bin ins Bett gegangen, ich hab die ganze Nacht geschlafen und ich bin morgens um 5 Uhr aufgewacht. Rauscht! Und hab mir dann irgendwie... Ich hatte mir vorher noch diese Macromos-Seite gebookmarkt mit irgendwie Spoiler Freed, und ich war eigentlich komplett frei. Ich hab bloß den Fehler gemacht, noch irgendwie meinen Java-Client einmal anzutickern, wo mir dann gleich irgendwie so ein verräterischer Kommentar von jemandem entgegenspulte, aus dem ich zumindest schon mal herauslesen konnte, dass es iPad heißt. Keine neuen MacBooks waren.
Ja, für die Leute, die da gesessen haben, die wussten schon, was wird jetzt kommen.
Hast du den Podcast runtergeladen?
Nee, ich hab mir den Stream angeschaut. Und dann von wegen Spoiler Free, dann hat diese MacRumors-Seite schon mal gesagt, dass das iPad angekündigt wurde. Hier könnte man sich das jetzt angucken. Und ich glaub auch Apples Seite, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob das noch...
War direkt auf der Frontpage.
Okay, also ich wusste zumindest, dass es so heißt. Drauf, geschissen.
Er hat es ja erst schon eine Weile lang nicht verraten. Hat er gesagt, hier auch Netbooks aren't good at anything.
Das war eine extrem nachvollziehbare Aussage, fand ich. Das fand ich gut. Also so gehört sich das auch. Ich werd hier mal die Keynote auch mal kurz hier auf diesen anderen Rechner werfen, dann können wir da vielleicht noch mal gucken. Und... Ja, was haben wir jetzt gekriegt? Also wir haben ein Gerät bekommen, was den Namen Tablett sicherlich... Nee, man kann sich dem auch sehr schwer nähern, finde ich. Und ich finde, darüber sollten wir aber als erstes reden. Also was haben wir bekommen? Wir haben ein Gerät, was wahrscheinlich... Wir haben es ja alle nicht in der Hand gehabt. Ach, scheiße, ich hab mir einen Prototypen gebaut. Den hab ich jetzt gar nicht mitgebracht. Du hast einen Prototypen gebaut, wie geil!
Du hast das PDF ausgedruckt.
Am Schluss auch, da hatte ich den schon gebaut, dann kam irgendwie dieses PDF noch dazu, dann hab ich das auch noch gemacht, das müsste ich jetzt eigentlich ja noch holen.
Ja, hol das mal rasch. Halten wir das so lange irgendwie überall über Wasser?
Ich frag jetzt, ob wir das schaffen?
Nicht, dass du jetzt die ganze Zeit...
Dann weiß ich ja nicht, worüber wir hier gerettet haben. Dann müsste ich ja jetzt sozusagen...
Einfach in der Werbepause.
Wir können das ja so machen. Ich, ähm...
Du willst ja jetzt was holen, was die Hörer nicht sehen können?
Was? Nein, wir machen das jetzt einfach ganz modern. Ich muss jetzt sozusagen dieses Teil holen, aber ich will natürlich an der Sendung weiter teilnehmen. Was mache ich also? Na?
Du schickst einfach deiner Freundin los, dass die das holt.
Nein.
Achso, wäre natürlich auch eine Option.
Nein. Na, denk mal nach.
Du packst uns jetzt auf dein iPhone drauf, lenkst dich in den Streamer ein.
So sieht's aus. Das werde ich nämlich jetzt tun.
Dann müssen wir jetzt weitererzählen.
Dann müssen wir jetzt gleich weitererzählen, während Tim hier das Ding klart.
Ich bin das ein totaler Control-Freak, weißt du?
Ja, ja, das ist die Axt, die er dann so nicht erzielen könnte.
Ja, schneller ist ja hier nicht der entscheidende Punkt, ne?
Also du findest das scheiße, ja?
Das hab ich nicht gesagt.
Du wolltest Bettkopfspiel, komm!
Ja, das schon. Also ich würd mir zum Beispiel erst mal keins kaufen.
Du würdest nicht keins kaufen? Ich überleg nur noch, welches Modell.
Das wüsste ich schon, das größte natürlich. Da wollt ich nicht überlegen, aber ich brauche erst mal so ein Ding nicht.
Brauchen? Brauchen wir sowas? Das ist ja die deutsche Antwort. Braucht man das?
Ja, na das ist ein cooles Spielzeug, ist es ja unbestritten.
Das ist viel mehr als ein cooles Spielzeug.
Ja klar, und zwar ist es ein neuer State of Computing.
Eben, genau das ist es.
Ihr seid euch ja einig. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist genau das perfekte Rät für meine Mutter.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Und meine Oma, vielleicht nicht mehr ganz. Aber für Leute, die keinen Plan haben und haben wollen, und ich finde auch, Leute müssen keinen Plan haben. Also von Tools, die muss man, also die müssen sich mir anpassen und ich muss mich nicht meinen Tools anpassen.
Genau so sieht es aus. Wir sind uns doch ja einig. Das ist ja total egal.
Naja, aber, erstens, für dich ist nichts. Na, kommt drauf an, was denn so für Programmchen kommen, aber am Ende brauche ich schon. Ich brauche halt ab und zu mal eine Shell und so dieses ganze kleine Schnickelkram, den man halt so hat, der geht halt mit dem Ding nicht.
Dass du da für deinen Mac nicht verklopst, das ist ja nun, also um das Ding zu holen, das steht ja komplett außer Frage.
Aber wo sollte ich denn das iPad einsetzen, wo ich dann nicht sowieso mein Laptop mitnehmen würde? In Urlaub. Okay, aber nur für Urlaub würde ich mir nicht so ein Ding holen.
Also ich glaube, ich habe einige Einsatzzwecke gehabt, wo ich mit dem iPhone da saß und dachte, dass diese Anwendung jetzt auf einem größeren Display ist.
Das wäre schon klar. Aber dann überlege ich auch, hätte ich jetzt in dieser Party hier irgendwie mit den 100 Leuten in den engen Raum, wo alle schwitzen, hätte ich jetzt da mein iPad bei?
Aber ich meine einfach von der Bedienung her, diese Fingerbedienung und sowas, das auf einem großen Display zu haben, das ist einfach der totale Hammer. Das ist, also was da an Applikationen möglich wird.
Ja, klar, aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mein Laptop mitschleppe, das ist ja auch gar nicht so viel größer.
Na doch, schon noch einiges.
Ja, aber das iPad passt nicht in deine Hosentasche.
Du brauchst irgendwie eine Tasche, eine große.
Und in diese Tasche kann ich auch gleich mein Laptop reinmachen.
Das stimmt, aber es kann ja viele Dinge, die dein Laptop gar nicht kann.
Zum Beispiel?
Du kannst zum Beispiel so mit dem Finger drauf, also Touchscreen.
Das ist wirklich allerdings cool, weil das ist der entscheidende Feature. Die Leute, also wie meine Mama, die muss nicht lernen, was irgendwie Shift ist. Okay, Shift kann auch eine Sekretärin mit Großbuchstaben, das geht schon mit Tastatur. Aber alles, Apfel, Kontrolle und alles so ein komisches Zeug, irgendwelche Spezialtasten, muss ja alles nicht mehr können, sondern wenn so was sieht, tippt sie drauf. Wenn da nichts passiert, dann geht es halt irgendwie auch nicht.
Braucht auch kein Virenscanner oder sowas oder kein Schick. Eigentlich sieht es mehr aus, als ob ein Schlag mich aufmachen hätte.
Das hat tatsächlich funktioniert. Ich bin jetzt wirklich einmal über die Straße rüber gelaufen und kurz nach dem Arsch eine Marke geholt. War ich weg? Na ja, ihr habt euch irgendwie über eure Omas gestritten. Also, was ich hier gebaut habe, ist dicker. Das hab ich irgendwie nicht besser hinbekommen. Ich dachte, mit Papier könnte ich irgendwie das Gewicht ausreichen simulieren. Und tatsächlich hab ich nämlich angefangen, das Ganze zu bauen, als mir aufgefallen ist, dass das Ding in etwa so groß ist.
Du bist ja schon noch so ein richtiger Fanboy. Das sieht aus, als wenn sein Junior was aus dem Kindergarten mitgebracht hat.
Ich kann das ja mal twitpicken.
Wobei die Kinder es bunter hinkriegen. Aber den schwarzen Rahmen hat er schick gemacht. Ich will auch eine. Das wiegt jetzt wirklich genau 690 Gramm.
Das wiegt exakt 730 Gramm. Die UMTS-Version wollte ich natürlich haben. Naja, was heißt Fanboy? Ich wollte, es war absehbar, dass ich kein Gerät hier bis zu dieser Sendung hinbekomme. Und wenn ich irgendwas für wirklich wichtig empfand, dann war es sozusagen diese Bewertung, wie denn dieses Gerät wohl in der Hand liegt. Das ist schon für mich das Teil so. Ich hätte nicht angefangen, hätte nicht rein zufällig der aktuelle IKEA-Katalog vor mir gelegen. Und ich habe festgestellt, dass der IKEA-Katalog so ziemlich genau so groß ist wie das iPad. Er ist nicht ganz so hoch, er hat exakt dieselbe Breite und er gibt die Dicke so in etwa schon mal vor. Allerdings hat er nicht das richtige Gewicht, sodass ich dann halt noch ein bisschen was dazu machen musste.
Ist der IKEA-Katalog zu leicht oder zu schwer?
Und es ist jetzt auch genau die Größe, ja?
Es ist exakt die Größe, aber er ist dicker. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher. Wir können es gleich nochmal nachmessen. Ja, ich glaube, die Seitendicke stimmt. Und dann habe ich hinten noch so viel Papier reingemacht, bis es das richtige Gewicht hatte. Und dann war das dann irgendwann so ein bisschen zu dick. Wenn man das so ignoriert. Ihr könnt ja hier mal kurz ein bisschen Licht an hier. Kannst du nachmessen. Dann kannst du auch nochmal Licht anmachen.
Wie dicke oder jetzt die Breite?
Die Breite stimmt. Das ist alles richtig. Der Rahmen und so weiter.
Die Tiefe ist schon ein bisschen mehr, aber das macht jetzt erstmal nichts zu gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sehr ich mich jetzt vertan habe.
Aber jetzt mal so eine Stunde hier so halten, damit ich ein Video gucken kann.
Du hast gerade den IKEA-Katalog zu neuesten in so einer Popularität verholfen.
Aber wenn der mal so touch-sensitiv wäre, wie das iPad, das wär was. Ich meine, den IKEA-Katalog auf dem iPad, da hätte ich Bock drauf.
Das war doch so eine Fake-Applikation, wie das Tablet unter Umständen aussehen könnte. Und da hatten sie doch ein IKEA-Katalog drauf.
Richtig, richtig, richtig. Darauf hatte ich mich jetzt gar nicht bezogen. So, jetzt gib mal her das Teil, jetzt mach ich hier mal für unsere Hörer mal ein Foto von meinem Prototypen.
Ja, das bringt aber, ich meine, es gibt genug Fotos vom Original.
Ja, was denn Original? Es geht ja darum, dass die Hörer müssen sich ja auch auf das synchronisieren, worauf wir uns jetzt synchronisieren.
Das ist überhaupt das ganze Netz.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das iPad so viel Gaffa Tape dran hat.
Warte mal, das glänzt. So glänzt es immer noch. Da sieht man aber auch, wie ich es gebaut habe. Das dauert auch schon mal was. So, aber jetzt ist es irgendwie ein bisschen zu... Warum muss ich auch immer so ein...
Wir können ja noch ein bisschen weiter labern.
Wir können ja weiter noch über unsere Omas erzählen.
Oder habt ihr auch schon eine Liste? Es gibt da ein bisschen mehr zu labern, wo ihr auch einfach gleich so loslegen wollt.
Ich habe hier so eine Wave angelegt, wo so ein bisschen was dran ist. Dann kannst du ja mal so ein bisschen mit reinhängen.
Mal gucken, ob ich mein Passwort finde.
So, jetzt habe ich hier mal ein Foto gemacht.
Hast du noch eine Ahnung, was wir das letzte Mal vor der Zeit haben so alles?
Ich kann ja sogar noch den Mobile Max-Aufkleber noch mit ins Bild bringen.
Ich habe ja noch Tipps gegeben, was das Ding haben wird.
Genau, das Original. Das Original Mobile Max iPad.
Das sind die 10 Gründe, warum das iPad doch nicht floppen wird. Weil es einfach mal ein verdammt geiles Gerät ist.
Die müssen wir wirklich durchgehen, weil so viel Quatsch.
Das sind die 10 Gründe, warum das iPad doch nicht floppen wird.
Doch nicht?
Doch nicht, ja. Wieder erwarten. Was ich schon hatte, war eine Liste mit 11 Dinge.
Ja, das ist geil.
11 Dinge, die dem iPad das Genick brechen werden.
Ja, also so ein Fail. Ich habe schon lange nicht mehr so einen Kloppen-Post gelesen.
Kein Multitasking, wie das iPhone. Ich finde es geil, das wird total untergehen, wie das iPhone das erfolgreichste Telefon ist.
Wie das iPhone auch schon untergegangen ist.
Wie das iPhone auch schon untergegangen ist, weil es kein Multitasking hatte.
Das bedeutet, man hat ein Tablet-PC mit der Rechenleistung eines Netbooks in der Hand und kann während des Internetsurfens kein Facebook-Client nutzen, oder kein Radio-App. Stimmt, aber das ist voll toll. Aber es wird kein Licht aus dem Knick brechen. Keine Kamera, das ist definitiv ein Totschlagargument.
Na ja, sie schreiben nicht, was sie meinen. Ob sie eine Fotokamera oder eine Videokamera meinen.
Na ja, aber ich meine, wofür braucht man eine Kamera?
Na ja, da sind wir jetzt wieder bei diesem Oma-Ding. Ich hab viel über diesen Oma-Aspekt nachgedacht. Omas und Videotelefonie, das geht hervorragend zusammen. Und wenn du jetzt sozusagen Oma etwas gibst, womit Videotelefonie nicht möglich ist, dann ist doch ein Laptop vielleicht die bessere Wahl. Also das ist definitiv so ein Punkt, weil gerade so diese Fernfamilienpflege, da ist Videochat ein echtes Ding.
Das stimmt, das ist das.
Das darf man nicht und weglassen. Und ich kann auch gleich meinen anderen grundsätzlichen Kritikpunkt vielleicht auch mal vorneweg stellen. Ich habe jetzt wirklich viel darüber nachgedacht und es gibt einiges, was ich ganz großartig finde an diesem iPad. Aber was mich stört und zumindest meine Wahrnehmung, so wie sie es jetzt angekündigt haben, dieses Teil ist in seinem Wesen immer noch ein iPod oder ein iPhone in der Art und Weise, wie es sich zu dem Macintosh verhält. Oder anders ausgedrückt, es kann nicht wie ein MacBook verwendet werden.
Es ist kein alleinstehendes Gerät.
Es kann kein iPhone damit sünden, sondern es sündet selbst wie ein iPhone mit einem Rechner.
Ja, das ist ein Problem, das du ganz dringend lösen musst.
Genau, und du kannst nämlich diesen Computer, dieses iPad, gar nicht als einzigen Computer verwenden.
Wieso nicht?
Na, wie willst du denn davon einen Backup machen zum Beispiel? Du kannst von diesem Computer keinen Backup machen.
Na okay, aber wenn man auf sowas verzichten kann, dann kann man...
Auf einen Backup willst du verzichten?
Ich möchte nicht auf einen Backup verzichten, aber ich meine, wie viele Leute kennst du, die an ihrem normalen Computer keinen Backup haben? Also ich gebe zu, ich sage nicht, dass es eine gute Lösung ist, aber ich glaube, das wird niemand davon abhalten, dass iPad im Zweifel... Also Menschen, die sich einen iPad als einzigen Computer holen, die scheren sich auch nicht sonderlich viel im Backup. Das behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal.
Na, ob sich die Leute jetzt drum scheren oder ob ich den richtigen Computer kaufe, das ist das eine, ja. Ich meine, da kommen dann auch die ganzen Fotos drauf. Ja, du kannst ja deine Kamera anschließen, das kann das Ding ja leisten. Das heißt, du kannst irgendwie so dein Digital Life, also anders ausgedrückt. Der Mac wurde vor einigen Jahren von Steve Jobs sehr richtig, wie ich finde, als Digital Hub präsentiert. Jetzt kommt das iPad und positioniert sich unterm Strich als eine neue Generation von Computer, die ganz andere Leute auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise anspricht. Deswegen sind die Geeks auch alle so jetzt am schreien. Oh, es ist ja nicht wie mein anderer Computer und wie hätte ich denn in meinem Leben Programmierer werden sollen, wenn ich so einen Computer bekommen hätte und so. Ja, nicht wie die meisten Leute. Die meisten Leute werden nämlich keine Programmierer. Ich würde sogar sagen, wenn du ein Programmierer geworden bist, wenn es dir vorbestimmt war, ein Programmierer zu werden, dann hätte dich dieses Gerät davon auch nicht abhalten dürfen. Sonst kannst du eigentlich jetzt sofort deinen Job wieder wechseln, wie hättest werden sollen.
Diesen Kritikpunkt, den du hast, den hab ich übertragen an einer anderen Stelle. Und zwar wurde das Wort Drucken nicht erwähnt. Ist es möglich, von einem iPad aus einen Drucker anzusprechen?
Stand da irgendwo.
Also es gibt zwei Berichte.
Wäre ja auch blöd, wenn nicht. Also ich meine, TV-Lan, Bluetooth.
Na es gibt in iPhone OS 3.2, soweit ich das bisher mitbekommen habe, noch keine Druckfunktion. Es gibt zwar die Möglichkeit, für Programme jetzt PDFs zu erzeugen, was vorher nicht ging. Was sozusagen schon mal eine Vorstufe sein könnte. Dann gab es allerdings auf Apple Insider einen weiteren Bericht, der sich so auf Gespräche on the Floor bezogen hat, was insbesondere Business-User betrifft und so. Und da fiel dann das Wort Drucken sehr wohl. Ich denke auch, dass das etwas ist, was wir mit iPhone OS 4.0 sehen werden. Und ich denke auch, dass dieses 3.2 wirklich nur eine ganz kurze Phase des Übergangs darstellt.
Das wird nur da sein.
Das kann sogar sein, dass das nur für iPhone zum Anpassen ist. Bis es wirklich rauskommt, dass die Programmierer jetzt etwas zum Spielen haben. Sie haben jetzt alles eingebaut, damit die Programmierer ihre Programme anpassen können, sprich die neuen User-Interface-Elemente, beim iPad diese Popovers vor allem, und natürlich die größere Auflösung und das ganze Paradigma, was damit verbunden ist, plus, ich glaube, ein paar neue Gesten im Wesentlichen sind dazugekommen. Und natürlich all das, was jetzt auch von Apple selbst mit den neuen Applikationen dort vorgezeigt wird, insbesondere iWork. Das ist das, woran die sich jetzt erst mal setzen sollen. Das wäre sozusagen eigentlich meine Anforderung an dieses Gerät. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was sie eigentlich herstellen könnten. Nur macht es auf mich gerade den Eindruck, vielleicht habt ihr ja einen anderen Eindruck, dass das noch nicht so ist. Also wenn ich jetzt diesen iPad nehme, kann ich keinen Backup davon machen. Und es ist auch so ein bisschen unklar, wie ich die Daten da sozusagen, ja, also generell, wie kriege ich die Daten da wieder raus? Und kann dieses Gerät überhaupt für sich alles tun? Und ich kann Musik damit kaufen?
Ja, das kannst du schon sehr viel. Also du kannst mit einem iPhone schon extrem viel.
Aber wenn ich schon einen iTunes-Account habe und ich habe schon Musik gekauft, kann ich die da wieder runterladen?
Na ja, dann hast du ja auch iTunes. Dann hast du ja auch einen Computer und hast iTunes. Und dann kannst du auch Synch.
Vielleicht hast du aber keinen Computer und ein iTunes, aber vielleicht hast du das nur für dein iPhone gekauft.
Den iTunes-Account. Also ich glaube, dass du das...
Ja, aber wenn du schon Musik hast...
Dieses Synchen bzw. Backupen ist ja fast... Oder du willst der Oma Musik geben.
Du willst der Oma Musik geben, die sie auf diesem Computer dann hat. Wie kriegst du die da drauf?
Schickst dir einen Link zum iTunes Store, das sollst du nicht kaufen.
Was heißt per Mail? Du kannst nicht per Mail Musik empfangen auf einem iPhone-Gerät und es dann in deine Musik reintun. Also du bist quasi gezwungen, eine Mac zu haben, um Musik zu machen, obwohl du auf dem Teil... Ja, du kannst da zwar Musik kaufen. Ja gut, aber ich meine, die Frage, ist das jetzt ein Computer für meine Oma, stellt sich da gar nicht, weil ich Oma sowieso noch einen Computer dazukaufen muss, damit sie den überhaupt benutzen kann. Oder sie muss halt regelmäßig nach Hause zu uns kommen.
Du hast ein Backup-Maske und ihr Musik aufspielst.
Ich meine, was...
Guck mal Oma, ich hab dir den neuen Rammstein.
Nein Oma, diese Musik darfst du nicht hören. Das fällt leider unter die Altersbeschränkung. Das fehlt diesen Store sowieso. Also ich meine, es gibt allerlei mögliche Beschränkungen, dass du irgendwie etwas nur ab 17 bekommst. Aber was ist irgendwie mit den 77-Jährigen, die bestimmte Dinge dann auch nicht mehr sehen dürfen?
Die dann totumfallen.
Die bei der Poliografie auch irgendwie so...
Das könnte die gefährden. Ja, eben. Dann ist vorbei mit Oma.
Ich hab da auch immer Angst vor.
Das ist der einzige Grund, warum du deiner Oma keine Porn.
Ich hab mich immer gewundert, was meine Oma macht, aber sie hat wirklich nur die fünf öffentlichen Sender da irgendwie und den anderen nicht.
Ich muss mir keine Sorgen machen. Fangen wir doch mal an mit dem Formfaktor. Jetzt habt ihr das Teil ja hier in der Hand gehabt. Wenn man es so ein bisschen an der Seite hält, denke ich, dann kommt das so von der Breite her hin. Und das Gewicht, das stimmt. Das hab ich jetzt wirklich auf Gramm genau abgemessen. Das ist die UMTS-Version. Also es ist schon, es liegt schon relativ satt in der Hand. Das ist nicht so ein leichtes Teil. Man kann es wahrscheinlich, das geht natürlich jetzt hier mit meinem Schlabber-Post nicht so gut festhalten.
Wenn das aus Alu ist, dann ist das auch deutlich fester als das, was du da hast. Dann hält sich das anders, dann wackelt das nicht.
Das MacBook Air zum Beispiel ist doppelt so schwer und das macht nicht so den Eindruck. Das ist ein ganz entscheidendes Ding und ich glaube, das wird insgesamt den Eindruck machen. Von der Größe her, da man das ja auch näher hält, als man jetzt vor so einem MacBook sitzen würde, ist der Screen eigentlich groß.
Klar, wenn man sich den näher vor die Nase holt.
Und mit diesem Rand ist es eigentlich auch ganz cool, weil wie man das Ding halt auch dreht, man hat immer Platz, seine Finger, seine Griffe da drauf zu machen.
Ich finde den Rand sehr gut. Er ist massenhaft irgendwelchen Blocks zerrissen worden. Warum das Ding denn so einen breiten Rand hat? Man muss es festhalten. Außerdem stört es auch bei so einem Ding nicht, weil das ist ja, ich würde sagen, wir können uns darauf einigen, es ist für einen Heimbetrieb eigentlich konzipiert, auch wenn es eine 3G-Version davon gibt. Und da spielt es, ob ich nur zu Hause drei Zentimeter Mehrrand auf dem Tisch liegen habe oder nicht, spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. Das ist bei mobilen Geräten interessant, wie dick der Rand ist bei anderen draufgeschissen.
Ich habe natürlich wieder Angst vor diesem Autorotate. Also Autorotate könnte das Ding mal wieder komplett kaputt machen. Naja, ich habe ja kein Problem damit, dass es das gibt, solange man es auch ausschalten kann. Insbesondere wenn ich mir den Film angucke.
Da werden die das, das wird es geben, dass man das abschalten kann, glaube ich.
Ach. Bestimmt.
Meinst du?
Warum? Weil guck mal so, also ich meine hier Steve und Phil und so, alle die das da benutzt haben, die haben natürlich schon auch ihre Choreografie, wie sie das Ding vorstellen müssen. Und da bestimmt drin irgendwie andauernd mal drehen und so. Und ich meine, die haben das benutzt, dann haben sie es wieder so, dann wieder so. Je nachdem, wie du es irgendwie gerade so machst. Und beim iPhone, das hält man ja schon auch sehr mit einer Hand.
Er hat sich aber nicht hingelegt auf die Seite. Ist eingeschlafen, ja.
Nee, aber das ist trotzdem, wie oft die das umgedreht haben. Ich glaube, das war nicht nur, weil denen gesagt wurde, du musst das so machen, sondern weil sich wirklich bestimmte Sachen will man eher so im Querformat haben und bestimmte Sachen will man im Hochformat haben. Und da man es sowieso mit beiden Händen hält, kann man es schnell drehen. Das iPhone zum Beispiel, das hältst du halt so, das ist mit dem Drehen, das ist immer nicht so.
Ich glaube, das Drehen ist eines der Key-Features. Was für ein Teil.
Was, wie das iPhone kann man schwer drehen? Was ist denn das?
Ja, nicht mit einer Hand.
Du hältst es in einer Hand und dann drehst es.
Ja, aber es ist immer so.
Ist doch egal, ob ich das in einer Hand drehe oder in zwei Händen drehe. Wenn es einen Lens gibt, dann hält man es sowieso in beiden Händen.
Also ich halte es dann meistens so, hab es dann eben so.
Jetzt hast du schon in der zweiten Hand dazu.
Ich hab sowieso meistens.
Denn ich finde deine Argumentation nicht schlüssig, warum sie deswegen Autorotate ausschaltbar machen. Das haben sie bisher nicht getan.
Nicht ausschaltbar, sondern ich würde sagen, bei dem iPad benutzt man es noch viel öfter, dass man es drehen kann.
Ja und? Dafür muss man es ausschalten? Nein, dafür muss man es anschalten, sagst du. Es soll Autorotate haben.
Bei dem iPhone ist diese Rotate-Funktion erst nicht so gefeaturet. Also zum Beispiel Apple kam jetzt mit der 3.0 erst, dass man irgendwie Mail drehen kann und so. Das gab es ja vorher nicht.
Ach so meinst du das.
So und bei diesem Gerät, da haben die gleich von Anfang an gedacht, das muss man in allen möglichen Lebenslagen auch drehen können. Also da wirst du Videos auch hochkant gucken können und so.
Okay, also was du sagen willst ist, alle Applikationen haben einen Let's Skip-Modus. Das ist das, was du mir sagen willst.
Ich würde mich mal behaupten.
I totally agree, aber das ist nicht das worüber ich rede. Ich rede davon, ob es möglich ist zu sagen, ich will jetzt mal explizit Autorotate ausschalten.
Ja, da kommen wir ja zum nächsten Schritt. Wenn die bei dem iPhone von Anfang an gar nicht alles in Autorotate hatten, dann hatten die natürlich auch noch keinen Schalter, um es abzuschalten, weil es sowieso erstmal nicht ging. Für die eigenen Apple-Probleme. So jetzt bei dem iPad ist natürlich von Hause aus gleich alles drehbar, deswegen kommen die darauf viel schneller auf die Idee, dass man es vielleicht auch mal abschalten will.
Na ja gut, also der Logik kann ich nicht so ganz folgen.
Ich bin halt schon eine Stufe weiter als du.
Ich glaube, es wird nicht abschaltbar sein. Und es dreht sich also noch in viel mehr Richtung. Also es ist ja, was ja beim iPhone nicht geht, dass auf dem Kopf dreht.
Klar geht das auf dem iPhone.
Aber es unterstützt keine Standard-Applikation.
Ja, dann können die das halt alle nicht. Aber es geht. Mein Text da macht das.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es geht. Aber es können die Applikationen alle nicht. Und auf dem iPad...
Also das kann dann Apple dafür, wenn die Programme das nicht einsetzen.
Keine Apple-Applikation kann's.
Können wir über wichtige Sachen reden. Das ist dann nur wirklich vollkommen egal, ob sich das jetzt irgendwie drehen lässt in irgendwelchen Applikationen oder nicht. Tatsache ist, es stört manchmal. Und ich fände es einfach gut, wenn sie da eine Antwort liefern könnten. Genauso, da habe ich ja hier, als ich hier alleine vor mich hin rantete, auch schon nicht definitiv zu geäußert. Autorität ist ein Problem, und dass man auch die Helligkeit nicht jederzeit mit irgendeiner Geste anstellen kann.
Das geht auch um die Tastatur, die hat eigene Tasten dafür.
Ach, großartig! Das heißt, ich stecke das Teil in dieses Dock mit der Tastatur und renne dann die ganze Zeit mit dem Ding so rum? Ja, und warum ist das auf der Tastatur?
Habt ihr die externe Tastatur auch, den Andung-Button?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe gerade ein Foto von der gesehen. Ich glaube, die hat eine Command-Taste. Also die hat da wahrscheinlich für die Shortcut.
Das ist ja schon wieder nichts für meine Mama.
Sie haben Escape in Home umbenannt und sie haben generell die Fs weggelassen. Und ansonsten ist das weitgehend identisch. Inklusive Option und so. Aber ich glaube, eine Kontrolltaste war auch nicht drauf.
Ich glaube, da war eine Kontrolltaste. Ich glaube, das ist eine wesentliche Standard-Apple-Tastatur.
Ach so, das war ja amerikanisches Layout. Das habe ich wahrscheinlich falsch interpretiert.
Also ich bin ja sowieso, ich habe ja irgendwie das Gefühl, gerade bei dieser Tastatur, also ich hätte ja nie dran geglaubt, dass die eine Tastatur hat und ich war wirklich baff, als du da das Dock mit Tastatur vorgestellt haben.
Funktion war nicht dabei.
Und ich glaube, das wird es auch nicht lange. Ach, das hat eine Funktion-Taste, das kleine.
Ja, Funktion-Taste ist auch eine ganz tolle Sache, finde ich.
Ja, die ist super, die sollte bloß auf der zweiten Seite noch sein, auf der anderen, auf der rechten Seite auch noch. Da vermisse ich so oft.
Du willst ja so ein Ding haben, ne?
Ich will so ein Ding haben, ja. Haben.
Ja, abgesehen vom haben.
Na, es gibt, wie gesagt, es gibt ungefähr 48.000 Anwendungen, wo ich mir auf dem iPhone gedacht habe, das geht auf dem iPhone so geil, von der Bedienung her. Das hätte ich gerne auf meinem großen Display. Und das sind einfach die Möglichkeiten. Also dieses Surfen mit den Fingern, da haben sich ja auch alle darüber aufgeregt, dass Steve Jobs das so lange vorgeführt hat, während der Keynote, wie toll man da mit den Fingern surfen kann. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein extrem tolles Argument.
Das ist die Art des Computers, würde ich behaupten.
Genau.
Das ist das Killer-Feature an dem ganzen Ding.
Genau, das ist das Killer-Feature. Du hast ein Gerät, das du nicht mehr aufklappen musst, finde ich ganz angenehm. Was augenblicklich einsatzbereit ist, ist ja auch beim iPhone sehr schön, diese Zeit, die vergeht, bis es einsatzbereit ist, ist ja noch mal um einige Sekunden kürzer als zum Beispiel bei einem MacBook, was ja erst mal aufwachen muss und hochfahren muss.
Ich nenne es noch nicht so 64er Speed, aber es ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Beim C64 meinst du, oder?
Ja, schaltest du ein, ist er da. Ich meine, so eine Geräte werden demnächst kommen. Das iPad hat kein Filesystem mehr zum Beispiel. Meine Mutter muss sich nicht kümmern, wo bestimmte Files auf diesem Ding liegen. Sondern du startest dein Programm und das Programm sagt dir, was für Dokumente, Musik oder was auch immer. Das Programm an Objekten verwaltet.
Es ist weitgehend stateless oder zustandslos. Es ist immer einsatzbereit. Ich habe immer den Webbrowser da, wenn ich brauche. Auf dem MacBook habe ich es so oft, dass wenn ich aus dem Büro wiederkomme, dass ich noch viele Tabs offen habe, die ich von der Arbeit hatte und brauchte, die ich jetzt nicht alle unbedingt schließen möchte und so was. Und dafür ist es dann einfach schön, dass man einfach zu auf Safari quasi als Zweitrechner, als rein Home-Rechner.
Also wenn sie da ein OS-mäßig alles richtig machen, dann kann man ja auch nichts kaputt machen.
Zum einen das und zum zweiten so beim Fernsehen. Tatsächlich das Gerät, was ich nutzen werde, wenn ich vorm Fernseher liege, auf der Couch, ist einfach ein MacBook total scheiße. Weil man muss irgendwie immer aufklappen, dann hat dieses Jahr noch dieses etwas Leid geschehen.
Beim Fernsehen. Beim Fernsehen willst du auch noch.
Beim Filmkonsum.
Na klar, das ist die Fernsehzeitschrift, die neue. Das ist die neue Fernbedienung, die neue Fernsehzeitung. Das ist die neue Küchen-, die neue Morgenzeitung in der Küche beim Frühstücken. Das ist das neue Buch, was du abends im Bett liest. All das ist das Ding. Das ist die neue Stadtkarte. Das ist der neue Fahrplan, all sowas.
Da kommen wir zu einem Feature, was ich bisher tatsächlich vermisse, was wir hoffentlich noch nachliefern werden. Und zwar als Fernbedienung. Das iPad als Fernbedienung für den Fernseher. Und zwar jetzt nicht irgendwie mit scheiß Infrarot oder sowas, sondern... Nee, bei Android hab ich einen durch versehentlichen Feature entdeckt, was echt großartig ist. Und zwar ist folgendermaßen...
Das kennt niemand.
Das kennt niemand. Ich hab mir ja diesen Media-Computer eingerichtet mit XBMC drauf, mit dem ich über meine Filme gucken kann. Und da gibt's auch fürs iPhone und für Android gibt's dafür eine XBMC-Fernbedienung. Und das hab ich mir auf beiden Geräten installiert. Bei Android ist das jetzt so, wenn ich im Webbrowser unterwegs bin und ich klicke zum Beispiel einen Videolink an, im Webbrowser, dann fragt mich, seitdem ich das Ding installiert habe, fragt mich Android, hey, möchtest du das gerne mit dem internen Videoplayer öffnen? Oder via XBMC? Dann sagst du via XBMC und BAM, wird das Video auf deinem Fernseher abgespielt. Und ich meine, wie geil wäre das denn, wenn man so dieses iPad vor sich hätte?
Du suchst dir was ausklickst, dann geht der Fernseher an und...
Und geht der Fernseher an und spielt dir das ab. Du suchst dir deinen Film raus, in der Bibliothek, musst du es dir nicht auf dem kleinen Ding angucken, sondern guckst es dir auf dem Fernseher an. Du liest einen Artikel und wenn du dann in der zugehörigen Nachrichtenbericht sehen willst, dann siehst du es auf dem Fernseher. Kaufst Musik, Musikvideos. Das wär für Fotos wärs auch der totale Hammer. Und das machst du einfach via IP, schließt es an deinen Apple TV an, fertig ist die Sause.
Na ich denke, sie werden bei dem Apple TV schon für die entsprechende Upgrade der Remote-Applikation sorgen. Sie haben ja generell... Also eine der Sachen, die mich wirklich beeindruckt haben ist, die ich konsequent fand, ist, dass sie ganz klar aufgezeigt haben, den Weg. Das iPhone mit dem kleinen Bildschirm hat eben dieses reduzierte User-Interface, aber wir haben jetzt einen Weg gefunden, erstens, wie wir klar dasselbe da drauf zeigen, diese Emulationen, aber das fand ich jetzt nicht so wichtig. Es ist gut, dass sie das gemacht haben, weil dann starten sie halt gleich mit 140.000 Apps und nicht mit keiner. Aber dass sie dann eben gezeigt haben, so und dasselbe User-Interface-Konzept funktioniert, aber auch für den größeren Bildschirm. Aber wir machen jetzt nicht einfach nur dasselbe in größer, sondern wir klappen das anders auf. Was weiß ich, ein Mail-Programm sieht auf einmal sehr viel mehr aus, wie auf dem Desktop, ist trotzdem noch reduziert. Du hast links deine Liste, aber im Prinzip setzt es sich zusammen aus zwei User-Interface-Element-Panes, die du beim iPhone halt hintereinander bedienst. Erst hast du die Liste der Messages, gehst rein, dann bist du in der Message. Jetzt beim iPad hast du halt den Platz, dann hast du links die Liste der Messages, rechts die Message und es sind aber quasi dieselben Interface-Elemente, die dort zusammenkommen. Plus, dass sie auch mehr dahingehen, ist noch sehr viel mehr wie eine Appliance zu machen. Also sowohl diese iBooks-Anwendung, als auch das Adressbuch, als auch der Kalender. Die Dinge sehen aus wie richtige Kalender, wie richtige Bücher. Ja gut, weil sie hätten aber mit dem Platz auch was anderes machen können. Sie hätten es ja auch weiterhin so compute-task rüberkommen lassen. Aber insofern glaube ich, Dennis ist auch wirklich recht, wenn er sagt, das ist halt in der Lage, quasi die elektronische Version von all diesen herumliegenden Sachen zu sein, für die man normalerweise immer ein Stück Physik herumliegen hat. Telefonbruch, Stadtplan, stimmt schon. Ich meine, wir verwenden auch unser iPhone so, aber du kennst ja auch die schrägen Glicke, die wir immer ernten von unseren nicht-Geek-Freunden, so wie komisch wir doch drauf sind, dass wir wirklich unser Telefon für alles verwenden.
Das wird sich jetzt total ändern, wenn wir es auf einem Zusatzgerät namens iPad machen.
Ich denke, dass das schon etwas ist, was andere Leute dann sehr viel mehr annehmen würden als dieses kleine Teil. Dieses kleine Teil ist denen dann einfach schon noch zu geekig. Und das große Gerät ist irgendwie, naja, das ist einfach freundlicher. Das liegt auch so rum und ist immer da und ist so dein Freund. Ich glaube, der Trend geht schon zum 2.
Als Urlaubsgerät finde ich es übrigens total geil. Als Urlaubsrechner hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es dafür taugt. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, mit so einem iPad allein in den Urlaub zu fahren. Man kann die Fotos von seiner Kamera runterladen, kann sie sich auf einem vernünftigen Display angucken und hat sie schon mal gesehen und aussortieren und löschen. Man kann so ein bisschen notdürftig, oder was heißt notdürftig, gut rumsurfen und hat nicht so dieses 2.000-Euro-Teil dabei. Also das, was ich vorher gedacht habe, was so ein iPad niemals leisten können würde, ich glaube, das würde mich schon über eine gewisse Zeit lang hinweg retten. Wenn dafür jetzt noch Text-Mail rauskommt, dann bin ich glücklich.
Aber das, was mich am meisten beeindruckt hat, von allem, das war die Vorstellung von iWork. Also, dass sie das losgezogen haben, und ich hatte auch so den Eindruck, das ist das, was den Unterschied macht. Weil ich glaube, ohne iWork werden wir eigentlich nicht so richtig überrascht gewesen. Das war within expectations. So Tablett und man kann surfen und klar und alle Applikationen, die sie sonst hast, hast du auch und dann sind sie vielleicht ein bisschen größer, hübscher und so weiter. Wir wussten nicht genau, wie sie es machen, aber ich denke, das ist schon so irgendwie das. Aber wo man dann anfängt, durchzuatmen ist, können sie es schaffen, eine Desktop-Anwendung, wo jeder auch sofort gesagt hätte, klar, das ist das, wofür man einen richtigen Computer in Anführungsstrichen bräuchte, nämlich Textverarbeitung, Tabellenkalkulation und Präsentationen erstellen. Das ist ja schon Hardcore. Dass man das damit machen kann. Und diese User-Interface-Interaktionen und die Elemente, die sie dafür eingeführt haben, die wirken aus der Ferne für mich recht natürlich, einleuchtend und weitgehend nachvollziehbar. Also muss man natürlich im einzelnen sehen gerade so mit dem Mehrfach selektieren und so weiter.
Das war ganz pfiffig gemacht.
Du hältst den ein und dann klickst du die anderen noch mit dazu bei dem Keynote und so. Das macht durchaus Sinn. Sie haben auch dieses Tab und Hold, also sind jetzt mehr als nur Tabs, sondern jetzt tappen und holden sie halt auch und dann machst du eben mit der anderen Hand noch irgendwelche anderen Sachen. Man merkt, dass sie jetzt diesen zweiten Schritt auch gegangen sind in der Verwendung von Multitouch. Sie haben sich ja eigentlich sehr zurückgehalten. Man hätte ja schon mit tausend Gesten losmarschieren können, bloß das haben sie halt bewusst sein gelassen, um zu sehen, wie weit kommt man erstmal mit wenig und wo hat man dann eben noch die Möglichkeit, komplett neue Interaktionsmodelle damit zu haben.
Wahrscheinlich weil dieses Gerät anders eingesetzt wird. Das iPhone, das hältst du mit einer Hand und hast eigentlich nur noch eine Hand frei, um es wirklich vernünftig zu bedienen. Und ich glaube, bei diesem iPad wird es eher so sein, dass man es auf dem Schoß in irgendeiner Form hat und quasi zwei Hände hat, mit denen man drauf agieren kann.
Ja, ich hab Leute gesehen, die sowohl auch die Tastatur mit, also in einem Vertikal gehalten, die Tastatur mit zwei Daumen bedienen konnten. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass man das Ding einfach auf der Rückseite hält, dass man sozusagen auf der flachen Hand liegen hat, wenn es dich zu heiß wird, und dann halt einfach mit der anderen so tippt. Und der Rest muss sich zeigen. Da wird nichts heiß. Ja, den Eindruck macht es.
Aber ich glaube, dieses iVac hat tatsächlich zwei Aufgaben. Das hat zum einen, für Entwickler ist das, glaube ich, eine wichtige Sache, damit die sehen können, es ist möglich, wirklich fette Applikationen damit zu machen, damit sie ein gutes Vorbild haben. Zum zweiten ist es, glaube ich, auch für die entsprechende Zielgruppe wichtig, dass es eben kein Spielzeug ist, wie jetzt mal das iPhone ist. Auf dem iPhone kann man ja keine ernsthaften Sachen machen, sondern es ist ja wirklich ein wesentliches Kommunikationsgerät. Das ist ein Gerät, mit dem man auch wirklich Inhalte produzieren kann, also durchaus ein bisschen kreativ sein kann. Insofern glaube ich, dass das iWork dafür existiert, ist sozusagen der Versuch der Angriff auf die Netbooks zu sagen. Das ist nämlich genau das Gerät, mit dem das alles geht, was ihr von euch von einem Netbook erwartet.
Der Angriff auf die Netbooks. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jemals die Netbooks als nennenswerte Konkurrenz angesehen haben.
Was heißt als Konkurrenz? Sie wollen in dasselbe, in ein Marktsegment rein. Das haben sie auch am Anfang relativ deutlich gesagt. Insofern sehen sie die Netbooks als...
In denen die Netbooks nie reingekommen sind.
In denen die Netbooks rein wollten, aber nie reingekommen sind. Genau.
Ich denke, sie haben einfach einen komplett neuen Markt, nämlich den iPad-Markt. Jaja, klar, genau. Den es derzeit irgendwie noch nicht gibt.
Am Anfang glaubten die Leute, ich ja auch, dass der durch die Netbooks durchaus besetzt werden könnte. Das hat sich als Irrtum erwiesen.
Also mal ehrlich, diese Netbooks waren doch eine Spielerei. Alle sind dem Traum verfallen oder glauben, dass sie mit diesen kleinen Dingern das Gleiche machen können wie mit ihren großen Geräten, nur dass es halt schön klein und schön leicht ist und sie deswegen überall dabei haben und dass die Akkus ewig halten. Da haben sie sich stundenlang und tage und wochenlang installiert. Und dass es billig ist. Und haben dann eine Woche rumgespielt und gemerkt, irgendwie ist es aber doch nicht so schön wie auf dem großen. Und dann haben sie es ja gelassen. Ich kenne so viele, die alle rumgezockt haben und klar, ein paar Freaks halten natürlich auch durch, weil sie irgendwie sich selbst und anderen nicht eingestehen wollen, dass es irgendwie nichts ist. Und ein paar kommen vielleicht sogar auch damit. Klar kann ja sein, aber ich finde, die meisten haben es irgendwie nach einer Weile wieder aufgegeben.
Ja, nochmal zur iWork. Und du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, so dieses Pfeilsystem ist weg. Tatsächlich sieht es ja so aus, als ob es auch ein bisschen wiederkommt dadurch. Ja, einerseits, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Na ja.
Du hast da keinen Zugriff auf Nürnungs.
Darf ich? Erstens macht das auf mich die… Ich hab jetzt mir noch nicht hier diese SDK-Geschichten und so weiter durchgelesen, aber soweit ich das zwischen den Zeilen gelesen habe, gibt es jetzt wohl die Möglichkeit, für jede Applikation auch Files zu sinken. Auf den Rechner. Das könnte tatsächlich eine der ganz, ganz großen Features sein. Stell dir mal vor, also solche Programme wie, was weiß ich hier, auf meinem iPhone One Password. Also um meinen Desktop-Rechner und meinen iPhone Klein miteinander zu sinken, gibt es derzeit keine Möglichkeit. Also es sei denn, ich lasse auf beiden Rechnern gleichzeitig das Programm jeweils laufen und dann verständigen die sich so. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass man einfach nie alles gesynkt bekommt. Wenn es aber jetzt für iWork und so weiter zwangsläufig die Möglichkeit gibt, dass die eben auch Dateien austauschen, dass es quasi Ordner gibt, so Shared Folder, so sehe ich das, ja, das iTunes quasi.
Ich glaube, das heißt explizit Shared Folder.
Dann könnte man natürlich darüber genau diese Settings hin und her transferieren. Das heißt, eine Desktop-Applikation, die sich mit einer iPhone-Anwendung synchronisieren muss, könnte es über diesen Weg machen. Und wir hätten endlich den Fall, dass eben diese ganzen Geräte, dass alle Applikationen auf diesem Gerät sich mit einem Rechner synchronisieren können über iTunes.
Ja, aber das heißt ja, ok, da ist ein Filesystem und natürlich hat das iPad auch ein Filesystem, aber das heißt nicht, dass der User beim Bedienen damit irgendwie konfrontiert wird.
Genau, jetzt Teil 2. Gut, er wird damit konfrontiert. Ich meine, wenn du dir mal die iWork-Demos anschaust, da tauchen die Dateien ja auf, nur eben nicht so im Sinne von, da ist eine Datei mit einem Namen in einem Ordner, sondern du siehst die Dateien.
Klar, tauchen die da auf als Bilder, als Zeug. Das ist ja logisch, du musst ja irgendwie deine Sachen rankriegen. Aber du siehst halt diese Struktur nicht mehr. Auch diese Baumstruktur siehst du halt nicht mehr.
Genau, es gibt keine Baumstruktur.
Wenn du bei Alvaro sagst, du willst Bilder importieren, dann macht er dir dein Bild, wie sagt man, Katalog oder Album auf und bietet dir sofort alle Bilder und eventuell sogar von allen Programmen, die auf deinem iPad gesagt haben, dass sie irgendwie Bilddateien haben. Oder Objekte würde ich das jetzt mal eher nennen und dann zeigt er die, aber du musst da nicht irgendwie brausen oder durch irgendwelche Hierarchien dich durchklicken oder dir sowieso irgendwelche Fade merken, aber das hat der App noch nie gemacht.
Ja, weiteres wichtiges Element. Von vornherein war es ja mit dabei. E-Books.
Ach, hast du jetzt endlich hier auch eine Magic Mouse, ja?
Ich erinnere mich, ähm...
Jetzt verstehe ich, warum das Ding E-Books heißt. Als Gegensatz zu E-Books, natürlich. Klar, logisch.
Naja, vor allem als Gegensatz zu iTunes.
Naja, das natürlich schon, aber dass sie den Namen iBook noch mal recyceln, hat mich tatsächlich ein bisschen überrascht. Aber dass sie so diesen Begriff, der jetzt gerade am Entstehen ist, diese elektronischen Bücher, E-Books, denen durch eine minimale Lautverschiebung zu ihrer Eigenmarke drehen, sozusagen.
Ja gut, aber sie reden ja auch von iBooks. Gut.
Statt E-Books kauft man sich jetzt iBooks.
Jaja, aber was ist da jetzt passiert? Also, kurz gesagt, der iTunes-Store kann jetzt auch Bücher verkaufen?
Voll nicht aus dem Konzept. Das ist nicht der iTunes-Store, sondern das ist ja eine eigene. Jaaa.
So nennen die das halt, aber das ist doch dieselbe Infrastruktur, das ist derselbe Account.
Ja bei denen da irgendwo, klar.
Das ist derselbe Account.
Sind aber unterschiedliche Programme.
Das ist derselbe Store.
Ja, es ist auch beim Up-Store schon ein unterschiedliches Programm gewesen. Trotzdem ist es da drin. Wie auch immer. Im Apfel-Online-Store, was auch immer. Also da ist halt einfach jetzt auch Bücher mit drin, als Items, selbes Revenue-Modell und so weiter. Nur USA, was mich überhaupt nicht verwundert. Und die große Frage ist jetzt so ein bisschen, welche Power kann Apple entwickeln, tatsächlich da in den Buchmarkt einzusteigen, in einer Art und Weise, wie es Amazon macht? Ich glaube, Deutschland wird eines der letzten Länder sein, was überhaupt diese Albuks sehen wird, wenn überhaupt. Weil...
Ja, ich glaube der deutsche Buchmarkt ist auch nicht so easy. Ich bin da immer so ein bisschen auf meinem linken Ohr, manchmal auch auf dem rechten, auf Arbeit. Und da kommen immer so Fetzen rein. Und ich glaube der deutsche Buchmarkt, das ist echt kompliziert.
Buchpreisbindung braucht man da nur zu sagen.
Ja, nicht nur das, das ist ja auch mit diesen ganzen Lizenzgeschichten. Also wenn du irgendwie ein deutsches Buch verkaufst oder verkaufen darfst, hier heißt es noch lange nicht, dass du es zum Beispiel auch in Österreich verkaufen darfst. Obwohl die da auch das gleiche deutsche Buch lesen.
Aber das ist ja im Musikbusiness kein bisschen anders. Also den Markt haben sie auch geknackt.
Kann sein, aber die Musik-Monopolo, oder hier dieses Amy Warner Brothers und so was, das gibt es wahrscheinlich vier große, mit denen musst du irgendwie gehen. Dann hast du das größte abgedeckt. Und im Buchmarkt ist es noch ein bisschen... Ja, aber das sind die größten, und damit hast du 90% erschlagen.
Nein, hast du nicht, weil du musst jedes Land für sich die Verträge neu aushandeln, weil die das tut. Weil das sind alles...
Ja, aber nur mit Vieren.
Nee, nee, für jedes Land.
Ja, für jedes Land nur mit Vieren.
Na ja, und dann noch mit den restlichen Labels.
Ja, aber die sind nicht so groß.
Nicht für 90%.
Aber um in Deutschland reinzukommen, mussten die... Also das heißt nicht, dass sie dann mit den österreichischen Marken, genau das was du gerade gesagt hast, abgedeckt haben.
Tatsache ist, es hat beim Musik lange gedauert. Das war ein Prozess von, ich weiß nicht mehr, einigen Jahren, bis das dann wirklich mal alles komplett abgefeiert war. Und jetzt steht im Prinzip mit den Büchern nochmal dasselbe bevor. Und es ist nicht klar, wie erfolgreich sie da jetzt wirklich sein werden. Sie sind vom Preis her wahrscheinlich genauso wie Amazon. Aber sie sind vor allem bei den Verlegern auch genauso, die haben genauso viel Schiss vor Apple.
Also die Verleger haben alle Schiss vor der Amazon Macht, weil Amazon hat da ganz schön irgendwie...
Ja, aber das heißt, dass sie genauso auch vor Apple Angst haben werden.
Weil gleichzeitig ist Apple für die jetzt gerade die Erlösung von Amazon. Also ob das klappt und ob da alle drauf reinfallen, ist natürlich so eine Sache. Aber auf jeden Fall versuchen die Verleger natürlich auch, Amazon und Apple gegeneinander auszuspielen. Ist natürlich klar. Also ich sag jetzt Amazon, jetzt was? Ihr macht uns keine coolen Deals.
Ich glaube, sie werden das relativ schnell hinkriegen, zumindest mit einigen großen. Einfach weil sie jetzt das...
Deutschland? Mit der Buchpreisbindung?
Also es wird den iBook Store relativ geben, wahrscheinlich nicht zu den gleichen Preisen wie in Amerika oder wie auch immer, sondern eben zu den deutschen Preisen. Aber ich glaube, das wird relativ schnell gehen, weil sie haben jetzt die Infrastruktur. Sie wissen jetzt, sie haben diesen Musikmarkt, haben sie einmal die entsprechenden Verträge gemacht mit allen, also dieses Romrennen und Verträge aushandeln. Und das haben sie jetzt drauf. Sie haben das mit der Filmindustrie, haben sie das auch in Deutschland hingekriegt. Das kriegen sie jetzt auch mit der Buchindustrie hin. Und mit der Filmindustrie, das ging ja relativ schnell. Ich glaube, das geht flott.
Gut, das würde ich jetzt einfach mal als brillanten Optimismus bezeichnen, weil die Märkte sind, glaube ich, nicht miteinander zu vergleichen. Allein schon, weil das Produkt nicht miteinander zu vergleichen ist.
Ja, die sind schwer miteinander zu vergleichen, aber du musst Verträge abschließen, massenhaft.
Wie auch immer, Apple benutzt ePub. Das überrascht überhaupt nicht. Das ist eigentlich der einzig nennenswerte Standard im Markt.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Eigentlich überrascht es mich fast, dass sie nichts Eigenes auf die Beine gestellt haben.
Warum sollten sie das tun?
Ich glaube, die Formate sind alle noch so ein bisschen zusammenschutert.
ePub reicht auf jeden Fall aus, um ein Buch anzuzeigen. Ja, aber es ist vor allem umbruchfähig usw. Das haben sie ja auch gezeigt, nicht wahr? Man kann halt von Größe anpassen und dann ändert sich wahrscheinlich auch das Inhaltsverzeichnis, nehme ich mal an.
Das Inhaltsverzeichnis? Bei der Fontgröße?
Na ja sicher, wenn weniger Buchstaben auf eine Seite passen, dann hast du mehr Seiten. Also muss ich das Inhaltsverzeichnis anpassen.
Aber du meinst, wo welche Seite ist. Seitenzahlen gibt es ja in dem Sinne eh nicht mehr.
Doch, da waren da Seitenzahlen zu sehen, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht total täusche.
Wir werden doch aber dann irreführend, weil dann würde ich mir auch merken, was beim Drehen des iPads schon nicht mehr…
Das ist aber das, was du bei einem Buch erwarten würdest. Wir haben jetzt hier gerade auf dem großen Bildschirm, das könnt ihr tollen Hörern natürlich gerade wieder nicht sehen.
Also Problem bei iPads ist halt, dass der Text einen Reflow macht, schon wenn man den Font ändert oder wenn man halt irgendwie in den Landscape-Modus, von Portrait-Modus in Landscape-Modus wechselt, dann wird es der Reflow pro Chapter. Und dann ändern sich natürlich die Menge, die pro Seite dargestellt werden. Und dadurch ändern sich halt auch die Seitenzahlen. Und deswegen ist das alles gar nicht so easy.
Und auch der Fond an sich ändern. Da sind Seitenzahlen drauf.
Wobei, die Seitenzahlen sind natürlich nicht insofern interessant, als dass man sich merkt, auf welche Seite man springen muss, sondern dass man einen groben Überblick hat, wie dick ist das Kapitel.
Wir hoffen mal, sie haben da Zahlen, also müssen die sich anpassen. Das können sie nicht anders machen. Ich wollte auf was anderes hinaus. Was nicht so richtig beantwortet wurde, was glaube ich nur Vermutung ist, ist, dass sie DRM zum Einsatz bringen hier. Habt ihr da irgendwas Konkreteres gehört? Also vermutet wird das allgemein. Und ich würde auch sagen, da liegt man wahrscheinlich auch ganz wichtig.
Da kann ich auch gleich was zu sagen.
Das hatte ich gehofft.
Und zwar bei DRM ist es ja so, wir nehmen jetzt mal hier DRM von irgendeinem Hersteller. Und wenn du in ein Buch DRM verschlüsselt hast und du willst es anzeigen, dann hast du vielleicht auch das Framework dafür, also die Software, die das für dich auspackt und das ganze Keymanagement und Zeug übernimmt. Aber dann kriegst du, in diesem Fall zumindest, kriegst du ein Bild geliefert. Also du sagst, du willst hier Seite so und so haben oder hast ein bestimmtes Bookmark, sprichst dahin, sagst du gib mal her die Seite und dann kriegst du die Seite halt als Bild. Dann kannst du das Bild irgendwie darstellen. Du kannst auch sagen, du willst jetzt irgendwie den Font irgendwie größer haben. Und dann kriegst du halt ein anderes Bild, wo der Font halt ein bisschen größer ist, aber du kriegst halt immer am Ende ein Bild. So, das heißt, du bist da relativ unflexibel. Was ich bei denen gesehen hab, ist, dass wenn die halt das, bei Bill, kann er halt den Font ändern und die Fontgröße und die kriegen halt kein Bild. Die kriegen richtig die Daten und können halt da frei irgendwie ihren Reflow machen und irgendwie alles ändern, wie sie wollen. Das geht halt nicht, wenn man nicht Owner von dem DRM ist. Also wenn man nicht die DRM-Software selber implementiert hat und wirklich an die puren Daten rankommt, wenn man da so ein Framework benutzt und das Framework auf Sicherheitsgründen immer nur Bilder gibt anstatt den eigentlichen Text, dann ist man ein bisschen aufgeschmissen.
Also ich meine, dass wenn sie DRM verwenden, dass sie ihr eigenes Fairplay verwenden, das ist ja glaube ich...
Ja, das ist deren Vorteil, sag ich ja.
Man kann diesen Frameworks nicht sagen, du nimm mal eine andere Schrift und formatier das mal so und so. Also wenn sie schon nur Bilder liefern?
Selbst wenn es gehen würde, du kriegst dann trotzdem nur ein Bild. Was die aber machen, ich weiß nicht, ob du das... Ihr habt ja alle die Keynote gesehen, da gab es ja auch das Beispiel mit der New York Times App. Die benutzen keinen DRM, aber nur mal so für ein Feature, was man in der Zukunft haben will. Die haben mit den zwei Fingern auf den Text geklickt, haben ihn auseinandergezogen und die Textgröße ist einfach... Die Fontgröße hat sich geändert. Und sowas kannst du halt nicht machen, wenn du von deinem DRM Framework immer nur Bilder kriegst.
Hast du da eine Suchfunktion? Ich meine, du kannst ja so ziemlich gar nichts machen.
Ja, doch, du kannst das schon auch suchen. Aber du bist da schon ein bisschen beschränkt. Genau.
Ihr traut euren eigenen Entwicklern nicht? Das ist echt mal hardcore. Nicht ihr, sondern die Hersteller der...
Natürlich trauen die nicht, deswegen machen sie doch DRM.
Dafür ist es doch da.
Sonst würde noch irgendeiner, der dieses Framework kriegt und das DRM auspacken könnte, der würde doch sofort einen Konvertierer schreiben, wenn er an die Raw-Daten rankommt und schon kannst du das DRM-System in die Tonne schmeißen.
Trotzdem, also ich fand das mit den E-Books irgendwie gut und ich finde, das ist auch eine sinnvolle, also gut implementiert. Ich hab mich ein bisschen geärgert. Ich wollte eigentlich noch in der letzten Sendung genau vorhersagen, dass wenn sie E-Books machen, dass dann auf jeden Fall eine schöne Anwendung mit einem ordentlichen Page-Curl bei rauskommt. Davon könnte man fest ausgehen.
Was ist ein Page-Curl?
Diese Blätter-Funktion.
Naja, überall in den anderen Applikationen bei Stunzer weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr, was so der letzte Stand ist.
Bei Classics gab es das auch so eine leichte Blätter-Funktion.
Ja, bei Classics, ja, da war das ein bisschen... Genau, das war einfach nicht so wie ein Blatt wirklich geht. Ja, da muss er auch noch auf jeden Fall......einen Page-Curl machen. Also bei Stunzer habe ich überhaupt gar keinen Page-Curl. Nee, der schiebt hier nur von links nach rechts.
Nein, du kannst auch die Seite nehmen und drüber ziehen. Ganz sicher.
Ja, wie denn?
Dann tipp mal drauf und...
Dann mach ich doch hier gerade. Der schiebt hier einfach von links nach rechts.
Nur tippen.
Und dann?
Nee, am Rand, nicht in der Mitte.
Dann schiebt er das auch noch rüber.
Dann hast du dir das so eingestellt. Stunzer hat auch Page-Curl.
Buchrotation?
Also so sieht es doch bei mir aus, so wie ich das mache. Aber der schiebt das auch von links nach rechts und von rechts nach links schiebt er so die Seiten rein. Stunzer ist so Mother of Page-Curl, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ich kenn das gar nicht.
Wär mir neu.
Ich auch nicht, guck da ganz selten rein.
Ja, jetzt muss man ja wieder anfangen Bücher zu lesen. Ansonsten haben wir ja gar keinen Grund, uns ein iPad zu kaufen.
Einstellungen gibt es hier.
Na gut, aber die sind beim iPad, Timme.
Ach, hier sind die Einstellungen. Nö, also Anzeigemodus Classic, das ist nur die Farbe. Also keine Ahnung, wäre mir unklar. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, das haben sie ordentlich hinbekommen. Und das war aber auch zu erwarten.
Ob es die Kindle-Software fürs iPad geben wird?
Ich hab einen Core gehabt.
Ich denke ja.
Weil, auf dem iPhone gibt es die ja?
Ja, ich meine, wenn sie es auf dem iPhone zulassen, dann müssen sie es auch auf dem iPad anmachen.
Eigentlich konsequenterweise schon, mit anderen Worten ist es. Dass es für das iPad dann von vorneherein relativ bald zwei Bookstores geben wird?
Also, Dennis zeigt uns hier gerade den Pitch-Curl bei Stunstar, aber der ist halt nicht so schick. Das ist so ein bisschen so.
Als ob man ein Brett umlegen würde.
Genau. Mich wird noch nicht mal wundern, wenn du sogar noch so ein Papierschleifgeräusch noch irgendwie im Kopfhörer hast, wenn du die Seiten umblättest. Das ist doch richtig so ein Blätter-Sound.
Oder aus dem kleinen Kopfhörer.
Nee, das nervt doch alles beim Lesen.
Etten ist großartig.
Man muss sich doch von den Leuten, die Büchern hören, immer diese ganze Haptik-Geschichte auch bei Newspapers und so weiter. Ah, da hab ich was in der Hand. Und das Papier und wie das riecht und so weiter. Wenn du zumindest schon mal den Klang übertragen kannst, wäre doch was geholfen. Kann man ja ausschalten.
Mach mal Flugmodus an.
Wir reden zu lange über Sachen, die eigentlich vollkommen klar sind.
Das ist die Zeitung.
Was?
Ich dachte ja, dass das, ich hatte ja letztes Mal prophezeit, dass das Zeitungslesegerät wird quasi.
Das ist das, worüber alle geredet haben.
Das wird es vielleicht noch werden, aber ist es bisher noch nicht.
Die New York Times App kommt doch schon. Die anderen werden auch so kommen. Die werden mit Abo-Modellen, die dann die Kohle reinholen.
Ja gut, aber da ist Apple in keiner Hinsicht irgendwie engagiert.
Was ja immer vorhergesagt wurde, ist, Ist doch egal, sie kriegen 30 Prozent.
Ja, aber es wurde doch die ganze Zeit in der Gerüchteküche herumgetragen, sie würden da Deals machen. Aber für diese New York Times App, der einzige Deal, den sie da gemacht haben, ist, dass der auf der Keynote sprechen darf.
Und dass die in den Developer Account kommen.
Wahrscheinlich hat ihnen deswegen Steve Jobs noch irgendwie so einen Einpeitscher noch in ihre Abentwicklung reingeschickt, damit das auch auf jeden Fall ordentlich aussieht.
Ja, so einen hätte ich ja auch gerne mal.
Stundenweise bin ich zu haben. Dann kann man ja auch gleich sagen, wie es geht. Was ist denn wirklich richtig geil an diesem Teil? Also was sie jetzt gebracht haben, was auch voll in meiner Erwartungslinie lag, war, dass sie jetzt das erste Mal einen eigenen Stein entwickelt haben, wo Prozessor und im Prinzip das ganze System drin ist.
Da wollen wir ein bisschen History erzählen.
Genau, sie haben sich ja vor zwei Jahren die Bude PA Semi gekauft. Wir hatten das ja auch sehr ausführlich bei RoboMax. Na bitte, erzähl.
Das war ja so, dass vor vier, fünf Jahren hat Apple irgendwie die ganzen G4 Prozessoren. Auf dem Desktop hatten sie schon G5 Prozessoren und sie hätten ja gerne den G5 auch in ihre Powerbooks eingebaut. Ging aber nicht, weil der G5 hat zu viel Strom gekostet. Da haben sie sich so ein bisschen umgeguckt. IBM hat das Ding natürlich nicht entwickelt, dass man es irgendwie in Laptops einsetzen kann und deswegen gab es bei IBM nichts zu holen. Da hat Apple sich weiter umgeschaut und da haben sie eine Firma gefunden, die hieß PA. Semi. Die haben sich darauf spezialisiert, Stromsparende Versionen von CPUs zu bauen. Also nicht nur PowerPCs, sondern auch, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, von ARM und Spark und so weiter. Und die hatten in der Entwicklung wohl zu dem Zeitpunkt noch einen Dual Core G5 in einer absoluten sparsamen Version, den man in so einen Laptop einbauen könnte. Da ist Apple wohl mit denen in Kontakt gekommen und gekannt haben, die sich wahrscheinlich eh, weil die sind ja alle da im gleichen Business. Aber dazu ist es nicht mehr gekommen, weil Apple schon zu schnell nach Intel gewechselt hat. Aber der Kontakt ist wohl geblieben. Und dann hatten die wohl schon die ersten Pläne für ihr iPad, muss ja dann irgendwann auch gewesen sein. Die müssen ja ein bisschen vorausschauen. Jedenfalls haben sie im...
Dass die mal einen eigenen Prozessor brauchen könnten, das war ja spätestens seit dem iPhone klar. Also ich meine, wir können wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass der Prozessor auch im iPhone...
Ein eigener Prozessor ist klar, seitdem sie Computer bauen, könnte man dann auch sagen.
Es geht ja nicht so sehr um eigener Prozessor, sondern es geht um System on a Chip. Es geht darum, dass man die Integration soweit optimiert, dass man eben möglichst wenige Steine von dritten Herstellern hat, was natürlich auf der einen Seite...
Dass man nach eigenen Bedürfnissen und Wünschen alles reinmachen kann, was man haben will.
Man ist halt einfach so, wie Apple das will. Und vor allem ist es natürlich auch sehr viel schwerer nachzubauen. Während du ein iPhone auseinandernehmen kannst und dann siehst du, ah hier der Samsung-Stein, ah das, das, das. Ja, das baut dann Microsoft auch gleich mal in den Zune ein. Und ha, haben wir auch. So, könnten wir gut nachmachen. Das wird jetzt ein bisschen schwieriger werden.
Aber nicht so wirklich, weil... Also die haben im März 2008 dieses PAsemi gekauft. Das ist jetzt die Design, diesen Chip, diesen Apple A4. Und der ist ja weiterhin, das ist ja ein ARM-Core. Aber mit irgendwie Shipset und GPU gleich alles mit drauf in diesem einen Stein drin. So und jetzt ARM ist ja so, das ist eine Chip oder eine CPU-Design, die bauen die selber gar nicht, sondern die designen die nur. Also das ist ein Architekt, der den Plan macht, aber bauen tun immer andere. Das heißt, die verkaufen ihre Lizenzen für ihre ARM-Architektur. Kannste bei denen einkaufen, das werden die bei PAsemi gemacht haben. Also die haben da nichts an dem ARM designen. Aber die haben natürlich den Strom optimiert und dieses Chip-Set und die GPU, da weiß ich auch nicht, vielleicht haben die das auch, alles eingekauft, aber halt so zusammengeschustert, genauso wie Apple das haben will, haben alles rausgeschmissen, was Strom kostet und nicht gebraucht wird.
Genau. Und es ist also basiert auf dem Cortex A9 ARM-Design, der an sich ja ein Multicore-Design ist. Ich habe allerdings noch nichts dazu gehört, ob das iPad tatsächlich auch ein Dual-Core-System ist oder ob sie sich da quasi auf einen einzigen Core beschränkt haben.
Das war jetzt am Augenblick so ziemlich, da wird viel drüber gerätselt.
Ja, das wird sich natürlich dann schnell herausstellen.
Das ist doch ganz klar, da sind vier drin. Nee, Jungs, war nur ein Spaß, war nur ein Spaß.
Also ausschließen kann man das nicht?
Nee, glaub ich nicht.
Ob allerdings jetzt die Software schon soweit ist?
Aber alle Leute, die das Ding in der Hand haben, sagen snappy wie Sau.
Ja, das hab ich halt vor.
Und ich meine, dieses ganze Touch- und Animationzeugs auf dem iPhone, das ist ja rattenschnell, aber das ist halt auch echt nur ein kleiner Screen. Wenn dieses ganze Animationzeug, was da so durch die Gegend fliegt und die Buttons animiert, nicht mal Buttons animiert, aber so rein und raus sladed und alles gleichzeitig und dreht und so auf diesen größeren Bildschirm, ist schon, ihr wisst uns ja vom Mac hier, wir haben die schnellsten Kisten mit den dicksten Grafikchips hier und so und trotzdem manchmal ruckelt es halt irgendwie alles, weil gleichzeitig geht dann irgendwie doch nicht so schick. Und da soll wohl richtig das flutschen.
Soll. 1 Gigahertz ist das Ding getaktet, für ein mobiles Gerät ist das schon eine ganze Menge Holz.
Naja, aber warte, die neuesten Nexus One, muss man dazu sagen, haben auch diesen Snapdragon, ist auch irgendein armer Tra-la-la mit 1 Gigahertz, also da sind die eigentlich auf gleicher Höhe.
Das ist ja auch dasselbe Design, ist auch ein Cortex A9.
Aber kurze Zwischenfrage?
Ich wollte es nur kurz in Relation zum iPhone setzen, weil das iPhone ist A8 Design, also Cortex A8, und ist bei 600 MHz, glaube ich, also ist sozusagen allein nur von der Sache her, kann man schon mal davon ausgehen, dass es wieder doppelt so schnell sein wird, und ich rechne eigentlich auch schwer damit, dass sie diesen A4 Stein auch ins iPhone bringen. Vielleicht ist es nicht der A4, sondern das ist dann der A5, oder was weiß ich, oder 4,2.
Oder A3, eine kleinere Version von dem in dem...
Genau.
Aber es wird diesen sauer.
Und da ist das ganze iPhone drin. Also im Wesentlichen eben Memory-Controller, und damit sparen sie sich natürlich wahrscheinlich wieder so viel Platz, und ich vor allem hoffe, ich halte auch Strom, dass eben das iPhone einerseits in Performance zulegen wird, aber vor allem auch ganz signifikant, was die Dauer betrifft. Ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, dass ihr jetzt dieses Riesenteil mit dem Riesen-Bildschirm, das war jetzt auch nochmal in diesem Interview, oder in diesem Snippet, was da mitgeschnitten wurde auf der Veranstaltung, wo sich der Mosberg mit dem Jobs unterhalten hat, wo der Jobs ja auch nochmal irgendwie unsere Steine verbrauchen, irgendwie keinen Strom. Das ist alles nur das Display.
Ja, aber es ist beim Laptop auch schon so. Drittel CPU, drittel Display, drittel Festblatt oder irgendwie so, oder drittel Rest. Und also man kann auch nicht unendlich an der CPU sparen, weil es nützt nichts, weil das Display immer noch so viel verhaut.
Ja, von daher müssen sie halt auch bei dem... Ja, keine Ahnung, wir werden es sehen. Also ich rechne fest damit, dass die Zeit, dass sie sich ihre CPUs einkaufen, ist vorbei. Also in dieser Kategorie. Und mich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn ein Nachfolger vom Apple TV demnächst auf so einem Stein basiert. Wenn man sich anschaut, was das Ding für eine...
Mal, ob der HD schafft, ist noch eine spannende Frage.
Der schafft HD.
Das, was die jetzt da drin haben, schafft HD? Ich würde sagen, es hat schon seinen Grund, warum das Display so eine relativ geringe Auflösung hat.
27p macht der einfach mal locker nebenbei. Ey, das ist kein Problem, das iPhone 3GS schafft HD 720p auf... 1080p.
1080p?
Wie?
Was muss ich dafür tun?
Na, da eine Datei drauf spielen, die 1080p ist und dann über einen externen Videoausgang abspielen.
Und dann hat man 1080p?
Hab ich gelesen, hab ich nicht selber ausprobiert.
Ich bin auch skeptisch, da bin ich echt skeptisch.
Wie auch immer. Also er hat keinen Videoausgang, um alle Pixel zu machen, sondern über das, was er halt hat, nämlich diesen Videoausgang. Darüber kann er es halt rausbringen, aber er kann diese Dateien processen. Das kann dieses Gerät unter Garantie.
Ich weiß nicht, wie 1080p abgespeichert wird, wäre in dem zu sagen meine spannende Frage. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die Informationen so gepackt sind.
Das machen die ja auch nicht mit der CPU, das machen die mit ihrer Abspiel-Hardware.
Ja, aber auch die müssen sie erst mal gut genug hinkriegen.
Die ist da drin. Das können die.
In einem Mobiltelefon?
Da ist auch OpenGL drin.
Ja, da ist OpenGL drin, aber das ist halt...
Das ist auch ein hardwarebescheuertes...
Das sind moderne Computer. Wir reden nicht mehr über so...
Ja, aber die kleinen Intel Atoms schaffen kein HD.
Naja, das ist deren Problem.
Das Ding kann bis 27p spielen, steht hier.
Das ist die offizielle Speck, ja.
Na ja, aber wie gesagt, ob man es...
Ich hab Berichte gelesen vom iPhone, wo Leute das einfach mal mit 1080er-Dateien ausprobiert haben und sie haben es abgespielt.
Also ich weiß, dass ein Apple TV kein 1080p kann, das hat man ja neulich, das Thema. Das kann 720p mit Myonote.
Naja gut, aber ich meine, dieser Cortex A9 Stein, das ist moderne CPU-Technologie. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das Ding nichts kann, sondern das ist einfach ein hochmoderner Prozessor, der eben insbesondere die Fähigkeit hat, wenig Strom zu verbrauchen. Das war schon immer die Stärke von ARM. Und da sind sie halt einfach so richtig gut. Und ich habe auch so langsam den Eindruck, dass gerade in diesem Segment, wo Intel ja ganz schön rumstrauchelt, also mit ihrem Atomprozessor und wo sie ja gerne hinwollen, weil da geht ihnen einfach gerade ein Riesenmarkt weitgehend flöten, dass sie da herzliche Schwierigkeiten haben werden, sich dort zu behaupten. Und dass dieses x86 Everywhere, dass wir uns da mehr von trennen können, als wir so dachten. Und auch hier so Geräte wie zum Beispiel die Time Capsule oder die Airport Extreme und so weiter. Alle Geräte. Das sind ja alles Armgeräte. Da sehe ich jetzt auch relativ wenig Gründe, warum sie da den Prozessor von einem anderen Hersteller kaufen sollten, wenn sie denn hier sein eigenes Design haben. Also sie können ja, gut, sie brauchen jetzt diese 3D-Fähigkeiten nicht unbedingt da reinbauen, aber da machen sie sich dann halt einfach auch nochmal einen Design, wo das eben nicht der Fall ist.
Ne, dann nehmen sie die, die vom Band fallen, wo die GPU kaputt war. Ja, so macht man das. Wenn bei irgendjemanden, wo die Chips irgendwie vom Band fallen, wenn ein Korn nicht geht, dann markieren sie den als Single-Korn, dann wird der so verkauft. Was denkst denn du?
Ja gut, Hauptsache, da reichen die Stückzahlen auch aus. Wir müssen mehr kaputte Chips produzieren.
Das ist ja so, wenn sie dann Single-Korn nicht genug haben, dann kriegst du einfach einen mit Dual, wo sie irgendwie die Sicherung für Dual durchgebrannt haben. Da wird mit dem Laser dann immer am Ende vom Band hier...
Das war doch damals schon beim 6850 so.... dass sie plötzlich angefangen haben, PowerMax...
Das Gleiche ist hier mit den Gigahertz- und Megahertz-Zahlen. Da ist das auch so. Wenn sie nicht genug klein haben, kriegst du einfach ein Geräuschen, der ist nur anders gelabelt.
Also im Chat fliegt gerade ein Link raus von Engaged. Da hat ich gelesen, dass 1080p HD Video Playback in 3GS drin ist. Das ist alles ganz modern. Wie haben die das hingekriegt? An der Stelle kann ich nur sagen, bravo. Dadurch stellt sich Apple auch mal wieder ganz anders auf. Jetzt sind sie wirklich in der Lage, ihr Gerät von Grund auf wieder von den Steinen her zu definieren. Früher, muss man sich erinnern, hat Apple das ja auch schon gemacht. Das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues. Nur mit der Ausnahme, dass sie bisher nicht auch noch ihre eigene CPU designt haben. Aber sie haben alle anderen Chips, also die ganzen Firewire, IO. Chips, ihre generellen Systemcontroller, Pipapo. Das war eigentlich fast auf jedem Apple-Mainboard in der Power-PC-Zeit. Da steckte mindestens zwei oder drei oder vier Chips drauf, wo ein Apple-Logo drauf war.
Die hatten ja dieses Grand Central, was es jetzt als Grand Central Dispatch Slip gibt hier für Software. Die hatten sie ja früher als Chip, der hieß auch Grand Central. Und das war auch deren Chip, der irgendwie alles gemanagt hat. Und deswegen hieß er halt Grand Central. Und noch lauter andere so eine.
So, kommen wir jetzt mal vielleicht so ein bisschen zu dem Gerät selbst nochmal. Also, es gibt sechs Gerätevarianten. Finde ich ganz schön mutig. Ich glaube, da kommt noch mehr. Ja, gut kann sein, aber jetzt haben wir erst mal sechs. Und das ist ja ein relativ breites Spektrum, nicht wahr? 16 GB, so nach dem Motto. Es gibt auch Leute, die nicht unbedingt viel speichern. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass diese, dass die Zahl der Leute, die sagen, mit 16 GB komme ich aus, sehr groß ist. Insbesondere, wenn man das Ding im Wesentlichen als Remote-Control, Surfstation und so weiter verwendet und weniger so als Videospieger. Brauchst du wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal 16.
Also ich würde auch sagen.
16 GB Ups.
Aber hallo, da kommen Games ohne Ende.
Ja gut, aber wie viele Spiele, dass du da wirklich drauf hast?
Ich sag dir, dass vor Ende des Jahres ein World of Warcraft blind rauskommt.
Ach so, wie macht sich denn das World of Warcraft so mit Touch? Ich meine, was von den User-Interfaces, Anforderungen, die man so hat, hat man eigentlich so Hover und so ein Scheiß? So zeigst du mit der Maus auf irgendwas drauf und dann siehst du was?
Du kannst deine Gegner anklicken, dann sind die selected, aber im Großen und Ganzen hast du ganz viele Buttons mit den ganzen Special-Features und Tricks und Moves und Zauber-Sprüchen. Wie Hover?
Naja, ein Hover-Event ist ja das Einzige, was du nicht machen kannst mit Touch. Du kannst mit einer Maus über etwas drüber schweben.
Achso, nee, du musst schon. Also du klickst, wenn du irgendwas willst.
Okay, dann wäre das ja durchaus machbar.
Sie müssen das schon minimieren und so, aber das würde mit diesem Ding gehen. Und ich meine, alle Firmen wollen jetzt ihr Programm natürlich aufs iPad bringen, ist doch klar, ist immer so.
Ja, also ich meine, das größte Spiel, was ich habe, für das iPhone, ist 99.
Für alle Spiele perfekt.
Nee, für alle nicht. Es gibt Spiele, wenn du... Ja, ich jetzt gerade. Wir waren gerade so schön. Also für Spiele wäre es insofern, du kannst sofort, das dauert nur ganz kurz. Für Spiele, vor denen man extrem lange spielt, wäre es einfach super, wenn man sich in einen sozial akzeptierteren Raum aus dem Schlafzimmer heraus, wo bisher der PC mit Bildschirmstand herausbewegen kann und sich zu den Rest der Familie ins Wohnzimmer setzen kann und soziale Aktivität simulieren kann, während man wirklich kein World of Warcraft spielt. Ich glaube, für so Subpotentialspiele ist das extrem gut geeignet.
Nudeljump in großartigem oder Flight Control. Und auf diesem riesen Bildschirm, das muss Spaß machen.
Ich glaube, so für Nebenbeispiele ist das so für die, wo man nebenbei noch interagieren kann, das ist ganz gut geeignet, das meinte ich damit. Ohne Word of Worldcraft einmal gespielt.
Ich glaube, dass dieses Gerät wirklich, also ich würde mir immer noch keins kaufen, ich würde erst mal abwarten und erst mal gucken und ich hab mein Laptop und alles schick und so, aber dieses Touch und das jetzt in dieser Größe auf dem iPhone, das Touch ist ja schon ganz nett, aber du bist halt doch relativ beschränkt, weil da passt nicht so viel hin und so. Also weil eigentlich benutzt man das iPhone ja mehr oder weniger auch mit einem Touch, mit einem Finger. Aber bei diesem riesen Teil, jetzt kannst du echt, also stell dir vor, wirklich Flight Control, du kannst wirklich schon mit zwei Fingern da den vollen Fluglotsen machen.
Flight Control ist schon angekündigt.
Ja, siehst du, also das legst du jetzt wirklich so hin und legst da los, also ich stelle mir das schon cool vor.
Nochmal zu dem Platz 2. Ich wollte jetzt mal auf diese Gerätespezifikation nochmal raus. Also das größte Spiel, was ich habe, was ich runtergeladen habe, ist Need for Speed. Das ist ja schon relativ so, was du, glaube ich, als fettes 3D-Game bezeichnen wollen würdest, oder? Vielleicht gibt es noch ein paar fettere, aber das sind so 100 in B. Das heißt, auf dem 16 Gigabyte-Teil kriegst du da irgendwie 160 von drauf. Das ist schon eine Menge Holz. Aber da gibt es dann auch nur eins von. Ich will darauf hinaus, es wird für die meisten Leute erst mal reichen. Und ich denke, man hat Bedarf für 32 und 64 GB, dann wenn man große Filme drauf speichern will. HD, Video, das ist das, was wirklich viel Platz wegnimmt. Aber so Audio, Podcasts und Spiele, das macht am Ende nicht so viel her. Das sind im Wesentlichen die Filme. So ein Film, der frisst halt 1 GB. Und ob du nun irgendwie 10 Filme auf deinem Teil haben kannst oder 30, das macht für manche Leute dann wahrscheinlich schon einen großen Unterschied aus. Dann gibt es noch die Variante mit dem UMTS. Und das ist ja nun wirklich auch ein sehr interessanter Schritt. Du kriegst das iPad halt auch mit einem schwarzen Balken und dann kann das Ding eben 3G und es ist unlockt.
Wie mit einem schwarzen Balken.
Na du hast da, die sehen anders aus. Ach. Ist dir nicht aufgefallen? Ist dir auf der Webseite relativ deutlich wiedergegeben. Ich zeig dir das mal kurz.
Also WoW hat 16,5 GB, les ich hier gerade. Das ist auch mit meinem letzten.
Ja, aber ich meine hier GTA zum Beispiel, was ich jetzt extra für euch runter lade, nur aus rein akademischen Gründen, hat 188 MB, was ich gerade gekauft habe. Und da gab es, das war früher ohne ganze DVD-Volle.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich nicht auch für das 32 GB, aber einfach mit 16 GB kommt man einfach.
Ich glaube mir würde 16 GB reichen.
Genau, es ist einfach nicht so, dass das jetzt so eine Größe ist, wo man sagen würde, was, nur 16 GB, wie soll es denn damit surfen? Also so ist es ja nicht. Wie viel RAM das Teil hat, haben sie uns gar nicht gesagt. So, hier gucke mal auf der Webseite, das ist die Wi-Fi-Version, alles komplett Alu. Das ist die UMTS-Version, da hast du so einen schwarzen Balken, das ist halt so ein Plastik, damit eben der Empfang da richtig ist.
Also auf der Rückseite.
Genau. Aber nicht wie beim aktuellen.
Ach so, ja, das ist halt das Plastik.
Genau. Also das ist halt die Einschränkung, ist ja auch egal. Und dazu kommt halt noch der SIM-Karten-Slot. Da verwenden sie diese Micro-SIM, das hat sich ja mittlerweile schon rausgestellt. Das ist im Prinzip derselbe Chip.
Einfach nur ein kleineres Plastik drumrum, da wird man wie früher, wo es das Kettenlocher gab, wird es demnächst SIM-Kartenlocher geben. Das ist kein Witz, ich hab so ein Ding schon gesehen, hat mir einer gepostet. Ja, so eine Zange, da ist so eine Form, da legst du genau deine SIM-Karte rein, dann ist da noch mal so eine kleinere Form, die das halt ausschaltet, dann drückst du zusammen und dann ist der Rest weg. Gibt's alles schon.
Ja genau, also wir werden da auch alle unsere O2-Karten irgendwie reinstecken können, denke ich mal.
Und dann ist es weg und dann brauchst du wieder Adaptern, damit du das auch noch ins alte Phone rein kriegst. Weil sonst wackelt die ja.
Also die Hoffnung, die ich ja mit diesem UMTS-Option verbinde, ich meine, es ist unlocked, es ist einfach nur noch SIM-Karte reinstecken, Apple kümmert sich einen Scheißdreck da drum, mit wem es verkauft wird, auch wenn sie mit LTMT ein Deal gemacht haben.
Aber sie bieten die trotzdem an, ist doch relativ, also...
Was bieten sie an?
Na diese Deals, eigentlich hätten sie doch ganz sagen können, sie kümmern sich nicht.
Ja, das ist aber in den USA einfach erforderlich, weil da gibt es halt einfach nur einen Anbieter, der in Frage kommt.
Aber das ist doch großartig, dass solche Deals anbieten.
Aber das werden sie glaube ich in Deutschland so nicht machen.
Also ich werde sie einfach keine Deals anbieten.
Also jetzt ist das natürlich alles mal auf einer Gerüchtetage.
Ich meine, 30 Dollar nur für Datenflat, das ist in Deutschland teuer.
Das ist teuer. Ja, weil bei den Amis ist das auch echt, da ist es wirklich teuer.
Ja klar, aber ich sage nur, hier gibt es, doch klar.
Wo kriegst du eine Datenflat für unter 30, also bei O2? Da zahlst du 25 Euro für die Datenflat. Das ist ungefähr 30 Dollar.
Zirka mehr.
Ein Euro gleich 1,40 Dollar.
Stimmt.
Und monatlich kündbar und sowas, also bei O2 glaube ich auch, aber das ist schon, muss man auch sagen, das ist eine günstige Datenflat, also das kriegst du bei anderen nicht so günstig.
Ich gehe auf jeden Fall davon aus, dass die Telcos gegenseitig überbieten werden mit einem Tarif, der fürs iPad funktioniert. Weil in diesem Moment haben wir wirklich hier Competition und da kommen im Prinzip alle an Start und es gibt auch billigere Flats. Ich finde, Deutsch mag gerade echt keinen Überblick, aber es gibt ja diese ganzen Discounter-Angebote und vor allem Telefon fliegt ja noch dabei weg.
Aber eine echte Flat gibt es, also bei Chibo gibt es irgendwie eine, die kostet ich glaube 20 Euro im Monat, ist dann auch auf O2 basiert, also so viel Luft nach unten ist da im Augenblick nicht.
Wir werden es sehen, Tatsache ist, es wird ein bezahlbarer Rahmen sein. Das ist definitiv etwas, was du haben willst. Aber jetzt kommt meine Hoffnung. Meine Hoffnung ist, dass ich noch eine Generation MacBooks abwarten kann und dann haben die Dinge auch einen Micro-SIM.
Dass diese Micro-SIMs endlich dabei kommen.
Und deswegen auch Micro-SIM, gleich von vorne rein. Sie machen eine SIM-Karte Standard für alle ihre Devices, sie werden Micro-SIM in das nächste iPhone reinbauen, sie werden es hoffentlich auch...
Ist das Micro-SIM eigentlich nur ihr Standard? Oder ist das...
Ist ein Standard-Standard.
Ist der gleiche Chip, nur mit weniger Plastik drauf.
Das ist klar, das ist Apple ausgedacht.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist ein Standard.
Haben sie einfach eingesehen, dass man einfach platzsparen muss, kleine Geräte brauchen einfach Platz. Früher waren die Telefone einfach groß genug, da hat das nicht mehr so sehr viel ausgemacht.
Da war es ja auch noch in diesen Riesen-Karten drin, wenn man sich noch erinnert an Zennet-Telefone oder so. Da hast du deine Kreditkarte mit dem Chip drauf reingeschoben. Da gab es noch ewig lange, oder ist das bis heute noch so, dass du diese Riesen-Karte immer noch kriegst, und du kannst das Ding da rausbrechen. Genau.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur, damit du nichts hast, was du so leicht verlieren kannst. In Zukunft werden das wahrscheinlich so zwei Brechnamen sein, wo man dann so noch eine für die Micro-SIM doppt.
Und dann gibt es halt Micro-SIM-Adapter für groß wieder.
Wo ich mir bei dem Formfaktor ja nicht so ganz so sicher bin, ist, es hat kein Loch. Wackelt das eigentlich, wenn es auf dem Tisch liegt oder nicht? In dieser sinnlosen 11 Sachen, die am iPhone scheiße sind, Poster aus Österreich.
Weil es so unten so ein bisschen so eine Rundung hat, wenn es liegt und wenn du dann links oder rechts klickst, dass es dann gleich immer so anfängt zu wippen.
Genau, guckt euch die offiziellen Produktfotos an. Da sieht es doch sehr rund aus.
Ich würde sagen, das wackelt.
Es ist aber auch flach. Also es ist im Mittelbereich flach.
Ich würde sagen, es ist einfach kein Gerät, was man auf dem Tisch legt.
Na ja gut, aber das ist ja... Aber ein Tablet, was man nicht auf dem Tisch legt?
Da arbeitet man nicht.
Also zur Nutzung... Da legt man das glaube ich nicht auf den Tisch.
Doch. Wieso sollte man das nicht auf den Tisch legen?
Das war ein Handgerät.
Mein Prototyp hier, liegt gerade auf dem Tisch.
Warum sollte ich den jedes Mal so nicht?
Wieso? Nur um da jetzt mal irgendwie eine Webseite abzurufen, muss ich den doch nicht jedes Mal in die Hand nehmen.
Na doch, dafür ist es ja abgerundet, damit das schön einfach geht. Damit du leicht mit den Fingern runter hast und ich haue einfach unten an die Unterkante.
Dann kommt das Ding nach oben, dann landet es von deiner Hand. Aber guck mal, man muss doch da gar nichts. Das Ding hat doch da keine Buttons. Du musst da nie drücken.
Na doch, aber du musst doch auf dem Display rumtouchen. Dabei kann ich schon...
Genau, aber nicht drücken.
Aber wenn du tippst, ich glaube, dann würde es schon anfangen zu wackeln.
Hast du noch nie dein iPhone am Tisch? Guck mal hier, ich drücke schon den Knopf und dann geht es schon hoch.
Ja, aber das iPhone hat den Bildschirm auch nicht so ganz... Ach so, wir müssen ja den Rande dann auch abziehen. Sie werden es ausprobiert haben, ich habe dazu nichts gelesen und ich frage mich, was damit irgendwie ist. Ja, und was sie dann auch getan haben, ist die Sache mit der Tastatur. Und das muss ich sagen, haben sie auch in einem Maße getan, mehr als ich dachte. Dieses Dock mit der Tastatur, wir hatten es ja schon erwähnt. Da ist ja die Tastatur so richtig da dran getackert. Es ist nicht so, dass es eine Tastatur dafür gibt, sondern das ist so mit Dock. Und dann steht es halt auch senkrecht. Das ist ja was ich, also wie es übrigens, das ist auch noch ein Punkt, wo ich mich ein bisschen gefragt habe.
Aber das ist Bluetooth-Tastatoren unterstützt.
Genau, das habe ich auch gehört. Das heißt, man wird...
Ist das sicher, dass es Bluetooth-Tastatoren unterstützt?
Das ist sicher, dass es Bluetooth-Tastatoren unterstützt. Das heißt, man wird jetzt hier diese normale kleine Bluetooth-Tastatur, mit der jeder EIMEC kommt, wird man verwenden können. Und die ist ja auch sehr praktisch. Und vor allem, wenn man das mal hier so größentechnisch vergleicht, unwesentlich länger als das Teil selber.
Also, als Sie während der Keynote das Tastatur-Doc gezeigt haben, da habe ich gedacht, ich falle vom Glauben ab. Das hätte ich für absolut nicht möglich gehalten. Ich behaupte, das ist ein Gerät, das wird es ein halbes Jahr geben. Und ich würde sagen, das ist auch so designt, dass jedem klar wird, nee, das willst du nicht wirklich.
Doch, ich glaube, das wird ein Riesen-Erfolg, dieses Teil.
In dem Moment, in dem du diese Tastatur benutzt, kannst du das Gerät nicht mehr benutzen. Was? Das finde ich das Lustige daran. Wie willst du das machen? Das Doc ist nach hinten hin relativ kurz, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Das kippt doch weg, wenn du dann auf dem Display rumtatschst. Du kannst es nicht mehr auf den Schoß nehmen. Du kannst es nicht mehr so nehmen, wie es...
Aber du musst doch nicht drücken. Es ist doch ein Touch-Display. Du musst da gar keine Kraft aufwenden.
Ja, aber das ist doch, guck mal, das Gerät ist dafür da, dass du dich auf die Couch setzt. Ich meine, sie haben das extra, sie haben es doch wirklich gemacht. Sie haben ein kleines Wohnzimmer auf der Bühne aufgebaut, haben sich ein Sofa gesetzt.
Aber die Tastatur mit Doc ist doch nicht für die Couch.
Genau, diese Tastatur macht es unmöglich, das Gerät so einzusetzen, wie es gedacht war. Genau das sag ich hier. Du kannst es nicht drehen mehr?
Das halte ich jetzt erstmal für eine Behauptung.
Du kannst es nicht mehr drehen?
Das musst du doch erstmal ausprobieren.
Aber das ist doch das Ding, das dafür ist, wenn du dein iPad auf den Tisch stellst.
Aber warum sollte ich das tun wollen?
Weil Leute am Tisch sitzen manchmal?
Na, weil du es lesen willst. Du willst dich nicht immer wieder rüber beugen. Das ist ja so ein Problem, wenn das auf dem Tisch liegt. Du willst dann mal was nachschlagen, dann musst du dich immer rüber beugen. Es mag ja einen guten Einfallswinkel haben, aber es ist immer noch bequemer, sowas mehr oder weniger frontal anzuschauen, als aus so einem schrägen Winkel. Also ich finde das völlig in Ordnung. Ich habe bloß ein ganz anderes Problem mit diesen Docs.
Nee, nee, nee, Moment mal. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Warum will ich was?
Warum willst du das am Tisch? Also am Tisch hast du ein Laptop. Wer ist dafür gemacht?
Ich habe auch einen Doc für mein Telefon.
Ja, aber nicht, um es zu bedienen, oder?
Doch.
Du bedienst es da drin? Du lässt es, du nimmst es nicht.
Ja, warum sollte ich es denn sonst, wozu sollte ich denn sonst einen Doc haben? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keinen Doc. Okay, es lässt sich nicht besonders gut bedienen. Ich finde, es müsste weiter nach hinten gekippt sein. Das ist aber bei diesem Teil der Fall. Aber ich kann es halt sehen. So, wenn es auf dem Tisch liegt, dann muss ich mich halt immer erst rüber beugen.
Wenn eine SMS kommt oder sowas. Aber wenn du es bedienen willst, dann nimmst du es doch dann wieder aus dem Dock raus, oder?
Wenn ich es länger verwenden will. Aber manchmal will ich es ja auch explizit laden lassen. Es soll ja laden.
Du willst den Ladezyklus nicht unterbrechen.
Und ich will es aber trotzdem manchmal auch benutzen, während es lädt. Ja klar, vor allem singt er dann ja jedes Mal gleich wieder und so weiter.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich keinen Dock habe.
Neben Kriegsschauplätze. Was mich jetzt ein bisschen gestört hat, ist, der Olle Jobs hat in der Keynote gesagt, man könne dieses Gerät auch während es singt verwenden, um zum Beispiel eine Slideshow dort laufen zu lassen. Und das Ding als Bildschirm, als Picture Frame.
Nicht während es singt, sondern während es nicht gelockt ist.
Ich habe die Stelle jetzt kurz vorher nicht nochmal gefunden, aber wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, sprach er explizit davon während es singt.
Also auf jeden Fall im Log-Screen. Oder sagen wir mal, während es lädt.
Das Ding ist bloß, als Picture Frame möchtest du das Ding natürlich quer haben. Ja, ich schon. Bilderrahmen ist einfach mal quer.
Hast du mal gesehen, wie das aussieht, diese Bildfunktion da unten?
Also je nachdem. Schon mal so ein Gruppenfoto gemacht, das ist doch, ach so, das ist quer, aber es gibt ja auch Portrait und Zeug und alles.
Ja, aber ein Bilderrahmen ist einfach mal quer. Ich würde mal sagen, 99 von 100.
Das Ding hinten, was den Bilderrahmen macht, kann man noch drehen.
Dennis, 99 von 100 Bilderrahmen sind quer. Wie auch immer, ich hätte gerne die Wahl. Das Ding ist nur, das Teil hat halt nur einen Dock-Connector. Und ich kann das Teil nur vertikal docken. Wieso?
Die haben doch gesagt, es hat zwei Connectoren.
Hat es aber nicht. Hat es nicht. Das war ein Gerücht vorher. Aber das hat sich nicht bestätigt. Ich habe mir das irgendwie alles angeguckt, wo da irgendwie die Dinger sind. Und einen zweiten Dock-Connector konnte ich irgendwie nicht so richtig entdecken. Das heißt, du kannst das Teil halt auch nicht im Landscape-Modus dann in diese Tastatur reinstecken.
Ja, dann passen wir einfach Ihre Slideshow ein bisschen an. Na guck mal, du hast doch in den Videos mal gesehen, wie die aussehen.
Vielleicht ist es kein Big Deal.
Diese Dinger packen mehrere Fotos gleichzeitig drauf und arrangieren die dann so, dass es hinkommt und schon ist alles dufte.
So, was habe ich denn jetzt hier von meinen Con-Sachen irgendwie abgeklickt? Ach ja, genau. Und jetzt eine der größeren Enttäuschungen, also wo ich jetzt wirklich mal enttäuscht war, neben dieser ganzen Computer ist zum Sinken nötig. Das Teil kann als Präsentationsgerät verwendet werden. Und die Keynote-Software, mit der du nicht nur Slides machen kannst und bearbeiten kannst, sondern halt auch präsentieren kannst, die kannst du dann eben sozusagen direkt als Präsentationsgerät verwenden. Allerdings musst du dazu an deinen Dock-Konnektor einen Adapter anschließen und dann kann das Teil VGA. Da hab ich zwei Probleme mit. Erstens, warum hat bitte Apple vor einem Jahr Mini Display Port eingeführt? Ein super Mini-Port, mit dem man sogar in so einen iMac hinten reingehen kann. Und dann bauen sie ein Gerät, was externes Video-Out haben soll, im Prinzip ein Computer ist und in diese selbe moderne Infrastruktur sich rein, klingen soll und es hat kein Mini Display Port.
Weil Beamer VGA haben und kein Mini Display Port. Und weil ich nach wie vor glaube, dass es...
Ja, aber das gilt ja dann für MacBooks genauso.
Und weil ich glaube, dass es nach wie vor die Auflösung nicht schafft.
Was will ich die Auflösung schaffen?
So eine fette hohe Auflösung, dass es nicht vernünftig flüssige Animationen auf so einem großen Display hinkriegt.
Erstmal hat das nichts mit hoher Auflösung zu tun, sondern mit digitaler Ansteuerung, damit das irgendwie ordentlich aussieht. Und zweitens sehe ich überhaupt gar keinen Grund, warum dieser Stein in diesem Gerät nicht in der Lage sein soll, großen Bildschirmen ansprechen zu können.
Weil er zu schwachbrustig ist.
Das ist wie mit diesem 1080p. Das können die Dinger jetzt einfach.
Viele können das nicht. Also ich meine wirklich, dass die Netbooks jetzt HD können, das ist ein total neues Thema.
Ich kann nicht erzählen, dass sie da einen Grafikstein drauf haben, der irgendwie OpenGL 2.0 macht und irgendwie OpenCL und was nicht alles, aber er ist nicht in der Lage, eine Bildschirmauflösung anzubieten, die größer als VGA ist.
Und da drauf noch die totale 3D-Animation hinzukriegen, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ist ein totaler Seiteneffekt.
Ist mir auch egal, auch 1024x768 könnten sie ja auch per Mini Display Port rausgeben, dann könnte ich das Teil halt an meinen iMac anschließen. So kann ich das nicht an meinen iMac anschließen. Dann bräuchte ich erst noch irgendein Converter von irgendwie VGA zu Mini Display Port. Also das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Man hätte doch hier schön die Infrastruktur nutzen können, hätte das Ding einfach noch einen Mini Display Port dran gehabt, dann alles wäre prima. Wenn du dafür jetzt einen Bildschirm haben willst. Wenn du deine Präsentation damit machen willst. Das zweite Problem, was ich mit der Präsentationssituation habe, ist, das Teil hat ja auch Features, um so Highlighting zu machen. Das heißt, nicht nur, dass du dann deine Slides damit irgendwie anzeigst und eben nicht mehr deinen Laptop brauchst. Nein, du kannst das Ding auch benutzen, um die Slides direkt am Gerät weiterzumachen. Zu sagen Next. Und auch um zu sagen Highlighting. Irgendwas einkreisen und so weiter ist ja super. Mit so einem Adapterkabel und dieser ganzen fetten 20kg VGA-Strippe, die du normalerweise bei solchen Präsentationen vorfindest, damit willst du das Ding nur in der Hand halten?
Genau das glaube ich nämlich, dass das...
Das wird einfach rausfallen.
Also ich hoffe mal, dass die einfachen... Also dass das vielleicht auch ein Grund ist, warum sie da nur VGA rauskriegen, dass sie ein extrem dünnes VGA-Kabel hinbekommen haben. Weil das war ja damals schon...
Hätten sie Mini-Displayport nehmen sollen? Hätten sie weniger Kabel gehabt als bei VGA?
Hier im Chat tauchte gerade auf, dass die Mini-Display-Transfiber wohl extrem teuer sind im Vergleich zu einem VGA-Chip. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber ich weiß nicht, was die Dinger kosten. Aber ich weiß noch, dass sie damals bei den iPods, um mal ganz weit zurück zu gehen, als Firewire-Kabel noch ungefähr unterarmdicke hatten, gefühlt, dass der iPod plötzlich ein extrem dünnes Firewire-Kabel hatte. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie das auch mit dem VGA-Kabel hinkriegen.
Ja, aber trotzdem muss er irgendwann den Beamer daran anschließen.
Ja, du hast halt einfach ein 2 Meter langes... Ein 2 Meter Apple VGA-Kabel.
2 Meter reicht nicht aus, wenn du das in der Hand hälst. Dann nur da ein bisschen hin und her. Ich meine, ich will doch auf einer Bühne... Ich sag dir, was ich will. Ich will W-Lan.
Ja, das wäre natürlich... Und dann so eine kleine Box, die du auf den Beamer draufstellst und die das dann für dich anschließt. Das wäre natürlich der totale... Aber wir wollen das gleiche.
Mit dem Teil, wenn wir noch rumlaufen. Ich will so eine Presentation-Box haben, wo hinten ein VGA- und Mini-Display-Port rauskommt und dann soll dieses Teil das per Netz machen.
Du machst das einfach per Apple TV. Das Apple TV hat WLAN schon drin. Apple TV hat einen hochauflösenden Display-Ausgang. Hat die Rechenpower, um das hinzukriegen?
Super Idee.
Sie haben eigentlich alles schon da, was du brauchst. Du brauchst nur noch neue Software drauf spielen.
Aber auch kein Mini-Display-Port. Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. So ein Gerät könnte tatsächlich eine Rolle übernehmen. Das wäre dann wirklich eine geile Präsentation. Mit so einem Teil in der Hand. Das wäre schon echt schick. Sonst müsste es halt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie willst du es sonst halten? Dann musst du da am Tisch sitzen, und dann hast du das Ding auf dem Tisch. Das ist einfach so, kann man nicht präsentieren.
Die meisten Leute stehen bei der Präsentation sowieso unter einem Pult oder so. Viel rumrennen macht man jetzt auch nicht. Dann muss man es sowieso die ganze Zeit quer halten. Ich glaube, das geht schon so halbwegs.
Was ich mich noch gefragt habe, wird das Ding irgendwie AirTunes unterstützen?
Als Lautsprecher oder als Abspielgerät?
Sowohl.
Als Lautsprecher behaupte ich mal nicht. Obwohl, ist das iPhone mittlerweile eigentlich ein AirTunes-Gerät auch nicht, oder? Ich glaube, das wird da auch nicht der Fall sein. Aber zum Ansteuern tendenziell kann ich mir das sehr gut vorstellen.
Kannst du das zum Ansteuern?
Kann das iPhone auch nicht.
Also mit dem Remote kann man den Rechner fernsteuern und schon noch einstellen, dass der Rechner über die AirPod X etwas abspielen soll.
Jetzt sind wir aber wieder bei Oma. Ich geh immer davon aus, ich hab nur noch dieses Gerät. Das ganze Internet ist gerade voll davon zu diskutieren. Old-Style-Computer und wir werden alle keine Programmierer mehr und New-Style-Computer. Endlich kann man diesen ganzen Scheiß mal benutzen. Dann möchte ich aber auch die Möglichkeit haben, mit dem New-Style-Computer auch meinen New-Lifestyle auch durchzuziehen. Und dann muss ich auch in der Lage sein, diese Musik, die auf diesem Teil drauf ist, irgendwie rauszudrücken. Das fehlt diesem Teil. Das ist genau wie mit diesem Drucken. Das muss eigentlich noch nachgeliefert werden.
Na klar, das ist ja auch eine erste seiner Generationen. Kommt natürlich noch.
Also ich glaube, dass du dieses... Ich kann mir diese Idee von der universellen Fernbedienung, also das iPad, als Fernbedienung für alle meine Home Appliances, die möchte ich jetzt nochmal ein bisschen pushen. Steve, wenn du dir das wieder mal anhörst, hast du ja auch sonst gut auf uns gehört, dann bau das mal ein.
Aber das Fernbedienung ist doch nur so voll das Abfallprodukt an Features, weil niemand kauft sich hier so ein mindestens 500 Euro Gerät als Fernbedienungsersatz.
Nein, wie gesagt, nicht als Fernbedienung, ich hab da große Tasten drauf, sondern als Fernbedienung von wegen, wenn ich Musik hören möchte, dann hör ich mir da mit Musik an, und zwar nicht über diese kleinen, blechernen Monodinga da drinnen, sondern spiel die gefälligst auf meine Anlage ab, die Musik, die ich jetzt da gerade auswähle.
Hast du so ordentliche Lautsprecher, wie sieht's da eigentlich aus? Also ich hatte unten die drei Ausgänge, aber so richtig, die Qualität kann da auch nicht rauskommen. Nö, da kommt bestimmt nichts tolles raus.
Und ich meine, da sind wir Erdchirms gigantisch. Dass ich dann einfach meine Boxen an oder meine Anlage starte.
Das sind natürlich alles so Sachen, die das Fernsehen dann wahrscheinlich... Das kommt dann alles mit iPhone und S40. Tja, und grundsätzlich, was sagen wir jetzt also zu dem Teil?
Ich bin erstmal weiter auf Abwarten. Also es wird bestimmt ganz nett, es wird eine Menge Sachen ändern. Also vielleicht wird es dafür sorgen, dass in Zukunft MacBooks vielleicht ein Touch-Display kriegen. Muss man mal gucken.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Wieso nicht? Wenn sie der Meinung gewesen sind, dass das eine sinnvolle Erweiterung ist, dann hätten sie das schon längst getan. Also das ist Quatsch.
Ich hab neulich als wir...
Das lag aber auch daran, weil früher das Touch immer das Display so hässlich gemacht hat und man irgendwie so einen Schleier drüber hat und nichts mehr ordentlich sehen konnte.
Das lag auch darin, dass man die Hand nicht so die ganze Zeit in der Luft halten möchte. Sie haben auf dem Ding kein Betriebssystem, was touch-tauglich wäre.
Also wenn das wäre, dann Apple.
Geht es euch nicht auch so, dass das Mac OS X User Interface einem einfach mal so antik vorkommt mittlerweile?
Das ist nämlich, das finde ich einen interessanten Punkt und zwar hat, wir saßen zusammen während der iPad-Präsentation, haben uns in einer Kneipe getroffen und da war Roddy dabei und der meinte, wie lange wird es eigentlich noch dauern, bis Apple das klassische Mac OS einfach einstampft? Oder beziehungsweise, bis die zusammen... Das iPhone OS.
Sehr, sehr lange wird das dauern.
Das wird noch eine Weile dauern, aber sehr, sehr lange wird das dauern. Bis das vernünftig zusammengeführt wird.
Was ist denn vernünftig?
Außerdem ist es doch das gleiche OS. Es ist nur, das eine macht Touch, das andere macht halt nicht Touch.
Das sind komplett andere User Interfaces. Was sind?
Ja, reden wir von den User Interfaces.
Wir reden von den User Interfaces. Das mag die selber Entwicklungsumgebung sein, aber es ist heute nicht möglich, für beide Plattformen gleichzeitig zu entwickeln.
Die Frage ist ja, was sagt der Markt? Wenn der Markt nach Universal Computer schreit, dann wird es auch Universal Computer geben.
Weiter geben, klar.
Wir müssen uns jetzt alle eigentlich fragen, angesichts dieses iPads, was sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Sind wir im Wesentlichen so Konsument und dann editiert man noch so ein bisschen was? Oder sind wir wirklich so Hardcore-Erzeuger? Ich meine, für Leute, die Programmierer sind und so ist natürlich so ein Gerät keine Option. Ganz klar. Für Leute, die High-End-Bearbeitung von was auch immer machen, ob das Tonbild, was auch immer ist, ist das alles nicht auch nur im Ansatz eine Option. Also es gibt einfach noch einen riesen Katalog von Arbeitsschritten.
Vor allem, dass die Programme ja erst mal kommen.
Ja, und ich sehe halt auch nicht, wie man... Also vor allem da muss erst mal der Mindset hinter diesem Touch hinterher kommen. Jetzt haben wir so eine erste Vorschau darauf gesehen, wie sich Apple selbst das unter Umständen mal vorstellen kann, wie man eben mit Dokumenten interagiert. Inwieweit das jetzt bei den App-Developern ankommt, wie lange das dauert, bis das dann auch bei Apple richtig funktioniert. Ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass es, wenn es rauskommt, werden jetzt erst mal alle wieder schreien. Ich meine, sie schreien ja jetzt auch schon, aber dann schreien sie halt nochmal. Und wahrscheinlich wird es auch eine ganze Menge berechtigte Sachen geben. Letzten Endes, denke ich, wird das iPad seinen Markt begründen. Also es gibt viele Leute, die eigentlich sowas haben wollen. Es gibt viele Leute, für deren Konsumentenverhalten das vollkommen ausreichend ist, weil sie tatsächlich nichts anderes auf ihrem MacBooks machen, als sie dann auf diesem iPad auch tun können. Also all diese ganzen Dinge, die wir schon besprochen haben, das sind up for that und das kostet sie weniger. Du hast weniger Stress mit so einem Teil, das geht einfach nicht so leicht kaputt. Da hast du nicht so viele bewegliche Teile. Das ist irgendwie alles viel netter. Du kannst es an viel mehr Orten mitschleppen und mitnehmen und trägt nicht so dick auf. Es wiegt die Hälfte von einem MacBook Air. Und ein MacBook Air macht schon einen riesen Unterschied, wenn du unterwegs bist. Das Netzteil ist wahrscheinlich auch noch kleiner. Sodass ich glaube, dass sich da einfach was ganz interessantes herausbilden wird.
Aber ich glaube auch so, was es an Applikation überhaupt erstmal ermöglicht. Also stellt euch davon, vernimmt ihr das Garage Band auf diesem Gerät vor? Und zwar jetzt nicht so sehr als Aufnahmegerät für Tonspuren, sondern als Musikinstrument, eine virtuelle Klaviatur, wäre plötzlich denkbar. Ist auf so einem normalen Gerät nicht vorstellbar. Moderne Musikinstrumente, Zeichenprogramme. Also es gibt Anwendungen, die heute, wenn sie überhaupt möglich sind, ein Schweine Geld kosten, die du in Zukunft mit einem Gerät für 500 Dollar und eine Applikation für 10 Dollar hinkriegen kannst. Das wird einschlagen wie eine Bombe.
Wie eine Bombe, meinst du? Meinst du, die machen gleich im ersten Jahr, werden sie so richtig viel verkaufen oder das wird sich erstmal schleppend entwickeln?
Ich glaube, es wird so ein paar Monate dauern, bis es warm wird. Ich glaube, was sie jetzt haben, ich glaube, die Killer-Applikation von dem Ding ist, sie haben sich hingesetzt und gesagt, Touch ist ready for serious computing. Also das, was wir ja auch alles sagen. Wir haben echte Applikationen, die man bisher nur vom Mac kann, die auch explizit nicht das iLive-Paket, sondern das iWork-Paket haben sie übertragen auf das kleine Teil. Das wird hoffentlich jetzt auch größere Firmen, die bisher sich relativ wenig um dieses TouchOS gekümmert haben, dazu animieren, nochmal zu sagen, Moment mal, damit kann man doch ernsthafte Sachen machen. Insofern glaube ich, werden wir es demnächst an jedem DJ-Pult sehen, wo bisher noch die Macs dabei sind und die MacBooks.
Ja gut, aber das ist natürlich kein Massenmarkt. Ich meine, dass jetzt DJs sowas auch noch verwenden.
Es wird unglaublich schnell in den Alltag einfließen, meine ich damit. Also es wird sehr viele Anwendungen geben, wo man einfach sieht, wow, dafür kann ich das Ding auch benutzen. Das meinte ich mit Bombe einschlagen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht von den Verkaufszahlen.
Für mich ist eigentlich die größte Frage, kann dieses Gerät verwendet werden in einem Environment, in dem es sonst keine Computer gibt? Also wenn man wirklich davon redet, dass das ja ein Rechner ist für Leute, für die ein normaler Computer nichts ist, dann muss dieses Gerät auch überleben in einer Umgebung, wo es sonst keine anderen Computer gibt. Und da bin ich wieder ganz am Anfang. Ja, aber da fehlt mir einfach die Infraschutten. Wieso stelle ich die Frage falsch? Ich habe ernsthaft über dieses Oma-Problem nachgedacht. Weil meine Eltern wollen jetzt irgendwie auch mal Internet haben. Und ich war schon die ganze Zeit so hin und her gerissen. Da haben wir jetzt erst mal dieses Videokamera-Problem, daran wird es wahrscheinlich schon mal von vornherein scheitern. Sagen wir mal, das wäre jetzt nicht so das Ding, weil ansonsten nämlich das Internet zur Kenntnis nehmen und bestimmte Dienste dann eben auch mit speziellen Applikationen nutzen und so weiter. Super! Trägt dünn auf, ist also auch in einer vollgeräumten Wohnung, die natürlich nicht schon Platz für Computer und Arbeitsplätze bereithält. Ist das Ding irgendwie kein großer Störfaktor. Und auch für Couchpotatoes und Leute, die sich nicht so viel bewegen können oder wollen, ist das halt auch super. Ich meine, alte Menschen und so weiter, allein so das zum Computer gehen und so weiter, das findet da einfach in dem Maße nicht statt. Aber wenn das Ding wie die Fernbedienung auch so mit am Sofa liegt, dann ist das einfach eine ganz andere Sache. Und dass du im Prinzip auch in jeder beliebigen Position da konsumieren und kommunizieren kannst, das ist ein super Teil. Nur, wie stelle ich halt sicher, dass du mit diesem Teil keinen Datenverlust hast. Wenn du da jetzt monatelang in dieses Gerät Fotos reinmachst und dann geht es kaputt und deine Daten sind weg, ich weiß die Lösung. Das geht nicht. Ja, was? Mobile Me oder was? Den vollständigen Inhalt.
Infrastruktur bereitstellen. In die Cloud synchronisieren.
Dein falscher Inhalt steht ja nicht sofort. Der füllt sich ja langsam und auch langsam wird es dann halt weggesyncht.
Und da das ein Always-On-Gerät ist, was du nicht irgendwie schlafen legst oder sowas, was immer instant ist, dann kann der doch im Hintergrund synchronisieren. Ist mir noch wurscht. Und wenn das drei Tage dauert über mein dünnes DSL, dann dauert es eben drei Tage. Legt das internen Prioritäten fest.
Aber sie haben über Mobile Mi nichts gesagt.
Ja, aber das ist was, was sie noch in Software nachlegen können.
Hätten sie einen Preis nennen müssen.
Ich glaube, ich kann mir gut vorstellen, oder ich rechne fest damit, dass das noch kommen würde.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, was ist Mobile Mi? Mobile Mi heißt, du singst ein paar von deinen Daten.
Jetzt müssen sie halt erweitern.
Aber wohin? Bis hin zu Complete Backup?
Was hast du da großartig?
Kann ich mir ein neues iPad kaufen im Laden, ich schalte es ein und kann sagen, hier ist mein Mobile Mi Account, Restore vom Backup.
Was muss denn dafür geladen werden? Alles. Zum Beispiel Apps. Apps sind sowieso schon bei Apple. Die brauchst du nicht nur irgendwo zu merken.
Also nichts mit meinem Mobile Mi Account zu tun, sondern mit meinem iTunes-Account.
Bei Mobile Mi könnt ihr sich merken, welche Apps habe ich gekauft. Und die Musik. Musik kann er sich auch merken, Video-Shows kann er sich auch merken.
Aber er kann sich nur die Musik merken, die ich gekauft habe.
Wie heißt dieser Dienst, den sie eingekauft haben? Lala oder so was?
Wie kriege ich denn überhaupt meine Musik auf dieses Gerät? Wenn du sie kaufst. Ja, wenn ich schon ein Regal habe mit irgendwie 30 CDs.
Dann brauchst du einen Computer dafür. Also wenn du CDs hast, ich meine, welche Möglichkeit bürte sich denn da?
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt, es bürte sich zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, diesen SD-Karten-Adapter oder USB...
Und wie kriegst du die Musik auf eine SD-Karte? Und dann an das USB-Laufwerk, CD-ROM-Laufwerk anschließen? Oder was an den USB-Adapter?
Oder an eine Festplatte anschließen, wo die Musik drauf ist.
Na, von jemand anderem. Ja, in dem Moment, in dem da irgendjemand mit einem Computer da ist, der dir für dich die Musik rippt, kann der auch das Pad rasch anschließen und dann sagen, alles klar, jetzt spiele ich dir diese Musik einmal drauf.
Trotzdem müssten die Daten halt komplett gesichert werden. Also es müssten alle Daten auf diesem Teil gesichert werden.
Genau, und ich sage, das ist gar nicht so unglaublich viel.
Naja, das könnten halt bis zu 64 Gigabyte sein.
Wie gesagt, wenn du dir viele Apps kaufst, Apps brauchen nicht explizit gesichert werden, sondern mussten in Informationen gesichert werden, dass du sie hast. Fernsehszen, Filme, Musik, die du alle über Apple Store gekauft hast, muss auch nicht gesichert werden, sondern nur die Information, dass du sie hast. Irgendwelche...
Ist mir alles klar. Der Punkt ist, es gibt diesen Dienst nicht. Derzeit gibt es diesen Dienst nicht. Wir haben auch so etwas nicht angekündigt.
Bei Apple so etwas nie angekündigt.
Es gibt einfach ein großes Fragezeichen. Womit ich viel besser leben könnte, ist, warum kann ich nicht einfach eine externe Festplatte kaufen und die per USB anschließen und dann macht das Teil Time Machine da drauf.
Weil es keine USB hat?
Natürlich hat das USB. Wo? Am Dock.
Es gibt ja einen Adapter, mit dem kannst du deine Kamera anschließen.
Es gibt auch einen USB-Kamera-Adapter. Da hab ich ihn gerade auf dem Bildschirm. So sieht hier übrigens der... Das ist der VGA-Schwanz hier. Das ist auch noch so 20 Zentimeter. Und es gibt halt diesen Kamera-Adapter. Einmal mit SD-Karte reinstecken und einmal mit USB. So. Und der Dock, das Dock hat USB 2.0. Das ist sozusagen ein Teil von diesem Dock. Die Kommunikation machst du über USB. Und ich sehe relativ wenig Gründe, warum man nicht auch eine Festplatte anschließen könnte, die dann eben vollständig von Time Machine übernommen wird. Das heißt, sie müssten im Prinzip Time Machine in iPhone OS integrieren und die Möglichkeit bieten, dass eine Festplatte, auf diese Festplatte legst du dann nichts anderes an.
Ja, aber das würde das ganze Konzept von dem Gerät zerstören.
Warum?
Weil dieses iPad ist, du hast ein Gerät, um das du dich nicht kümmern brauchst.
Ja, und du hast ein anderes Gerät, um das du dich auch nicht kümmern brauchst. Das schließt du einfach an und dann...
Du hast ein Gerät, so das ist das einfach. Und das jederzeit einsatzbereit ist, du musst es bloß hin und wieder laden und schon ist es immer verfügbar. Wenn du dann plötzlich, hey, du musst mal wieder deine Festplatte, sondern hast du genau diesen Punkt, den du vorhin hattest, nicht dick auftragen... Time Capsule? Das wäre eine Option, die theoretisch sogar noch besteht.
Ja.
Da spricht ja nichts dagegen eigentlich. Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass das kommen wird, sondern ich glaube, dass sie das wirklich hoffen.
Warum nicht? Warum soll man sein iPad nicht auf eine Time Capsule sichern? WLAN hat das Teil?
Sie könnten es, wenn sie wollten. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es wollen.
Warum sollten sie es nicht wollen? Da würden sie mir Time Capsules verkaufen und man könnte dieses Teil getrost irgendwo hingeben und die Leute hätten ihre Daten noch. Also, ich sag's mal ganz kurz. Time Machine über WLAN. Das sollte dieses Teil können. Und dann wäre diese Time Capsule irgendwie eine gute Idee. Und dann wäre ich zufrieden. Gibt's nicht, also bin ich nur nicht zufrieden. Wenn sie das einbauen, kann ich das Leuten einfach so verkaufen.
Also, was ich daran zu bemeckern hätte, wäre weniger die... Also, Backup und Syncing in einem. Hätte ich gerne. Und zwar weil, was ich jetzt total doof finde, dass ich immer dieses, dass iTunes nach wie vor dieses begrenzende Ding ist. Und jetzt sagen alle, da muss eine neue Syncing-Software her. Nein, da muss ein Scheißdreck eine neue Syncing-Software her. Das muss irgendwie einfach gehen. Einfach aufgrund dessen, dass ich ein iPhone habe, dass ich ein iPad habe, dass ich ein Mac habe. Das kriegen sie alle hin. Also, dass meine Adressen synchronisiert sind. Das ist ja nun wirklich gar kein großes Ding mehr. Und das soll gefälligst mit all meinen Daten funktionieren. Das soll, wenn ich mir Musik auf meinem Mac kaufe, dann soll das die wenigen Minuten oder Sekunden später auch auf meinem iPad drauf sein und auf meinem iPhone. Und ich hab gar keinen Bock, mir Gedanken darum zu machen, wie sie da drauf kommt. So soll das gefälligst funktionieren. Und so soll das mit allen Inhalten sein. Wenn ich Fotos in iPhoto mache, soll das gesynchronisiert werden. Auf jeden Fall eins mit 3G. Und da weiß ich noch nicht, mit wie viel Gigabyte. Weil ehrlich gesagt, nur um 64 Gigabyte zu haben, da nochmal 200 Euro draufzulegen, das ist relativ fett, finde ich.
Und später ärgert man sich dann aber, wenn man die nicht hat.
Ja, mag sein, aber bei meinem iPhone habe ich etwas mehr als 16 Gigabyte belegt. Ich komme nicht ansatzweise an die 32 ran.
Ich bin auch seit einem Monat auf über die Hälfte. Seit einem Monat lohnt es sich, dass ich mehr habe als 16.
Und wofür ich das brauche in erster Linie, ist für Musik, die ich unterwegs dabei haben will. Und da ich das iPad nicht zum Musikhören nutzen würde, dafür habe ich mir gerät.
Dann würde ich vielleicht mehr Filme draufgucken.
Und mehr Spiele spielen.
Nee, Filme würde ich auf meinem Apple-TV tendenziell gucken.
Unterwegs?
Ich gucke unterwegs eigentlich nie Filme.
Habt ihr vielleicht auch schon mal nachgedacht, dass vielleicht das Gerät gar nicht für euch ist?
Doch, das Gerät ist was für mich. Das Gerät ist was, wenn ich zu Hause vom...
Hab ich drüber nachgedacht. Hab ich mich ja schon zu geäußert, oder?
Und?
Naja, die Oma-Kompatibilität kommt, wenn es einen Backup gibt.
Du bist doch aber gar keine Oma.
Aber das Ding wäre auch nicht gegeben.
Ob es für dich was ist?
Für mich ist es definitiv was, ja.
Also schon so jetzt, wie es ist, auch wenn es alle deine Probleme sind, die du schon so hast und die nicht behoben werden.
Es ist eine super Ergänzung für das Eigenheim.
Du hast doch ja dein Laptop.
Fast in jedem Zimmer hat das Ding eine besondere Bedeutung, wo ich derzeit halt entweder mein iPhone oder ein MacBook benutze und beides ist scheiße. In der Küche ist es einfach mal der 1a das Kochbuch. Ich koch fast eh nur aus dem Internet heraus, von daher wäre das einfach wunderbar. Derzeit muss immer irgendwie zum Rechner gegangen werden, ausgedruckt werden und dann legt man sich das da hin.
War das nicht letztes Mal?
Ich weiß jetzt so für das Gerät, das Gerät ist für alle, die sich das Internet ausdrucken, weil dann können sie sich einfach mal auf den Bildschirm lassen, das Internet und sich hinlegen.
Genau, deswegen brauchst du vielleicht auch keine Druckfunktion. Im Wohnzimmer ist es einfach super, um einfach mal, ja so...
Couch surfen sag ich ja.
Couch surfen, aber auch eben Fernbedienen so von Home Automation, dein AV-Garten irgendwie fernsteuern.
Das Ding, also so als Familiengerät, wird das so Multiuser unterstützen? Verschiedene Lock-ins?
Nee, ne? Nein.
Das ist aber schade eigentlich.
Ich glaube auch da würde ich wieder sagen, mach das Konzept von dem Gerät kaputt, dass es sofort da ist.
Du meinst jeder nur ein Kreuz? Jeder nur ein iPad?
Ja, aber als Familiencomputer, ich meine, Mama, wo ist denn der iPad?
Ja, stimmt schon.
Nee, das ist okay, aber ich meine, nimmt das einfach, was willst du? Na großartig, ist ja nicht so als...
Aber wenn Mama da ihre E-Mails auf dem iPad verwaltet, dann will die das nicht in Kids rausrücken, dann geht das ganz schnell schief.
Das ist aber ein echter Punkt. Ich finde auch mehrere... War da nicht irgendwas... Warte mal, jetzt klingelt irgendwas in meinem Kopf. War da nicht irgendwas mit... mehr...
Also ich glaube entweder...
Es sagt einer, das iPad kann mehrere Profile, wurde schon geleakt. Ich hab da noch nichts von gesehen. Die brauchen immer Links, Jungs. Ohne Links geht gar nichts.
Wir glauben euch kein Wort.
Pics or didn't happen.
Aufzeichnung der Demo. Ich hab die Aufzeichnung der Demo. Jetzt sagt mir mal, wo das ist und dann guck ich mir das hier gleich noch mal an. Kann man das auch noch mal einspielen? Wir könnten das auch mal zusammenschneiden und diese ganzen... Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch so oft einen Single, der mit ihrem Scheiß irgendwie amazing und wie amazing das doch alles ist und amazing...
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ich höre das gar nicht mehr.
Baseball oder auch mal ein bisschen darüber rumraten.
Ach, du musst die Stelle mit den Netbooks finden.
Das ist ganz am Anfang.
Das iPhone kann mehrere Profile? Aha, würde ich aber gerne mal sehen, wo.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ganz genau.
Hat jetzt irgendjemand hier im Chat gerade behauptet, dass das iPhone mehrere Profile könne. Das iPhone.
Das iPhone, ach so.
Configuration Profiles, das sind einfach die normalen 3G Configuration Profiles.
Genau, so wie auf dem iPhone auch.
Das gibt es auf dem iPhone auch schon. Das hat nichts mit User-Profilen zu tun. Das ist nicht das, was wir jetzt meinen. Was sollte ich jetzt hier nochmal mit dieser Stelle machen? Mit der Netbox irgendwie?
Die wurde im Bildschirm zitiert, das kannst du ja einmal in Stream reinwerfen.
Was wurde da zitiert?
Das, was er gesagt hat, war auch irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen. Das heißt, man muss als Text sehr zu erkennen sein.
Ja gut, aber das ist irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden.
Da, da, da, jetzt.
Ja, Netbook und dann?
Dann sagt er es doch gleich.
Was sagt er dann gleich?
Dass sie für nichts gut sind.
Darüber reden wir doch gerade gar nicht. Wir reden über die Profile oder nicht?
Ach so, das haben wir doch geklärt.
Ja, was haben wir denn geklärt?
Dass es nicht geht. Dass das Bild das nicht aussagt, sondern dass das halt für diese Profile zählt.
Ja, aber ich finde auch so multiple User. Aber wie würde man denn das machen? Log-Screen und dann...
Also schaltest du es ein, kommst ins Screen, und dann hast du da verschiedene User mit deinem Bild, die du halt kennst, dann klickst du drauf und bup bist du drin.
Ohne Passwort.
Dann hast du zumindest schon mal eine Unterscheidung, wenn der Mama nicht will, dass man in ihren E-Mails rumfummelt. Vielleicht ist halt auch nur das E-Mail-Programm protected. Oder vielleicht ist das auch pro Programm. Kann man mehrere User anlegen. Also bestimmte Programme brauchen ja gar nicht Multi-User. Also zum Beispiel die Fernbedienung, da ist eigentlich egal welcher User das benutzt. Vielleicht ist es immer erst per Programm statt, dass es dann fragt, welcher User bist du denn gerade. Das ist ja vorher gar nicht wichtig.
Das würde ich so scheiße finden.
Ja, wenn du nur einer bist, brauchst du da nichts einrichten. Guck mal, was du scheiße finden wirst. Das geht mir so auf den Sack. Und zwar gibt es immer Leute, die sagen, das finde ich alles scheiße und das ist voll blöd. Aber es gibt halt auch andere Leute als ich. Es gibt halt Familien wie Tim, mit Frau und Kind. Und der würde scheiße finden, wenn es halt mal nicht geht.
Und du hast ein Problem damit, wenn dein 3-jähriger...
Was kannst du denn für ein Problem damit haben, wenn du es doch gar nicht benutzen musst? Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel auch nur einen User. Ich habe da gar keine Probleme damit, dass es mehr User kann.
Das ist aber auch eine andere Kiste.
Also es wäre schon gut. Dann kannst du halt einfach so ein Gerät in der ganzen Familie verwenden, sonst nicht. Ich meine, wenn ich mal meine Termine anschauen will oder mein E-Mail anschauen will.
Dann nimmst du dein iPad und ist gut. Und wenn dein Kind ein Spiel spielen will, dann gibst du ihm dein iPad und dann spielt das.
Und wenn weitere Familienmitglieder ihre Mail lesen wollen, dann kaufen die sich ein iPad. Das ist doch genau das, was wir sagen. Du meinst, jeder nur einen kreuzt.
Stimmt, weil es dich ja nicht stört. Du musst ja dann keine vier Geräte kaufen.
Naja, aber ich meine, jedes Mal, wenn ich das rangehe, hier nicht diesen Unlock-Button zu haben. Stell dir das vor, du müsstest, anstelle, wenn du an dein iPhone ran willst, müsstest du erstmal ein Passwort eingeben.
Muss ich. Weil ich es gelockt habe. Weil ich will dieses Feature. Und wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, du brauchst dieses Feature nicht, dann nutzt du das Feature nicht. Aber zu sagen, das ist voll doof, ich will das nicht, die sollen das nicht einbauen, ist doch voll bekloppt.
Das Gerät ist für einen anderen Bereich gedacht. Das Multi-User, das macht nur andere Dinge kaputt, die man nicht haben möchte.
Du willst es nicht haben.
Also für so ein Teil, was im Wohnzimmer rumliegt, ist es schon ein bisschen was anderes, als ein Telefon, was man in der Hosentasche hat. Also ich kann verstehen, wenn sie es nicht machen. Das ist ja auch Komplexitätsreduktion. Nach dem Motto, am Ende kauft ihr euch ja sowieso jeder euer eigenes, aber eigentlich ist das irgendwie doof. Man sollte halt das auch anders haben können. Aber dann kann man sich halt auch eins so einrichten, wo dann niemand seine Meldung hat. Dann gibt es dann irgendwie nur den gemeinsamen Familien-Account.
Weil es ist doch eindeutig für eine Familie, wo das Ding zu Hause rumliegt, alle werden dieses Ding benutzen wollen.
Ja.
Und wenn man da drüber Filme gucken kann, alle wollen irgendwie Filme gucken. Dann hat Papa da irgendwie, nee es geht nicht. Also entweder ist es offen, dann will ich aber auch wirklich nicht E-Mails drauf haben, so.
Und es stellt sich auch wieder die Frage nach dem Home-Server. Erneut.
Na die sollen ihre Mac OS X Server Software mal anpassen, dass die halt mit diesen Dingen irgendwie alles managt.
Ach Mac OS X Server Software, achso.
Das ist kein Gerät für Leute, die ein OS X Server sich da auch sehen stellen.
Ich habe jetzt noch einen Bericht nachzuliefern, fällt mir gerade ein.
Sind wir schon fertig mit iPad?
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich wollte nur kurz anmerken, dass ich noch einen Bericht nachzuliefern habe, weil ich ja auf diesem Apple-Veranstaltung war. So, jetzt gucken wir mal hier, ich guck mal, wollt ihr euch noch ein bisschen streiten, dann guck ich mal kurz durch die Wave. Was wir denn davon jetzt hier irgendwie schon, also diese Großeltern-Kompatibilität, die ist auf jeden Fall ein heißes Thema. Also ich glaube, das diskutieren wirklich viele Leute.
Also ich glaube, dass es keinen Home Server geben wird, dass Apple sowas nicht macht, sondern dass es einfach darüber laufen wird, wir werden schnelles Internet haben und damit hat sich der Salat. Also ich meine, ich habe jetzt zu Hause einen VDSL50 und bin das erste Mal in der Situation, dass mein WLAN die langsamste Komponente ist in meiner ganzen Infrastruktur. Das heißt, ich kann theoretisch schneller aus dem Internet Daten runterladen, wenn ich es per Kabel mache, als per WLAN. Das wird in Zukunft eher die Regel sein als die Ausnahme. Warum soll ich mir dann auch irgendwie zu Hause einen Home Server hinstellen, wenn ich dafür, wenn ich das auch irgendwo sonst umpacken kann?
Du bist mal wieder der ohne Familie. In der Familie hast du einfach mal genau dieses Problem, dass du Daten für alle haben willst. Du willst, dass alle die Musik haben und du willst, dass alle die Filme haben.
Ja, und warum, dass da nicht irgendwo... Ich sage, das ist ein Synchronisationsproblem und das gehört in die Wolke.
Die Wolke ist aber bei mir in der Wohnung. Da kommt einfach der HD-Film, kommt da einfach nicht schnell genug aus dieser Wolke. Weil dieses Internet einfach im Zweifelsfall nicht funktioniert. Und schnell ist es auch nicht.
Also wie gesagt, im Zweifelsfall ist dein Internet schneller als dein WLAN. Insofern... Also bei mir ist es der Fall.
Nur weil ich Musik hören will, gibt es die ganze Zeit meine Internet-Leitungenplatte und kann nichts anderes mehr machen. Das ist doch Quatsch. Ich finde das Quatsch.
Dafür stellt ihr ein eigenes Gerät für ein paar tausend Euro hin.
Paar tausend Euro? Mein Gott, die sind scheiß Mac Mini verkaufen. Für welchen Preis? Tausend Euro.
Tausend Euro.
Da ist keine Software drin.
Achso, der Server.
Der Mac Mini-Server kommt mit Mac OS 10 Server und es gibt keine Software da drauf, die in irgendeiner Form meine Medieninhalte verwalten würde. Das ist der große Fail. Microsoft hat sowas.
Die sind geil, die sind cool. Die haben halt vorausgedacht.
Ja, die wissen Bescheid. Die haben Erfolg.
Die haben halt mehr Fokus auf ein Gerät oder OS. Nicht so tausend verschiedene Sachen.
Ich krabbel hier gerade mal durch die Wave und lass mal Sachen, die wir noch nicht angesprochen haben, einfach mal so fallen. Musikplayer im iTunes-Style. Ist euch das auch schon aufgefallen, dass das alles sehr viel mehr iTunes-iger aussah als auf dem iPhone?
Ja, das hab ich jetzt auch nochmal. So mehr Platz.
Haben wir da einen Ausblick auf iTunes X bekommen?
Genau, das ist nämlich die Frage, die ich mir auch stelle.
Das war ja mein Kritikpunkt von Anfang an.
Du hast ja dann einen Coco geschrieben.
Und kein Coverflow.
Kein Coverflow?
Ja. Habt ihr irgendwo Coverflow gesehen?
Es gibt gar kein Coverflow mehr. Das iTunes muss doch Coverflow sein.
Ich weiß nicht. Habt ihr eins gesehen?
Ich hab keins gesehen bisher, das stimmt.
Ich guck nochmal. Design. Irgendwo war doch hier auch iTunes-iges Zeug. Ich hab viele Videos gesehen.
Sagen wir's mal so, wenn es kein Coverflow hätte, hätte doch Steve Jobs da erstmal 4 Stunden Coverflow gerollt. Oder hat er vielleicht? Nee, hat er nicht. Und hätte uns sein Bob Dylan-Album gezeigt.
Bob Dylan hat er gezeigt. Bob Dylan war wieder dabei.
Ja, aber nicht per Coverflow.
Nee, stimmt. Sondern sie hatten nur diese Popovers, diese Teil, was dann so hoch geht. Und dann konntest du da halt irgendwie das sehen. Video, YouTube, da ist auch kein Coverflow dabei. Ich seh keinen. Doch! Nee, doch.
Doch.
Hier, Upstore.
Im Upstore jetzt sogar, ja.
Aber hier in dem iTunes gibt's nichts, oder? Songs, das ist leider so klein hier. Nee, hier gibt's nur die Genres, also beziehungsweise was du dir anschauen willst, wonach du sortieren willst. Aber es gibt keinen Button, mit dem du einen Coverflow aktivieren kannst. Also zumindest seh ich keins. Und der iTunes-Store hat das auch nicht.
Aber guck mal, der...
Nur der Upstore ist hier so was...
Der hat so ein Coverflow-Ding.
Coverflow-artiges.
Das könnte auch ein Screenshot sein im Upstore.
Es ist noch nicht...
Obwohl, das wird schon funktional sein.
Naja, klar, ich meine, wenn sie das so zeigen, dann ist das schon so das, was sie meinen. Aber gut, werden wir sehen, ob sie das beibehalten. Auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie nicht mehr so da. Das würde ich wirklich sehr begrüßen.
Aber iTunes haben sie ja auch explizit in dieser Queransicht gezeigt. Und da ist es ja viel besser so als irgendwie anders.
Keine Stiftbedienung, mein Gott Leute.
Ich hab ja so einen Pogo-Stick. Damit kann man dann auch ein iPhone, damit kann man bestimmt auch ein iPad bedienen. Kennt ihr das Ding? Habe ich schon mal gezeigt.
Was für ein Stick?
Ja, diesen Stick, mit dem man das iPhone bedienen kann.
Hast du den gezeigt? Du hast wahrscheinlich dieses Mal auch deinen Palm-Prix vergessen. Ich habe ihn jetzt mal ein bisschen benutzt. Ja stimmt, ich habe Coverflow auf meinem Dingsbums drauf.
Allerdings wird der mit jeder Software schneller. Das ist ja so ein Stick, so ein Stift, mit dem man das iPhone bedienen kann. Also der hat vorne so eine hautähnliche Oberfläche drauf. Der leitet einfach durch. Der Gedanke war, dass man, warum ich das gekauft habe, um zu testen, ob man damit auch mit nassen Fingern das iPhone bedienen kann, vernünftigt.
Pixel-Dichte, das wird hier noch...
Ja, die ist geringer als auf dem iPhone.
Verwundert ja auch nicht. Ich meine, das iPhone hält sich ja auch viel näher an deine Fresse. Also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass du das Display auch mit einer anderen Wechselauflösung machen kannst.
Ich kann kurz mal hier noch ein Thema aufgreifen. Da gab es die Frage, ob es den Texte-Reader für das iPad geben wird. Kann ich natürlich nicht beantworten, weil das ist ja nicht meine Entscheidung. Aber die ganzen alten iPhone-Programme laufen ja auf dem iPod in eine normale Auflösung oder mit dem X2-Button in eine doppelte Auflösung. Da hast du noch ein bisschen Platz, weil wenn man die Auflösung vom iPhone doppelt rechnet, dann bleibt immer noch ein bisschen Platz zur iPad-Auflösung. Aber dann ist es so, dass beim Programmieren du kannst da irgendwie eine Zeile reinschmeißen und dann sagst du deinem bisher schon existierenden iPhone-Programm, dass es halt die größere Auflösung geliefert kriegt und dann kannst du dein App gleich anpassen. Das heißt, wenn du zum Beispiel diese ganzen, so wie Contacts, wenn du da sowieso nur Apple-Table-Views benutzt, dann musst du dich ja nicht um irgendwelche Größen kümmern, sondern du machst ja halt immer nur diese Zeilen und Spalten und Zeug oder die Zeilen sind es. Und dann ist alles automatisch in Größe. Oder wenn du zum Beispiel ein Programm hast, was irgendwie die Map anzeigt in einem Fenster, dann musst du dich ja auch nicht um eine Größe kümmern. Du machst das Fenster also auf, in der Größe, wie das iPhone ist. Und wenn du sagst, es soll halt die Größe vom iPad übernehmen, dann zack, ist dein Map-Fenster dann in der neuen Größe. Also man muss nicht viel anpassen, wenn das Programm schon relativ generisch ist.
Das würde mich sowieso mal interessieren, wie hoch der Anpassaufwand ist. Also diese Menüs, diese Pop-Up-Menüs, die jetzt überall in den Leisten auftauchen, die sahen mir immer so aus wie diese halbstatischen Dialogen oder halbmodalen Dialoge in der alten Software oder auf dem iPhone. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass diese ganzen Layer, die so um drüber packen, exakt die Breite hätten von einem iPhone-Layer. Und ich hab mir gedacht, das ist doch wahrscheinlich...
Also so genau hab ich es jetzt noch nicht geguckt.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich kein Zufall, sondern dass sie einfach das machen, was hier auf dem Ding ein eigener Dialog ist, wo sich dann der Bildschirminhalt komplett ändert, dass du das auf dem iPhone einfach so machst, das wird dann einfach daneben gestellt. Viele Applikationen sind ja so aufgebaut.
Könnte schon sein.
Es würde mich echt mal interessieren, wie viel mehr Entwicklungsaufwand man hat, wenn man fürs iPad entwickeln will.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass man viel mehr hat, weil man hat einfach viel mehr zu verwalten wegen dem Screen Space. Du hast dann nämlich nicht nur eine Tabelle, sondern wie die Mail-Programm, du hast halt die Tabelle und den Inhalt so. Aber ich denke, man muss das alles schnell zu machen.
Ich hoffe mal, weil das könnte ich mir nämlich echt vorstellen, dass das ein ziemlicher Stolperstein wird, dass es jetzt erstmal dann möglicherweise auf dem iPhone, die Software nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wird, weil sich alle wie Blöde auf das iPad stürzen oder umgekehrt, dass das iPad nicht so richtig in den Markt kommen wird, weil es zu viel Aufwand ist, iPhone-Software vernünftig zu portieren.
Ist kein Aufwand. Ja, vernünftig. Ich meine, guck dir die 100.000-Forts-Applikation an. Seit wann wird denn da was vernünftig programmiert?
Na ja, es gibt schon ein paar vernünftige Applikationen. Aber da Twitter kleint oder sowas.
Die wird es ja dann auch weiterhin geben. Leute, die sich Mühe geben und bezahlt werden oder die halt eine coole Firma dahinter haben, die sich halt kümmert, wird es dann geben. Die werden natürlich schön ein Special-iPhone-Programm machen und es passt ein iPad-Programm.
Sie machen es auch nur, wenn sich der Aufwand lohnt. Also zum Beispiel bei...
Aber es geht ja bei vielen Programmen gar nicht um den Aufwand. Da geht es ja auch um Marketing und Zeug. Die verdienen auch gar kein Geld damit, wollen aber ein cooles Produkt draußen haben.
Na ja, aber ich möchte schon, dass die Leute, die Software fürs iPhone machen, damit auch Geld verdienen. Das ist ja Sinn der Sache. Und wenn ich mir zum Beispiel jetzt hier tweet hier diesen Twitter-Client angucke, auf dem Mac und auf dem iPhone, die iPhone-Version wird ständig weiterentwickelt, ist mittlerweile der Mac-Version um einiges voraus. Die Mac-Version dümpelt so vor sich hin und geht nicht weiter. Warum? Vermutlich verdienen so eine iPhone-Version deutlich mehr Geld. Oder ist das der Aufwand?
Bei Echo Phone ist es nicht so. Da kannst du jetzt beliebig viele andere Vergleiche ziehen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich denke mal, das kommt immer auf den Fall an. Und natürlich wird man auch da dann mehr entwickeln, wo sich das Programm mehr lohnt. Und auf dem iPad kannst du auf jeden Fall mehr machen. Hast du mehr Möglichkeiten, würde ich sagen. Aber wer weiß, wie viel iPads dann so verkauft werden, wie groß der Markt ist, wie die Leute so kaufwillig sind und so. Mal gucken, was sich da auch so für Preise durchsetzen. Apple hat jetzt hier mit dem iWorks, haben sie gesagt, 10 Dollar pro Applikation von diesem iWorks. Da muss man mal gucken. Aber natürlich wird es da auch die Cheapskates geben, die alle irgendwie Zeug raushauen, ihre billig iPhone-Apps irgendwie portieren und dann irgendwie da diese 79 Cent haben wollen. Vielleicht sagt Apple sogar, hier Jungs, iPad ist unser Minimumpreis, ist jetzt einfach mal 2 Dollar.
Zack!
Das werden sie nicht tun, glaube ich.
Das werden sie nicht tun.
Warum sollten sie die Best Seller abschalten?
Egal. Ich meine jetzt, wollt ihr noch weiter da irgendwie glaskugelig irgendwie machen? Ich habe hier gerade so noch ein paar andere Sachen gefunden, hier in der Wave. Diese Public Wave ist wirklich hilfreich, muss ich sagen. Also es ist schon eine gute Erfindung. Viele Leute können ja mit Google-Wave-Dienst anfangen, aber ich glaube für Podcasts ist echt ein Segen. Hier wird natürlich dieses leidige Thema Flash aufgegriffen. Wollen wir das irgendwie auch noch mal aufgreifen?
Ja, den Demovideos ist wohl Flash zu sehen. Bei Steve gab es ganz prominent nur das Plug-in zu sehen. Der hat genau dafür gesorgt, dass man sieht, dass es nicht geht. Da kann man jetzt auch munkeln. Ich würde sagen, Apple mag keinen Flash-Punkt. Es ist aus dem Demovideos raus.
Ich fand das so geil, dass er wirklich so genüsslich da mit diesem blauen Lego-Steinchen in die Notär. Nee, ich meine, hätte er es als peinlich empfunden, hätte er eine andere Seite gezeigt, dann hätten die das nicht gemacht.
Er hat prominent gezeigt, dass es nicht geht.
Ich glaube, wem er das gezeigt hat, war der New York Times. Was, ihr seid auf der Homepage, auf dem iPad seht ihr so aus und ihr habt immer noch kein Video. Warum eigentlich nicht? Ich meine, es ist mittlerweile kein Problem mehr. Was ich allerdings auch nicht gesehen habe, war inline-Video in einer Webseite. In dem Sinne, ist das überhaupt machbar? Ich meine, du kannst zwar dein Video so anbieten, dass wenn du dann da draufklickst, also auf dem iPhone jetzt, dass dann dieser Videoplayer aufgeht. Was ich mir erwartet hätte eigentlich von dieser Demo, ist, dass man eben auch inline-Video in einer Webseite sieht.
Jetzt soll das noch mal kleiner.
Na ja, ich hab was gesehen.
Ja, ich meine, du kannst auch zoomen und...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es in der Webseite gesehen habe, auf jeden Fall war es in der New York Times App. Da haben sie gezeigt, wie sie ein Video inline abspielen.
Ja, in einer Applikation. Ich rede von einer Webseite.
Na ja, aber was haben die da anderes als ein Webview in der New York Times App?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall gehe ich mal davon aus, wenn es das entsprechende Widget für die New York Times App gibt, dass es das dann auch...
Sie haben es nicht gezeigt. Das ist alles, was ich sage. Sie haben es nicht gezeigt, aber sie haben gezeigt, dass es eben mit Flash nicht geht.
Also das hätte ich gerne inline, fullscreen und fullscreen auf dem Fernseher, so, der Videos abspielen kann. Dafür soll der Button sein.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall gab es natürlich gleich wieder diese Diskussion mit ohne Flash habt ihr ja nicht das ganze Internet und bla bla bla und Adobe ist irgendwie beleidigt. Es gab da so ein paar interessante Blogposts, wo sie so ein bisschen rumgeweint haben und dann irgendwie so jetzt könnt ihr den ganzen Porn nicht mehr sehen und überhaupt und warum hauen denn immer alle auf Flash so ein und wir sind doch ganz lieb und ohne uns geht es ja kein Video und was nicht alles, das mag ja alles richtig sein. Erinnert aber nicht an der Tatsache, dass das halt irgendwie ein Schmerz ist.
Na ja, aber es ist doch auch mal ganz nebenbei erwähnt, hat irgendjemand gesagt, auch Moment mal, bisher gibt es doch noch gar kein Flash für ARM vernünftig.
Da sind sie irgendwie dran, aber das ist ja nicht der Grund.
Naja, aber sie könnten nicht mal liefern, selbst wenn Apple jetzt sagen würde, Adobe, jetzt Flash.
Ich denke, der Nexus One hat das.
Das ist irgendeine Beta-Version. Die ist noch nicht total fertig.
Wie auch immer. Ich kann Apple so gut verstehen, dass sie das rauslassen und ich kann auch sehr gut verstehen, dass sie ihr Momentum an der Stelle irgendwie nutzen. Trotzdem muss man sich natürlich schon fragen, wenn ich mir jetzt ein iPad kaufe und ich möchte in der Erwartungshaltung heute mir das Internet anschauen, dann ist es klar, dass ich eben bei vielen Inhalten einfach gegen die Wand laufe und es wird auch definitiv nicht für jede Webseite, die für mich irgendwie interessante Videos hat, eine Applikation geben, geschweige denn die Bereitschaft, diese dann auch immer zu laden und zu benutzen.
Na, aber was es gibt, ist mittlerweile bei vielen großen Video-Hostern, dass die dann einfach eine MP4-Werke, also dass sie dann auf dem iPhone dir einen MP4-Link einfach anbieten. Das gibt es bei Vimeo.
Ja, Vimeo, aber wo klicken die Deutschen drauf? Spiegelonline.
Bei FSC Karloch schreiben sie, dass aus den Demo-Videos das Flash wieder verschwunden ist.
Das war ja auch ein bisschen unklug, das da so zu machen. Aber was ich ja auch gerade sehe, ist, dass Omni Group sagt in einem Blogpost, dass sie alle ihre großen Productivity-Apps aufs iPad bringen wollen.
Ach was.
Wer sagt das?
Das sagen alle Firmen jetzt.
Wer denn noch? Alle. Wie alle?
Sag ich jetzt mal so.
Ja behauptest du, aber du weißt es nicht.
Ist doch aber auch so, oder? Also ich meine, klar, wollen jetzt alle.
Du meinst Photoshop für iPad? Das bezweifle ich aber, dass das kommt.
Die haben doch auch so eine Mini-Version. Die haben ja auch sogar ein iPhone-App oder nicht?
Kannst du dann ein Bild rotieren und irgendwie outlinen?
Haben die nicht auch ein iPhone-App?
Ja, die haben aber das kann nichts.
Ist doch egal.
Nee, auf ein iPad?
Das ist nicht das, wovon ich rede. Die reden davon, dass sie irgendwie Omni-Graphel, Outliner, Omni-Plan, Omni-Focus und auch ihren Graph-Sketcher aufs iPad bringen. Und das bedeutet, dass sie ihre komplette Mac OS X GUI-basierte User-Interaktion überdenken für eine iPhone OS-basierte Interaktion. Das ist schon nicht mal eben neu compilen, sondern das heißt, komplett alles neu überdenken, aber es heißt aber auch, dass mein Omni-Outliner kommt. Und das wäre mal echt so ein Argument.
Das ist ein Traum für dich.
Dann müsste ich es singen. Quatsch, iPhoto Touch. Erster Programm? Photoshop Touch wird auch kommen.
Nein, das wird es nicht. Da haben wir gleich mal die erste Kiste Mate hier zum wetten. Das wird nicht kommen. Weil das ist wirklich die Software, für die du einfach einen Mac brauchst.
Aber es gibt noch die iPhone-Version.
Das ist nicht Photoshop.
Es ist schon klar, dass die Leute das komplett aufschaffen. Das iPad zu kriegen kann schon sein, weil es ist ja auch nur mal ein Riesenprogramm.
Nicht nur nicht das komplette. Nein, Max, darfst du nicht. Es hat nichts damit zu tun, außer dass sie diesen Namen genommen haben.
Es ist was anderes.
Das iPhone ist noch ein bisschen kleiner. Das iPad schaffst du schon ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist doch nur, weil sie das Photoshop nennen. Heißt das doch noch lange nicht?
Ja, das haben wir jetzt, Kathrin. Ihr holt jetzt beide eure Argumente. Sie sind eh gerade dran. Sie müssen Photoshop umbauen für Coco komplett.
Niemand macht Fotoretusche mit dem Finger.
Das macht keiner.
Nein, niemand wird das tun.
Das wird passieren.
Nein, bis wann?
Es wird nicht Photoshop, sobald die 64-Bit-Version draußen ist.
Du meinst innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre gibt es Photoshop fürs iPad? Und zwar Photoshop Elements.
Was denn jetzt, Photoshop oder nicht?
Photoshop Elements ist so was wie iPhoto oder nicht?
Nein, Photoshop Elements ist ein Light. Photoshop ohne Photoshop. Das kann kein CMYK. Das ist ein Photoshop Light.
Das ist ein Photoshop Touch.
Photoshop für einen Home-Anwender.
Was für Funktionalitäten hat man?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Funktionalitäten man haargenau hat. Du hast schon sehr viele Retursche-Funktionen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob die Omni-Group-Jungs alle Features nehmen.
Du hast die ganzen CMYK-Funktionen nicht. Es ist nicht für Druck, sondern für Fotos gedacht. Du hast keine Bezier-Funktion. Du hast diese ganzen Freistell-Funktionen.
Sag mir nicht, was es nicht hat, sag mir, was es kann.
Es ist ein Photoshop, was für den Home-Anwender auf Fotooptimierung ausgerichtet ist. Und dafür aber schon eine Menge Funktionen bietet.
Was heißt das? Was heißt Menge Funktionen? Welche Funktionen?
Ich hab seit ungefähr 100 Jahren...
Crop und Scale, ja klar.
Es ist schon Photoshop.
Du weißt es nicht, aber du sagst, es kommt. Aber du weißt nicht, was kommt.
Ich hab das letzte Mal vor drei Jahren damit gearbeitet und da hab ich gesehen, wow, das kann ja gar nicht sein.
Levels, wird es Levels haben? Werde ich damit Histogramme einblenden können? Levels irgendwie anpassen können? Sowas wird es fürs iPhone geben, mit Photoshop. Und so diese Art und Weise. Und verschiedene Layer und überblenden und einstellen, wie ich diese Layer ineinander einblende und Effekte machen und Dropshadow und diesen ganzen Kack. Das wird nicht kommen.
Du weißt doch auch nicht, was die Omni-Group-Jungs alles für Feature übernehmen. Da gehen bestimmt auch ein paar über uns an.
Ja, aber die sagen, dass sie ihre Programme portieren. Ich sage, Adobe wird diesen Schritt überhaupt nicht tun.
Warum sollten sie das nicht tun?
Weil es einfach genau keinen Markt gibt für diesen Scheiß. Leute, die Photoshop benutzen, machen professionelle Fotoretusche.
Und Omnigrafe gibt es im Markt.
Und die werden das auch in zwei Jahren auf diesen großen Computern machen. Die brauchen einen riesen Bildschirm, die brauchen eine Maus, weil sie jede einzelne Pixel anfahren müssen. Die brauchen viel Windows, die brauchen irgendwie dicke, fette Platten, die müssen viel speichern, die müssen viel auslagern. Die brauchen da tonnenweise Gigabyte, weise Rahmen.
Es gibt doch Millionen von Leuten, die alle nur Internet-Items machen und Zeug.
Egal, okay, stopp! Kiste, Mate, ich hab sie. In den nächsten zwei Jahren wird es nicht etwas geben, was Photoshop ist.
Da brauchen wir gar nicht wetten. Du wirst jetzt immer ausreden, dass ein Feature fehlt und es nicht erfüllt ist.
Ab wann ist das Feature erfüllt? Dass es Photoshop fürs iPad gibt?
Also Histogramme, Layer, irgendwie Layer aufeinander einzeln so überblenden und diese ganzen VD-Layer zusammenhängen.
Ich guck mal, was Photoshop drin ist.
Mit Masken und so weiter. Das ist das, was Photoshop macht. Ich mein, das ist das, was Fotoretusche macht. Won't happen.
Ich behaupte trotzdem, alle großen Firmen werden ihre coolen Tools aufs iPad bringen.
Nee, das glaub ich nicht. Ich glaub nur, dass wirklich nur die coolen erst mal anfangen werden, ihre Applikationen aufs iPad zu bringen. Und Omni Group ist definitiv, die sind definitiv cool genug.
Kann sein, dass Adobe jetzt die bösen sind und so weit sie Flash haben. Aber man muss auch sagen, wenn Photoshop so richtig scheiße wäre, dann hätte schon eine andere Firma versucht, sich von dem Markt ein größeres Stück zu schnappen. Ist bisher nicht passiert.
Du kannst das nicht, dann kriegst du sie da nicht mehr raus.
Die sind in dem Bereich gut, weil sie viele Features drin haben, die du als Endanwender tatsächlich nicht brauchst. Also sie können zum Beispiel, was sie wohl so gut können wie kein anderer, ist für die Druckvorstufe das sozusagen vorbereiten, dass du vor allem für dich drucken kannst.
Kein Endanwender braucht Photoshop.
Das brauchst du nicht. Also andere Hersteller können das ähnlich gut. Also so ein Programm wie Brushes, was sie ja nun auch gezeigt haben, das reicht ja für die meisten Sachen total aus. Insofern gebe ich da Tim total recht. Aber dass sie sich in diesen Markt, dass sie sich denen nicht... Also sie würden ihn sich vielleicht entgehen lassen, wenn sie jetzt einen gigantischen zusätzlichen Entwicklungsaufwand dafür hätten. Aber da sie jetzt...
Die müssen das doch schon deswegen machen, damit nicht eine kleine Konkurrenz starten kann, damit die schon im Keim erstickt wird, dann musst du gleich denen das Wasser abgraben. Weil sonst könnte ein Programm wie Brushes auch immer größer werden und irgendwann hast du plötzlich eine Konkurrenz am Arsch, willste nicht.
Es gibt für einen Mac tolle Programme, Pixelmater, kostet irgendwie ein Bruchteil dessen, was Photoshop kostet, kann auch eine ganze Menge...
Grafikkonverter.
Und die Pixelmater ist um einiges besser als Grafikkonverter. Aber das ist trotzdem natürlich keine Konkurrenz für Photoshop. Aber da sie, wie gesagt, ich behaupte, da sie eh dazu gezwungen sind, jetzt das ganze Zeug auf Coco umzustellen und da sowieso dran sind, wird sich da irgendjemand sagen, bei dem Moment fällt dabei nicht fast eine iPad-Version unter den Tisch. Und dann werden sie sagen, ja, irgendwie schon. Und dann machen sie das einfach.
Da gibt es bestimmt auch Firmen, die dann keinen Bock drauf haben, aber viele werden es natürlich machen.
Gibt es in dem Chat noch irgendwas, was wir unbedingt touchieren müssen?
Wir haben ja noch 60 Tage, zwei Monate, vier Sendungen oder drei Zeit, bis es dann irgendwann mal da ist. Also das Thema wird noch oft genug aufpoppen.
Ja, natürlich wird es oft genug aufpoppen. Die Frage ist, müssen wir jetzt noch irgendwas an unserem geistigen Auge vorbeiziehen lassen? Ich überleg gerade. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt sozusagen erstmal die Vision besprochen und dann sind wir in die Details gegangen. Vielleicht können wir ja nochmal an den Anfang kurz zurückkommen, was sozusagen das iPad so für eine Auswirkung haben wird. Meine These ist, es wird sich genug verkaufen, um für Apple ein lohnenswertes Produkt zu sein.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die davon ausgehen, dass sie davon echt viele verkaufen, sonst hätten sie nicht gleich sechs verschiedene. Dann sollen sie erstmal mit den kleinen anfangen und die größeren später nachliefern, wenn sie besser einen Überblick haben, was dann nun jetzt so geordert wird. Aber dass sie gleich schon mit sechs Modellen so am Start sind, ich habe das Gefühl, die gehen auch bei dem Ding mal wieder davon aus, dass es sich wegverkauft wie warme Semmel und die sind ja schon auch einigermaßen gut jetzt im Einschätzen von, was so der Bedarf ist.
Ich würde es anders formulieren. Ich würde sagen, dass sie, um Erfolg zu haben, diese Variabilität meinen, einfach bieten zu müssen. Und zwar, weil sie einfach den Spagat zwischen, also wir haben ja wirklich eine ganze Menge Szenarios besprochen, wie man das jetzt, wer es wo wie verwenden könnte. Und da gibt es irgendwie so die Linksoben-Fraktion, so WLAN only, 16 Gigabyte, das ist halt so das Teil, das liegt irgendwie in der Wohnung rum und wird dort rumgereicht und ist so das Universal-Nachschlagewerk. Wie Wikipedia gucken, Webseite machen, irgendwas bestellen, Kinoprogram checken, tralala, Apple TV fernsteuern, mal einen Film angucken und so weiter. Rechts unten, Modell, hast du den Ubergeek, der das Teil natürlich auch mit unterwegs dabei hat, der immer Internet haben will, der ganz andere Applikationen benutzt und der natürlich immer den vollen Speicherausbau haben will, bzw. das dann auch auf Reisen verwendet und explizit immer ein großes Archiv von Filmen dabei haben will. 10, 20, 27P-Filmchen, oder zumindest eben in dieser Vollauflösung 1024, 768, das muss es natürlich schon so sein, da wird wahrscheinlich erstmal wieder viel reencoded werden in der nächsten Zeit. Und die willst du halt haben und dann... Genau, dann nehmen die Filmchen halt irgendwie schon so 1,5 Gigabyte irgendwie weg. Und wenn du dann irgendwie schon mal 16 Filme hast, dann hast du deine 16 Gigabyte ja schon mal voll. Und dann denke ich mal irgendwo dazwischen gibt es dann eben auch noch so diese Anwendungsfragestunde für, da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet, was kann das iPad im Businessbereich leisten? Weil was natürlich für so ein Tablett sehr interessant ist, ist für welche vertikalen Märkte das Ding unter Umständen interessant ist, was dann auch nochmal nennenswert Stückzeilen generiert. Also Arztvisite, ja das ist schon ein bisschen ein Klassiker, aber generell mobile Datenerfassung und mobile Datenbank-Abfrage, was jetzt so Verkäufer und so weiter betrifft.
Versicherungsvertreter, für die ist das auch ein interessantes Gerät. Die bisher, ich meine, ich hab neulich...
Jetzt drucken kann, ja.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich noch das Problem. Aber die haben immer einen Drucker dabei. Aber die haben diese Riesenklötze von Rechnern dabei.
Aber die sind noch sehr lange in der Windows-Welt. Also das ist nichts, was dieses Jahr schon irgendwie greifen wird.
Natürlich sind die noch lange in der Windows-Welt, aber es gibt viele Käufergruppen, für die es extrem interessant wäre.
Also ich denke, ich bin irgendwie so links unten, Mitte unten, so irgendwie 16, 32 Gigabyte. Ja, ich will auch GPS haben und so.
Wenn die jetzt sagen würden, du kannst das Ding immer mit deinem iPhone tessern, egal, also dass das so eine Special-Erlaubnis kriegt, würdest du dann auch immer noch das mit UMTS nehmen? Das iPad. Also angenommen jetzt, wie Apple sagt.
Ah, darum haben sie gar nichts gesagt, ne? Achso, dass man das...
Dass du es nutzen kannst.
Dass du es nutzen kannst, dass du sagst, okay, es ist zwar nicht erlaubt, also das Tessing ist nur erlaubt, wenn du halt Special Deals halt mit Telekom hast für deinen Rechner, aber hier das iPad kriegt irgendwie Spezialerlaubnis, das darf immer tessern mit deinem iPhone. Würdest du dann auch UMTS ordern trotzdem? Dass du mit deinem iPhone das Netz für dein iPad machen kannst.
Da muss ich das ja immer da ranstecken.
Wie soll das da ranstecken?
Ich glaube, dann würde ich mir tatsächlich die WLAN-Version kaufen, weil...
Nee, also ehrlich gesagt, das ist für mich vollkommen unerheblich, weil ich würde dieses iPad, das sehe ich überhaupt gar nicht in Relation zu meinem iPhone.
Aber das iPhone habe ich wirklich immer dabei.
Jaja, klar, aber ich mache was anderes damit.
Ja, aber du könntest dann...
Du kannst ja mal das Netz sharen. Warum soll man zweimal... Guck mal, das sind ja immer...
Ich hätte dann meinen Twitter irgendwie auf meinem iPad.
Ja, aber er meint doch bloß, dass das iPhone, wenn das iPhone mit der Software 3.2, die dann irgendwann kommt, oder 3.1.3 oder sowas, wenn da einfach ist, nicht mehr die Ansage, kein Tethering, sondern Tethering fürs iPad. Ja, für andere nicht.
Wieso soll ich da rumtetheren und noch mal sinnlos Batterie verbrauchen, wenn jedes Gerät selber funken kann?
Weil du 130 Euro beim Einkauf sparen könntest.
Dann hast du kein GPS mehr.
Dann hast du kein GPS mehr. Ja, das ist auf dem UMTS-Chip drauf.
Es kann auch einfach sein, dass ich dieses Gerät nutze, ohne dass mein iPhone eingeschaltet ist oder sonst irgendwas, das ich telefonisch nicht erreichen will. Das kann ja auch zum Beispiel der Akku alle sein und so weiter. Also ich will einfach mit dem iPad, wenn dieses Gerät für mich eine Rolle spielt, dann muss das autark sein. Das muss es halt auch außerhalb des Hauses sein. Also Tethering spielt für mich keine Rolle, zumal ich davon ausgehe, dass ich sowieso auf dem selben Vertrag bin. Ich hab bloß zwei SIM-Karten.
Ja, es kostet, wie gesagt. Also ich würde tendenziell schon sagen, da ich glaube, dass ich das iPad, wenn ich mir eins kaufe, tatsächlich eher in einer Umgebung verwende, wo ich sowieso WLAN habe, in einem totalen Ausnahmefall über 3G, bin ich ernsthaft am überlegen zu sagen, ach, dann nehme ich doch lieber die WLAN-Version. Aber ich weiß, dass es mich so ärgern würde, die dreieinhalb Male, wo ich dann doch 3G haben wollte, dass ich zur 3G-Version tendieren würde.
Deswegen, wenn du Testing hättest, dann so das zu verzichten. So geht es mir auch. Aber ich weiß auch, das würde Apple nicht machen, weil die wollen diese 130 Dollar einnehmen. Für die dreimal, wo man denkt, das wird...
Das ist eine total alberne Diskussion.
Und mit dem GPS ist es natürlich schon nochmal ein Argument.
Und nochmal 25 Euro für die zusätzliche SIM-Karte bei O2. Die es dann hoffentlich auch als Micro-SIM gibt.
Ja, da waren erst noch Fragen im Chat. Kurz mal gucken, deshalb der genug Zeit gehabt, hier irgendwie noch Sachen zu fragen. Wieso GPS? Wozu braucht man GPS? Ach Leute, wozu braucht man GPS? Damit man weiß, wo man ist? Mein Gott!
Achso, es kam noch irgendwie das WLAN-N, warum das denn drin sei? Weil es da reingehört.
Weil das da reingehört.
Weil Apple keinen mehr findet, der was Älteres verkauft.
Ja, das hat da einfach...
Die Frage kann man nur stellen, wenn man auf einem Land wohnt, wo man nicht die ganze Zeit mit fremden WLANs zu bombardiert wird und die eigenen Frequenzen voll sind, sondern wo man auf das N-Frequenzband ausweichen muss.
Es gibt Netze, die sind N, also will ich die auch benutzen.
Und wenn man da dicke Movies auf das Ding übertragen will, das muss schnell gehen, aber man will nicht ewig warten.
Genau. So, jetzt hab ich noch ein einziges Thema für uns.
Okay, kurze Intermezzo, wir müssen uns ja immer reinmixen, bevor du uns hier voll ballerst in den Pausen. Weil ich hab nämlich noch ein cooles Tool, was ich während der Arbeit benutze, das heißt iPhone Simulator Exchange. Also ich hab so das, ich schreib halt dieses Texter-Ding jetzt und ich brauch halt auch Leute, die das ab und zu mal testen. Und die haben jetzt auch nicht alle unbedingt immer ein iPhone und so weiter. Und wie lässt man die irgendwie dieses Programm testen? Und die haben natürlich schon Max. Und die können halt Xcode installieren und da ist halt der Simulator mit dabei. Und da gibt es halt dieses Tool, das ist von Simulator Exchange. Damit kann ich von meinem Programm, was im Simulator läuft, mache ich so eine Art Installer, so Mini Installer, gebe dem Supporter das, der halt mein Programm testet. Und der kann das bei sich starten, bei dem wird es dann automatisch in seinem Simulator installiert und dann kann er dort im Simulator mein Programm starten. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool so zum Testen. Da habe ich mit dem Developer gestern nämlich ein bisschen Mini-Debug-Session gemacht, könnte man sagen. Und da gibt es jetzt eine neue Version und das ist eigentlich ganz schick. Das ist total praktisch. Ist ganz nur eine Mini-Anwendung. Macht gar nicht so doll viel, aber ist sehr praktisch. Wollte ich mal gesagt haben. Ist der gleiche Typ, der auch Grand Total und Timelock macht und so.
Und kostet ein bisschen Geld und so.
Nee, das ist iPhone Simulator Exchange, ist for free. Die anderen kosten Geld.
Ich habe hier gerade noch mal ein paar schöne Sachen. Doch.
Das Thema ist, das ist schon so vor 10 Minuten gewesen.
Okay, und zwar haben sie jetzt den iPhone Simulator gehackt. Das ist ja gerade, lese ich irgendwie, auf ein Gadget. Und haben ein paar Features freigeschaltet, die Apple gerne noch geheim halten möchte. Und zwar ist das wohl...
Wie freigeschaltet? Entdeckt?
Entdeckt, naja, die sind im Augenblick noch versteckt, auch im Simulator, und die haben sie jetzt irgendwie freigekriegt. Also es ist erst mal Rechtschreibkorrektur. Location-Aware-Ads-in-Maps.
Rechtschreibkorrektur ist doch nichts Neues.
Nein, ein richtiges... Rechtschreibkorrektur? Es gibt nur diese Type-Korrektur, aber eine echte Rechtschreibkorrektur, die mir auch Vorschläge macht oder sowas. Na, hab ich bisher noch nicht gesehen.
Der macht doch Vorschläge. Du meinst mehrere Vorschläge.
Na, erstens mehrere Vorschläge und zweitens nicht nur, wenn ich einen ähnlichen Buchstaben, sondern wenn ich irgendwie Apfel ohne P geschrieben habe, dann schlägt er das nicht vor.
Doch.
Nein, wenn ich ja Apfel eintippe, dann sagt er...
Ich hab schon die unmöglichsten Wörter geschrieben und er hat das Richtige erkannt.
Nein, das macht er nicht, wartet mal. Doch, doch.
Ach, Quatsch.
A-F-E-L, schlägt er mir Adel vor.
Ja, ist halt passender als...
Es ist keine Rechtschreibkorrektur.
Doch.
Es ist eine Tippkorrektur.
Das basiert aber auf einem Wörterbuch.
Aber es gibt kein User Interface für eine Rechtschreibkorrektur.
Und was haben die da jetzt rausgefunden?
Ich hab's noch nicht... Ich sehe hier den Artikel.
Wir reden jetzt wieder über Sachen, die wir gerade das erste Mal irgendwo jetzt im Internet entdecken, ohne wirklich zu wissen, worum es geht. Weil es für so was...
File Upload in Safari geht. Endlich.
File Upload. Und wo kommt das File dann her?
Wahrscheinlich aus deinem Fotoalbum oder aus deinem... Oder ist es eine...
Dass ich so ein Bild hochladen kann?
Dass man ein Bild hochladen kann.
Im Simulator haben die das freigeschaltet.
Das haben sie im Simulator freigeschaltet.
Im neuen 3.2 Xcode. Verstehe.
Sie haben es gefunden.
Gefunden, ja.
Nee, es ist... Also sie haben hier das...
Sie meinen es 3.2...
Sie haben hier das Settings Pane, was wenn man sich mal anguckt...
Das ist ja jetzt das iPad, nicht iPhone.
Das ist das iPad Settings Pane, was ja, wenn man sich das mal auf ein Simulator, wovon wir alle schon Screenshots gesehen haben anguckt, total mager aussieht und quasi keinerlei Einstellungen anbietet.
Die Developer kriegen ja alle den iPad Simulator.
Ja genau, aber der sieht ja total... Der hat ja all diese Funktionen nicht, die die hier freigeschaltet haben. Und sie haben es offensichtlich irgendwo geschafft, ein paar Dinger zu setzen und jetzt hat er die.
Was cool ist, ist, dass der Simulator an diesem neuen Xcode Beta, wo ich eigentlich gar nicht drüber reden kann, aber ich glaube, das ist überall schon gepostet, der kann jetzt auch endlich im Simulator auch deine Positionen bestimmen. Also übernimmt die Position des Rechners, das hatte der vorher immer nicht.
Haben sie quasi an die Core-Location-Funktion angeschlossen? Ah, sehr gut. Das habe ich neulich das erste Mal gesehen, wie Core-Location auf dem Mac aussieht. Also eine Applikation, die das genutzt hat, und wo dann tatsächlich wie auf dem iPhone diese Abfrage kam so, das Programm möchte gerne ihre Position ermitteln, wollen sie das wirklich weitergeben? FoursquareX, also so ein Foursquare-Klient.
Was ist denn Foursquare?
Foursquare ist ein Programm, dessen Sinn ich noch nicht so richtig verstanden habe, wo man angeben kann, in welcher Kneipe man gerade rum sitzt.
Da kannst du Bürgermeister werden.
Und da kannst du Bürgermeister von Kneipen werden, oder von irgendwelchen Locations, und alle deine Freunde erfahren, wo du dich gerade aufhältst. Und ich hab noch keinen so richtig guten Anwendungsfall dafür gefunden, aber ich hab halt, es gibt dafür einen Mac client, der ist so relativ hübsch auf den ersten Blick, und der nutzt offensichtlich Call Location und fragt dann die Position ab.
Jedenfalls zu diesem Simulator. Das werden natürlich alle iPhone-Programmierer, diesen iPad-Simulator an diesem Xcode benutzen, um ihre Programme da anzupassen, und in zwei Monaten wird's da hageln an iPhone-App-Updates für iPad in Billish. Und dann dauert's eine Weile, bis sie dann auch wirklich schick sind. Aber das ist erstmal halt nicht nur diesen X2. Genau, was ich noch richtig schlecht finde, also Apple ist erstmal ganz schön peinlich, dieser Doppelvergrößern-Button für die Standard-iPhone-Apps, wo man halt wirklich gar nichts gemacht hat. Ich dachte, dass sie ja für ihre eigenen Table-Views und so, dass sie wenigstens den Font dann schon auch in Wissen, dass sie den Doppelsogroßen nehmen und den Anzeigen, aber nee, es ist wirklich pixelverdoppelt und sonst nix. Zumindest im Simulator.
Damit hab ich eigentlich auch gerechnet, oder?
Ich dachte, dass sie so ein bisschen resolution-independent sind. Natürlich wissen sie, sie machen jetzt ihr eigenes Table-View doppelt so groß, dass sie dann auch gleich den richtigen Font da reinballern.
Aber dann müssen sie es doch gleich mit allen Elementen machen und dann geht es wahrscheinlich in die Hose, weil die Programme eben Annahmen darüber haben. Also ich denke...
Also erst mal hast du einen wesentlich höheren Aufwand und zur zweiten wollen sie auch einen Anreiz schaffen für die Entwickler, dass sie eine iPad-Version rausbringen.
Genau, das denke ich auch.
Und darum soll das gehen, aber so scheiße wie möglich aussehen.
Eine Kurzeile, also es ist wirklich gar nicht schwer, das so zu machen. Eine Kurzeile, dass dein Programm erst mal weiß, dass der Bildschirm-Inhalt größer ist und wenn du sonst mit Standard-Interface-Elements arbeitest, wie halt diesen Table-View, du sagst ja im Table-View nicht, wie groß es ist, sondern es ist ja immer so groß wie das iPhone. Und ab dann ist das Table-View plötzlich so breit wie das ganze iPad und zack, das war's.
Also ich nehme an, wenn man sich auf Drehung relativ gut vorbereitet hat, dann hat man schon mal eine Grundvorbereitung aufs iPad.
Selbst wenn nicht.
Also wie gesagt, Table-Views, kein Ding.
Na ja, aber man will ja schon. Man hat nicht nur Table-Views.
Jetzt ist wirklich mal Ende mit iPad, ja? Da habe ich noch eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Guck, wie gut ich mich noch dran erinnere. Ich war auf einem Apple-Education-Workshop, da bin ich so eingeladen worden. Da ging es um diesen Podcast-Producer. Genau, dass ich da hinfahren wollen würde. Das wusste ich ja vorher auch nicht. Deswegen konnte ich es ja gar nicht so richtig erzählen. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob du mich gefragt hast, aber das ist halt ein Teil von Mac OS X Server. Das gibt es seit 10.05 und bei 10.06 hat das auch noch mal eine Überarbeitung erfahren. Und das ist halt ein System, was einem ja, das Produzieren von Podcasts abnehmen, naja abnehmen ist ein bisschen übertrieben, sondern erleichtern soll. Also Streamline automatisieren soll.
Die Arbeit, die wir jetzt gerade machen oder sozusagen die Nachbearbeitung von den Audiodaten, die man dann schon hat?
Genau.
Was ist denn die Nachbearbeitung?
Na ja, der komplette Prozess des Aufnehmens bis hin zum Enkoden, Taggen, Feed erstellen. Das ist im Wesentlichen das, was der Podcast Producer so macht. Und du machst das halt übers Netz. Das heißt, da läuft halt Software auf dem Mac OS X Server. Und das ist jetzt auch alles so schwer nicht einzurichten. Du hast da so eine Applikation, die heißt Podcast Composer. Und da stellst du dir deine Workflows zusammen. Du hast so ein paar Default Workflows. Und dann kannst du halt sagen, das ist irgendwie ein Video, das ist ein Audio Podcast. Und man merkt aber auch gleich, dass das alles auf Video Podcasts hin optimiert ist. Ich hab natürlich dann gleich mir Workflows mit Audio Podcasts angelegt und hab dann irgendwie die Software komplett in den Ruin geschickt. Also ich hab verschiedene Verfahren gefunden, wie ich diesen Workflow komplett aus der Spur bringen kann, dass er irgendwie mittendrin abbrach oder irgendwie einfach die ganzen Audio-Bestandteile nicht richtig zusammengeklebt hat. Bei Video funktioniert ja das alles weitgehend. Das Ding ist halt, du kannst dich halt auf deinem Mac in so einem Netz, kannst da halt so eine Applikation starten, die ist ja auch serienmäßig bei Mac OS X mit dabei. Podcast Capture heißt die. Bloß wenn du die halt so startest, dann fragt die halt erstmal nach dem Server und wenn du keine hast, dann kommst du da nicht weiter. Und du kannst das dann halt so launchen und sagen, hier die Kamera hätte ich gerne und dieses Mikrofon. Kannst halt einfach mit der eingebauten rumtesten. Aber im Idealfall möchtest du natürlich eine externe Kamera haben. Ich sag gleich mal vorher vorweg, wofür das eigentlich gedacht ist. Wofür es auch wirklich gemacht ist und wofür es auch ganz gut funktioniert. Deswegen wird es ja auch von dieser Education-Abteilung von Apple präsentiert. Das ist im Wesentlichen zum Mitschneiden von Vorträgen. Du hast halt dieses Problem an der Uni, du machst halt irgendwelche Vorträge und du willst sie irgendwie podcasten. Aber diesen Workflow zu automatisieren, das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll und sehr wertvoll, weil du natürlich niemals die Leute hast, die da wirklich jetzt viel Zeit drauf schmeißen wollen. Also versuchen sie das Konzept so zu machen, du hast auf dem Server diesen Workflow definiert. Du startest auf dem Client deinen Podcast-Capture, wählst deinen Workflow aus. Beziehungsweise das machst du erst später, aber du nimmst halt auf und dann sagst du irgendwie hier bitte mit diesem Workflow das weiter bearbeiten. Dann ist deine Sache fertig, dann geht die komplette Aufzeichnung. Also erst mal wird es lokal aufgenommen. Und in dem Moment, wo du fertig bist und sagst so und jetzt bitte diesen Workflow sowieso starten, überträgt er das zu dem Server. Der nimmt halt diesen ganzen Video- und Bildschirmstrom und dann kannst du eben so verschiedene Sachen machen. Erst mal kannst du so einen Trailer davor packen. Du kannst so Metadata anzeigen, also so einen Titelgenerator. Kannst du auch während deiner Sendung noch so irgendwie als Fließband durchlaufen lassen. Da gibt es so verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Und am Schluss halt noch mal so einen Ausklang, sozusagen so ein After-Trailer, Closing-Sequenz. Und du kannst dann eben auch noch mit verschiedenen Videoeffekten sagen, wie diese einzelnen Komponenten ineinander übergehen. Aber das ist im Prinzip das Konzept, so ein Opener, so eine Menüanzeige, was kommt jetzt, dann der eigentliche Content und dann noch mal der Abschluss. So, und danach kannst du sagen, in was das eben konvertiert werden soll. Du kannst verschiedene Keywords angeben und Metadaten. Und dann rechnet der dir das halt durch. Das heißt, du machst auf deinem Client eigentlich nichts anderes mehr, als zu sagen, hier bitte einmal aufnehmen. Dann geht das dahin und dann erzeugt er Feeds. Bei Default Atom Feeds kannst du aber auch RSS Feeds haben. Und das heißt, im Prinzip rechnet der dir das alles um, macht das Ganze in Coding. Das kannst du so mit den Build-In Tools machen, wenn du aber dir halt auch noch hier Logic oder Final Cut Studio oder sowas gekauft hast, dann hast du ja auch diesen Kompressor dabei. Dann kannst du eben auch direkt den Kompressor aktivieren. Aber du kannst auch von Out of the Box schon dieses Cluster Tool, diesen Q-Master von Apple verwenden, also mit X-Grid sozusagen. Wenn du also mehrere Rechner hast, kannst du mehrere Rechner dran mit rumrechnen lassen, sodass es dann eben auch schneller geht. Und am Ende sind dann diese fertig encodeten Video-Dateien in den gewünschten Formaten. Also halt üblicherweise so was weiß ich, iPhone, Apple TV usw. Kennst du ja diesen ganzen Schnas. Das liegt dann halt einfach da auf der Platte rum und er erzeugt dafür Feeds. Und dann ist fertig. Das heißt, er macht nichts mehr, als alles zusammenzubauen, Trailer und so weiter davor zu machen, Videoübergänge, das in die richtige Größe zusammenzubauen. Und dann legt er das an irgendeine Stelle hin und aktualisiert einen Podcast-Feed. Wenn du das also dann weiter verwenden willst, wenn du das also wirklich in deine Webseite bringen möchtest, dann musst du dir noch Glucode bauen, der diese Feeds dann sozusagen befragt und feststellt, ah, da ist ja was Neues, sich dann diese Dateien zieht, die da hinlegt, wo du sie haben willst und so weiter. Du könntest theoretisch auch direkt von deinem Server natürlich das nach außen geben, aber das ist eigentlich ja in seltensten Fällen so das Ding. Soweit ist die Theorie und das klappt auch praktisch irgendwie ganz gut, aber es hat halt so seine Haken. Haken eins ist halt, wenn irgendwas schief geht, gibt es relativ schlechte Debugging-Möglichkeiten. Also der ist dann da irgendwo verreckt.
Also wieder so ein spezielles Tool, wie es bei Apples üblich ist, so wie mit dem OSTen Server auch. Das ist alles prima, solange man auf dem Fahrt bleibt. Das ist ein bisschen rotkäppchenmäßig. Muss nicht vom Fahrt abkommen, sonst kommt der böse Wolf.
Genau. Und dann kommt der böse Wolf auch gleich aus einer Art und Weise, dass er nicht mehr weiß, wie die wieder aus dem Haus rauskriegt. Das war wieder so ein klassisches Ding, wo ich dann auch gleich wieder so ein bisschen mit dem Kopf schütteln musste. Also, obwohl das eigentlich ganz nett war und so vom Workflow her alles sehr einfach zu machen ist und wenn du das einmal aufgesetzt hast, dann funktioniert das meistens auch. Aber das ist, also mit Audio hat es überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Ich habe natürlich dann gleich erst mal Audio-Trailer und Audio-Abspann gemacht. Und es gibt auch die Möglichkeit einzustellen, ist alles nur Audio. Aber es hat dann nicht funktioniert. Also, er hat mir anstatt den Opener, den Inhalt und die Closing-Sequenz zu machen, kam am Ende zweimal die Closing-Sequenz hintereinander. So, und es gab dann keinerlei Erkenntnisse darüber, was da jetzt schief gegangen ist. Du kannst dir zwar irgendwie Lockfiles anschauen und dann auch relativ ihnen so einen Modus bringen, wo er dann wirklich jeden einzelnen Schritt, den er so durchführt, so lockt. Plus gab es dann vor Ort, also auch jetzt mit dem relativ gut, das Produkt kennenden Menschen da von Apple, der da hingeschickt wurde, um das alles zu erklären, der hatte halt auch so schnell keine Antwort. Bisher habe ich auch keine Erklärungen nachhinein bekommen. Weiß nicht, wie viel Zeit er dafür hat, das mal zu checken. Er wollte sich das nochmal anschauen. Aber es ist eben genau wie du sagst. Das ist das große Problem von Mac OS 10 Server ist, dass das alles gut gemeint. Und die Tools sind auch eigentlich wunderbar. Und solange sie funktionieren, ist es ganz großartig. Aber sobald du irgendwie mal vom Weg abkommst, dann bist du auch gleich auf eine Art und Weise verloren, die das Gefühl habt, eigentlich die Sachen nicht wirklich im Griff zu haben.
Das ist echt blöd. Meinst du, wir würden das Gleiche von diesem OS sagen, wenn sie irgendwie... Also dem hier, dem OS 10, wenn wir keine Shell unten drunter hätten. Also angenommen Next Step wären Systemen gewesen mit den Frameworks und Cocoa und alles, aber sie hätten halt keine Unix Grundlage genommen. Meinst du, wir würden dann auch sagen, also vielleicht hätten wir dann gar keine, dass wir sagen würden, naja, das ist alles ganz toll, solange man halt nur die Standardsachen benutzt, die Apple so hat, aber wenn es schief geht, kann man ja nichts machen hier auf diesen Ding, weil das wär ja dann auch so ein S geworden, oder?
Na gut, beim Server hast du ja dann die Shell. Und die brauchst du da auch. Also es war auch sehr interessant, also für die Anpassungen zum Beispiel, die das System so vorsieht, bestimmte Sachen, wenn du, was weiß ich, also Beispiele demonstriert, wenn du deine Feeds da weiter aufsplitten willst nach Keywordern und so weiter und so Combo-Feeds erzeugen möchtest und so was, dann musst du quasi auf der Kommandozeile ein paar Tools benutzen, so. Das war dann auch schon so ein bisschen scary, weil er meinte, ja, er hätte dann halt mal ein bisschen rumgeforscht und dann das so entdeckt und so. Also man merkte, dass er das nicht so aus der offiziellen Apple-Dokumentation entnommen hat, sondern er hat einfach selber so lange rumgeforscht, um da noch ein bisschen flexibler zu sein und hat dann den etwas überforderten Leuten da auch gleich irgendwie Kommandozeilen Aufgaben gegeben und so weiter. Bauer eine Kommandozeile, die das und das macht und da rollten schon einige Leute mit den Augen. Es waren halt alles so Leute von Unis, die da waren. Ich war eigentlich der Einzige, der da wirklich podcastet. Und die Anforderung, halt nur Audio zu machen, das hat alle verwirrt. Wie? Kein Bild. Ich bin Last Century?
Na, kein Bild.
Was hat denn das mit dem Century zu tun?
Stimmt, das ist schon Millennium inzwischen.
Nein, auch im letzten Millennium gab es schon ein Bild.
Du hast immer noch keins.
Das ist doch kein Fortschritt-Bild.
Sicher? Also die ganzen User mussten jetzt hier so ein Foto von deinem coolen iPad sehen. Und haben es gar nicht so richtig mit drehen und alles betrachten können, wie wir jetzt hier so Landscape wechseln und sowas.
Können wir mal in der Webcam noch hinpacken. Ich bin übrigens sowieso aufgefordert worden, heimliches Spy-Pics von deinem Studio zu machen. Vielleicht solltest du das mal lieber selber machen demnächst mal. Ein paar Spy-Pics liegen.
Ich werde hier mein Studio ausreichend dokumentieren, wenn es fertig ist.
Das ist doch nie fertig. Seit wann ist denn bei dir was fertig?
Naja, es gibt halt noch einen Schritt, den ich hier vollziehen möchte und dann ist das Ganze...
Und der wäre?
Na, hier muss halt noch der Tisch reinkommen.
Ach ja, stimmt, da hat es ja noch diesen Special-Auftrag.
Das bedeutet, dass hier auch alles nochmal umgebaut wird.
Und dein Plan?
Also, technisch bin ich jetzt relativ gut dabei.
War es nicht irgendwie, du wolltest deinen riesen iMac, wolltest du den nicht irgendwie an die Wand kleben?
Ja, ich will mir noch eigentlich noch einen zweiten holen.
Ach so, und der kommt dann an die Wand. Und der ist auch genauso groß wie der, oder wie? Und auch mit CoreFed Power++?
Das bin ich mir halt noch nicht ganz so sicher.
Ob der an der Wand auch so viel Power braucht?
Ja, braucht er wahrscheinlich nicht. Andererseits finde ich den Aufpreis für schnelle Modelle sind auch nicht so groß.
Also ist die Frage, ob das der Ort ist? Wie viel kostet der mehr? Weil wenn man schon so eine Riesensumme ausgibt, dann fallen die 100 Euro oder 200 auch nicht mehr auf.
Wo fängt der jetzt an, der normale iMac? Ach man, ich hab das jetzt im Einzelnen nicht so im Kopp. Das ist nicht so wichtig. Nicht so wichtig, ne? Ich bin einfach noch nicht so weit, weil es hängt dann auch mit an dem Tisch, weil das hängt davon ab, wie groß der Tisch ist, wohin das Ding direkt dann kommt an der Wand. Weil wenn es an der Wand ist, dann hängt da auch fest. Bzw. ich schau halt auch noch, ob es irgendwelche Möglichkeiten gibt, da so eine Schiene zu machen. Weiß ich nicht, ob ich das wirklich tun sollte. Aber eigentlich will ich den einen Ort finden, wo er hinkommt. Und dann muss man auch so einen Arm bauen und so. Also das kommt alles noch. Erstmal muss dieser Tisch konzipiert werden. Und da gibt es noch viele Fragen zu beantworten. Jetzt guck ich trotzdem nochmal hier. Jetzt bin ich im falschen Stor. So, wir sind jetzt die Themen offiziell ausgegangen. Wir haben auch schon fast drei Stunden wieder.
Wirklich? Bist aber nicht extra später gekommen.
Der kleinste iMac 27 Zoll kostet 1500. Und der Quad-Core kostet halt 300 Euro mehr. Da könnte man eigentlich auch. Tja, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht nehme ich den kleinen.
Ja, waren wir jetzt mal so, ich schnapp jetzt auch langsam.
Du schläfst jetzt ein? Jetzt schon? Ja, da schlägt einer vor, ich soll mir doch einen 30 Zoll mit Mac Mini kaufen. Das ist bloß teurer als ein iMac.
Ja klar, ist aber auch ein 30 Zoll, obwohl die Auflösung ist die gleiche.
Ja, geringfügig höher.
Ach so, wegen dem 16 zu 10.
Ja, nee, der iMac. Und dann muss ich den Mac Mini ja noch irgendwo rumstehen haben.
Aber er hat wirklich ein größeres Bild, was für die Wand ja ein bisschen cooler ist, weil kann man es noch besser sehen.
Ja, das macht jetzt aber so viel auch nicht aus. Der hier ist doch eigentlich wunderbar zu entdecken.
Ja, aber das an der Wand ist ja schon nochmal wieder einen halben Meter weiter weg.
Ja gut, aber ich muss da am Ende auch einfach mal den Font so groß machen, bis man ihn wirklich gut entdecken kann. Und ein paar Pixel mehr bringen mir dann auch nichts.
Man kann nicht alle Fonts größer machen. Kriegen sie ja bis heute nicht hin.
Was? Wie?
Von den Menüs und so bei Apfel?
Darum geht es mir nicht, aber so Webseiten und keine Ahnung, Chatprogramme und so. Ich arbeite dran und ansonsten bin ich hier mittlerweile sehr glücklich und zufrieden und das geht hier alles ganz gut zusammen. Ich habe hier auch die Quelle meiner Soundstörungen gefunden. Das ist nämlich die AirPod Express gewesen. Die ist extrem anfällig für Schaltströme auf dem Strom und gibt das sehr gerne auf den analogen Audio-Port raus.
Da gibt es ja so eine ganz einfache Sache, mit der man das fixen kann.
Ja, einfach optische Eingänge benutzen. Hab ich aber an meinem...
Fandes Ding noch.
Welches Ding? Ja, kann es ausgeben, aber da muss ja auch erstmal einen SPDIF-Eingang haben, einen optischen.
Gibt es da auch Adapter und so einen Schneegnack, oder?
Da gibt es nicht so viele, wie man vielleicht gerne hätte.
Eben gerade hat es kurz geknackt.
Bitte?
Ja, ja, weil das ist nämlich auch gerade angeschaltet. Das kann sehr gut sein, dass das jetzt eben der Effekt war. Weil ich habe das hier im Hintergrund nämlich noch an. Jetzt kann ich das mal ausmachen, jetzt wird es nicht mehr knacken. Also im Prinzip habe ich es im Griff. Jetzt muss ich halt nur mal gucken, ob ich die eigentlich noch verwenden will an der Stelle. Und wenn ja, dann werde ich mir da eher noch einen Weg finden, wie ich das Ding halt optisch einspielen lasse. Aber ich habe halt an meinem Mischpult so keine optischen Eingänge. Und es gibt auf dem Markt einfach kein Gerät, was einfach mal acht optische SPDIF-Eingänge hat, die es nach irgendwas sinnvolles wandelt. So habe ich einfach noch nichts gefunden. Gut, dann haben wir es, wa?
Ja, und über DSL-Erfahrungen erzähle ich beim nächsten Mal.
Das ist auch heute drei Stunden, ist aber genug.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage.
Tabletsendung gewesen.
Die zweite Tabletsendung.
Diesmal die nicht ganz so spekulative. Wobei wir haben es irgendwie geschafft, doch relativ viel herum zu spekulieren, obwohl das Gerät jetzt theoretisch da ist.
Eigentlich ist nichts klar. Nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Wir werden das alles sehen in der Zukunft, die ist sowieso mal interessant.
Außer dass wir es alle kaufen.
Dann sagen wir jetzt erstmal ganz artig und brav Tschüss. Und ja, ich kann ja jetzt auch mal wieder auf wenn ich die AirTunes-Teile schon angeschlossen habe, dann kann ich ja auch wieder auf leise Musik schalten. Und bis bald und Tschüss bei Mobile Max.
Oh Gott, mit Hintergrundmusik. Die Glückwunschantenne.
So ist das hier alles ganz modern.